THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING A
SENSUAL HEARING AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES AS
WE COMPLY WITH THESE ORDERS
WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN DEBATE REMOTELY WITH THE USE
OF VIDEO CONFERENCING SYSTEMS.
FOR MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY
HOWEVER PLEASE A MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS ARE I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL MUTE AND UNMUTE
THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH
TO SPEAK AND WE DID A LITTLE
PRACTICE ON HAND RAISING- WITH
SENATOR BORCHERS WHO WILL IN
FACT BE ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY. BY WERE MUTING AND THEN
ALLOWING ON MUTING TO BE DONE
BY OUR T. PEOPLE IT WILL
ELIMINATE ANY ACOUSTIC OR WE
HOPE IT WILL ELIMINATE ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK SO I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION. YOU USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. AND ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND BILL NUMBER TWO WHICH YOU
ARE REFERRING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR HEARING WE
HAVE ADMITTED TO A MEMBERS. OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AN ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
SO IT'S ON THE SCREEN PLEASE
MAKE NOTE THAT THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS HASH TAG ONE. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE AND I WILL
REPEAT THAT THE NUMBER IS NOT
HASH TAG HERE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE- COULD SOMEONE FROM I. T.
ASSURE ME THAT THEY YOU EITHER
YOU NEED TO USE THE HASHTAG OR
YOU DO NOT. WHEN YOU CALL IN I
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE WHO
HAS- WANTS TO CUT YOU DO NOT
HAVE TO USE THE HASHTAG. AND
HAVE. ALL RIGHT SO. LET ME
CORRECT. THAT THAT SIMPLY. CALL
IN THE NUMBER. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX. FOUR
FOUR FOUR ONE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. NINE TWO SIX TWO SIX
SEVEN FOUR AGAIN THE ACCESS
CODE. NINE TWO SIX TWO SIX
SEVEN FOUR. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
AND OPEN YOUR LINE. AT THAT
TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUCH MUTE THE
DEVICE ON WHICH YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. I GUARANTEE YOU THAT
WILL NOT BE CUSTOMARY TODAY WE
ARE WORKING REMOTELY WE HAVE
HAD A NUMBER OF HEARINGS THEY
DO WORK THEY ARE JUST
DIFFERENT. SO PLEASE BE PATIENT
WITH ALL OF US AS WE TRY TO DO
THE PEOPLE'S WORK. DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME SO THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE USE OF
NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN BE
HEARD WITH THAT SAID. WE WILL
BEGIN OUR HEARING WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
SIX OF WHICH ARE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION OF THE BILLS LET
US ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY OF PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AT THE SENATORS PLEASE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONE ON.
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE DID
ASAL HERE IT OUT SO HERE
GONZALEZ HERE GONZALEZ HERE
JONES- JONES HERE MORNING HERE.
MONNING HERE STERN YOUR STERN
HERE ON BURKE. WHY CAL SKI HERE
WHY CASKEY HERE. ALL RIGHT A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISH I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE NOTE
THAT WE WILL HAVE SENATOR
PORCHES ON THE LINE BUT
PURSUANT TO OUR RULES HE IS NOT
ABLE TO VOTE BECAUSE HE IS NOT
PHYSICALLY PRESENT BUT HE WILL
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
DISCUSSION. HE CHOSE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO VOTE SO NOW LET'S
TURN TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE IS SIX BILLS ON THE
PROPOSED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS FILE ITEM
SEVEN AS BE TEN OH THREE BY
SENATOR JONES FILE ITEM NINE SB
ELEVEN OH FIVE BY SENATOR
UMBERG FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG WITH AMENDMENTS. ON
PAGES SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE OF
THE ANALYSIS FILE ITEM TWELVE
SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR JONES WITH AN AMENDMENT
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS
AND FILE SHE'S BEEN FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN IS BE THIRTEEN OH FIVE
BY SENATOR ROTH. AND FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
THE- JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BILL
MOVIE CONSENT CALPERS A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
Y. KOWSKI MEMBERS FROM BOND.
AND I'M SORRY. JACKSON BUY
BACKS IN I DID ALSO A DURACELL
I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I JONES
HI JONES HI MONNING AYE MONNING
AYE STERN. STERN I ON BURKE Y.
CALLES GAME I Y. CASKEY I WENT
ALL RIGHT WE WILL WE HAVE SIX
VOTES AND LEAVE IT SEVEN VOTES
AND WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR SENATOR UMBERG WHO I
BELIEVE WILL BE A LITTLE LATE
IN ARRIVING TODAY. SO NOW WE'VE
BEEN HERE OUR FIRST BILL
SENATOR PAN ON SB EIGHT NINETY-
THIS IS FOR PRESENTATION ONLY
THERE WILL NOT BE VOTE TAKEN ON
THIS BILL. AND SENATOR- YOU ARE.
PRESENTING THIS WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING APPRECIATE YOUR
CAN HEAR EFFORTS HERE THIS A
FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUE AND I
THINK THE ANALYSIS IT DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB IDENTIFYING THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN TODAY'S
WORLD ON THIS TOPIC- BUT
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK ON IT
AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CHAIR JACKSON AND SENATORS
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB EIGHT
NINETY A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA WEBSITES
REMOVE PHOTOGRAPHS OR VIDEO
RECORDINGS OF A CRIME POSTED BY
THE PERPETRATOR. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE CRIME VICTIM OF THE
FAMILY WHO- WAS THE TICKET IN
THE CONTENT AND THAT THEY WOULD
BE REMOVED WITHIN TWO HOURS AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK SENATE
JACKSON TO DO JUST FOR YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL. I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL BECAUSE I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT VICTIMS OF
THE SALT BEING RE VICTIMIZED BY
PUBLICATIONS OF IMAGES OR
VIDEOS OF THEIR ASSAULT BY THE
PERPETRATOR THEMSELVES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. FOR EXAMPLE ON
MARCH TWENTY TEN TWENTY
NINETEEN. ONE CHURCH MEETING
WHAT FIFTY PEOPLE DEAD WHICH
WAS LIVES. ON SOCIAL MEDIA AS
IT HAPPENED BY THE PERPETRATOR
OF THE CRIME OVER TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE WATCHED A LIVE VIDEO
PLATFORM BY SOCIAL MEDIA. AND
HERE IN SACRAMENTO A LEADING
ANTI BAXTER PHYSICALLY
ASSAULTED ME ON A PUBLIC STREET
AND LYFT AND IT. THIS ASSAULT
ON SOCIAL MEDIA TO THE
ADULATION OF HIS FOLLOWERS. AND
SO THE SIX OF THIS VIDEO COULD
INCITE FURTHER ATTACKS ON LATE
LEADERS IN FACT ONLY IF YOU
LATER ANOTHER ACTIVE. THAT ONTO
THE FLOOR LET'S CITY FOR. THE
BILL DOOR BY THE- SLEEVE CAUGHT
BECAUSE RATE HEY SAID IN THEN
CROP AGAINST ASIANS ISLAND HAVE
STE. DURING COVER NINETEENTH.
INCLUDING VIDEOS OF VIOLENT THE-
ASIANS. PACIFIC ISLANDERS ON SO
MEDIA. IN FACT THE NEWLY
LAUNCHED A HATE INCIDENT
TRACTOR STOP AT I HATE WHICH IS
CREATED BY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY I FOCUS
NONPROFIT GROUPS HAS RECEIVED
MORE THAN ELEVEN HUNDRED
REPORTS. OF CORONAVIRUS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS IN JUST TWO WEEKS.
FORTUNATELY MANY OF THESE
RACIST HATEFUL ACTS ARE
RECORDED AND STREAMED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. ON FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MINUTES SAN
FRANCISCO RECORDED THEMSELVES.
THEY RECORD THEMSELVES STRIKING
AN ELDERLY ASIAN MAN WITH A
METAL POLE. THIS VIDEO IS
POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND WENT
VIRAL. AND IN THE VIDEO AT
LEAST ONE PERSON TO BE SAID
SAYING I HATE ASIANS. THESE ARE
JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF HOW
SOCIAL MEDIA WEBSITES HAVE
PLATFORM TROUBLING CONTENT
PUBLICIZING VIOLENCE ACROSS
PLATFORMS. WHICH IT FURTHER
TRAUMATIZED VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIMES. THE BILL SEEKS TO DENY
PERPETRATORS OF VIOLENCE FROM
BENEFITING FROM THEIR OWN
VIOLENT ACTS AT THE EXPENSE OF
THE VICTIMS. HOWEVER AS WE
WORKED WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
TO ADDRESS THE FIRST AMENDMENT
ISSUES WE RECOGNIZE WE WOULD
NOT HAVE THE TIME TO CRAFT A
SOLUTION THAT MET
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER. I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL IS NOT TO
PREVENT ANYONE EVEN
PERPETRATORS OF ASSAULT FROM
EXPRESSING THEIR OWN VIEWS. ARE
EVEN POSTING ABOUT COMMITTING
CRIMINAL ACTS. THIS BILL WAS
SEEKING TO REGULATE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES FROM
DISSEMINATING IMAGES ARE
PLATFORMING IMAGES OF CRIMINAL
VIOLENCE TO OTHER PEOPLE ON THE
PLATFORM WHICH COULD ALSO
INCLUDE. THE ASSAULT VICTIM AND
HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS. THE
BILL REQUIRES SOCIAL MEDIA
SITES REMOVED VIDEOS POPE
POSTED BY THE PERPETRATORS
THEMSELVES NOT VIDEOS THAT WERE
POSTED BY NEWS MEDIA SITES ARE
ACTUALLY ANY OTHER PERSON WHO
MAY HAVE A COPY OF THE VIDEO
TAKEN AROUND VIDEO. I DO WANT
TO THANK THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION AND SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TYPICALLY TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK WHO HAVE OPENED A
DIALOGUE WITH ME ABOUT THE
SIMULATION OF VIOLENCE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THE INTERNET. AND
I URGE SOCIAL MEDIA SITES TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER ALONG
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO COMBAT
HATE. AND DEVELOP A BETTER
RESPONSE MORE EXPEDITIOUSLY
REMOVED VIOLENT LIVE STREAM
VIDEOS POSTED BY CRIME
PERPETRATORS OF VICTIMS CAN BE
PROTECTED FROM FUTURE HARM. I
LOOK FOR TO BRING LEGISLATION
NEXT YEAR TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WHEN WE HAVE MORE TIME TO THAT
THE COMPLEX ISSUES INVOLVED. SO
AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE FROM THE CHAIR THAT SB
EIGHT NINETY BE HOLDING
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OF THOSE THAT
REALLY WANT TO THANK AGAIN THE
CHAIR. ALLOW ME TO THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO STILL PRESENT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PENN AND THIS IS INDEED
A VERY TROUBLING ISSUE WE ARE
WE HAS LEARNED THAT. A PERSON
WHO VIDEO TO THE MURDER OF A
YOUNG BLACK MAN. IS A LIVE TO
BEEN COMPLICIT IN THE ACTUAL
CRIME ITSELF- WE CLEARLY HAVE
GOT TO GET A BETTER HANDLE ON
THIS. ISSUE BUT WE KNOW THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS A REVERED.
ATTENTION OF AND FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE OF OUR DEMOCRACY SO I
APPRECIATE. YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
DEFER THIS I HOPE THE
DISCUSSION WILL CONTINUE OUR
NEXT YEAR- BECAUSE THIS REALLY
IS A VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD AND WITH
THAT. I WILL NOW MOVE TO ANYONE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
I'D LIKE TO CAUTION YOU THAT
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
THE NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
ACCORDINGLY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES OF ACTUAL TESTIMONY I
DON'T CARE HOW IT'S DIVIDED BUT
AT THE END OF THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY WILL BE TERMINATED.
ALL OTHERS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
AT THAT POINT WE'LL HAVE TO
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE MEASURE SO-
NOW- LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE'S-
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. AND MADAM CHAIR I HAVE
NO FORMAL WITNESSES- TO TAKE UP
THE TIME THIS COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SENATOR SO WITH
THAT- WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE OVER
AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO WE
DON'T NEED TO GO THERE- TO WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELEPHONE. TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT NINETY WE WILL BEGIN.
CERTAINLY CHAIRPERSON JACKSON
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE BEEN. AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBER AND FOR THEIR
INSTRUCTOR. IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE WE ASK YOU PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. PLEASE
ALLOW FEW MOMENTS FIRST
TOGETHER MY NUMBERS AND
MODERNIST MODERATOR WOULD YOU
GIVE THAT NUMBER AGAIN PLEASE.
YES SUCH ONE THEN IS ZERO. TO
PUT YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU INWILL WAIT TO A FEW
SECONDS TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN FACT ON
THE PHONE. WITH THAT MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I AM NOT SHOWING
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT.
THE LET US CONTINUE THEN- IS
THERE ANYONE OF PRESIDENT WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. SEEING NONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IS
THERE- THERE'S NONE IN TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE INVITE THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
QUEUE UP ON THE LINE. CERTAINLY
ONCE AGAIN IFYOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP THIS TIME IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ACTUALLY HAVE A FEW
THAT ARE TEARING UP PLEASE
ALLOW SECURE MOMENTS TO GIVE OF
MARYLAND NUMBERS. PUBLISHED
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE GIVE
US. THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INDICATED THEIR WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT NINETY. I DO HAVE THREE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT IN WITH
LINE NUMBER SIXTY ONE THAT DICK
IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
SIXTY ONE OF YOUR CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR SELF MUTE WE ARE NOT
HEARING ANY AUDIO. PART LET'S
MOVE ON MR LOTTERY NINE WILL.
IT WILL MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS BRITNEY BAR
SAUDI WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT NINETY
AB ONE TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BEING WILLING TO
WORK ON ON LANGUAGE WITH US SO
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND SIXTY
WILL YOU CHECK YOUR LINE YOU
MAY BE IN YOUR. ALL RIGHT-
MISTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU SEE
IF THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AND LET US ENCOURAGE
THOSE. TWO WHO. DID LINE UP. TO
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE. USING THE RIGHT BUTTONS IN
ORDER TO BE HEARD. CERTAINLY
AND ONCE AGAIN AS A REMINDER TO
KEEP UP IT IS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. AT THIS TIME IT IS
FROM LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX LINE
SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HI I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. COULD YOU GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
SURE MY NAME IS THOMAS MONAGHAN
OF THE LANDLORD IN SAN
FRANCISCO. I THINK YOU MAY BE
ON THE WRONG BILL THIS IS SB.
EIGHT NINETY BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
MISTER MODERATOR WHO ARE IN
LINE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. NOT AT THIS TIME
CHAIRPERSON THANK YOU. SO THANK
YOU TO THOSE WHO TESTIFIED IN
THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I DID NOTE THAT
SENATOR BORCHERS HAS HIS HAND
UP WILL CALL ON HIM FIRST AND
THEN GO TO SENATOR MONEY.
CENTER BOARD JUST GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU ARE. IT
JUST MUTED YOUR PHONE JUST THE
I THINK THE BEST THING TO DO IS
LAY OFF IT I THINK THE I. T.
PEOPLE HERE WILL LINK YOU WIN.
ARE YOU CAN ARE YOU THERE YOUR
ME NOW YES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I JUST WANTED TO SOME
CLARIFICATION MAYBE ALL FOR
EIGHTY- RECOMMENDATION FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE BY THE
AUTHOR- I'M LOOKING AT.
SEARCHING TO ON LINES THIRTY
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT OF THE BILL
THAT DEFINES VICTIM. CANON
IDENTIFIES THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
BE A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT FOUND
TO HAVE SUSTAINED PHYSICAL OR
FINANCIAL AND PERSONAL PROPERTY
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU ARE THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL- IS AS YOU
REVISIT THIS ISSUE AND RESUBMIT
NEXT YEAR ALRIGHT IT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL FOR CONSTITUTIONAL.
SINCE OUR TO LIMIT IT TO
PHYSICAL INJURIES- AS OPPOSED
TO FINANCIAL INJURIES ARSENAL
PROPERTY. THAT JUSTIN I. JUST
OBSERVATION I THINK COULD HELP-
YOUR CALL IS AS YOU TRY TO
MINIMIZE INDIVIDUALS ABILITY TO
EXPLOIT OUR WHAT OTHERWISE
WOULD BE A CRIME. YOU KNOW IT'S
THE ELDER HAD ANY THOUGHTS ON
THAT. SENATOR PAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND- CENTER BUDGETS
I APPRECIATE- THAT INSIGHT AND-
CERTAINLY WILL TAKE IT INTO
CONSIDERATION THE MAIN FOCUS OF
THE BILL ACTUALLY WAS ON-
PHYSICAL ASSAULTS ARE A
PHYSICAL. ATTACKS SO CERTAINLY
THAT WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH
THAT MY ORIGINAL THINKING ABOUT
THE BILL AND APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THAT UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SENATOR
BOARD JUST SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MDAM CHAIR I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK. THE COMMITTEE THAT IS
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS ALSO
RECOGNISES THOSE ARE NOT
ABSOLUTE. AND THE SCENARIOS THE
EXAMPLES YOU'VE SHARED. NOT
ONLY ARE EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE
FEATURING REAL TIME VIOLENCE
BUT ALSO REAL TIME VIOLENCE
THAT COULD INCITE FURTHER
VIOLENCE SO. APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORT- JUST A QUESTION- MAYBE
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT I NOTICED
IN THE CRITERIA TO SECURE. SOME
THE CMPLIANCE BY THE SOCIAL
MEDIA ONE OF THE CRITERIA IS- A
POLICE REPORT. IN IN MY
EXPERIENCE. PLEASE REPORTS ARE
NOT ALWAYS AVAILABLE PROXIMATE
TO THE TIME OF THE COMMISSION
OF THE CRIME EVEN IF THE POLICE
HAVE BEEN ON SCENE OR TAKEN
WITNESS STATEMENTS OFTEN YOU
HAVE TO WAIT A LONG TIME TO GET
A POLICE REPORT IN TO EVEN GET
IN NUMBER THAT A POLICE REPORT
EXIST SO I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO LOOK AT THAT MAYBE TALK
TO. FOLKS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT CRITERIA COULD PUSH. COULD
SUSPEND GETTING THE ACTION YOU
WANT FROM THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
GENERATE THE POLICE REPORT. IN
A TIMELY FASHION SO JUST TO THE
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER MONEY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING TIS
BILL SENATOR PAN IT'S GOT A LOT
OF CHALLENGES BUT IT TO I THINK
WE ALL AGREE THAT THE VICTIM
SHOULD NOT TO BE RE VICTIMIZED
BY THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR. SO
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BUT FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO- I THINK- BOTH CENTER BOARD
JUST CEREMONIES FOR YOUR
SUGGESTIONS AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THE BILL AND AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR GIVE ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND ALSO TO YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING VERY HARD ON THIS BILL
JUST BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE TIME. TO SORT OUT THE
VERY COMPLEX ISSUES AND
CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT EVERYONE
HERE CLEAN MYSELF AS A VERY
STRONG THE CENTER OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT THAT IS A YOU KNOW
CORNERSTONE OF OUR CONSTITUTION
WELL BE SURE WE PROTECT THAT-
BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND I THINK
THE CENTER MINING SAID IS THAT.
IT'S NOT WITHOUT SOME
BOUNDARIES AND WE DO NEED TO BE
SURE THAT WE ALSO PROTECT
VICTIMS OF CRIME WHILE ALLOWING
EVERYONE TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES FULLY AND OUR OUR-
COUNTRY THANKS VERY MUCH AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN THIS
WOULD MAKE QUITE AN INTERESTING
BAR EXAM QUESTION ONE OF. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
NOW TO A FILE ITEM TO SENATOR
WHY CAO SKI THIS IS SB EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT AND YOU WILL
PRESENT IF YOU WOULD FROM YOUR
CHAIR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COLEAGUES AB ONE THE
GREATEST HURDLES FAMILIES FACE
WHEN CON. BUT AT THE OF PURSUE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION IS THE
SKYROCKETING COST OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE DESPITE THE TROUBLING
TREND MANY CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO SEE VALUE IN A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. SAVINGS PLANS SUCH AS
SCHOLARSHIPS- FIVE TO NINE
PROVIDE FAMILIES OF ALL INCOME
LEVELS WITH A DIVERSE SET OF
INVESTMENT. TAX DEFERRED GROWTH
AND WITHDRAWALS FREE WHEN USE
QUALIFIED HIGHER EDUCATION
EXPENSES SUCH AS TUITION AND
BOOKS FEES AND OTHERS REQUIRED
SUPPLIES. UNLIKE RETIREMENT
PLANS WHERE IT'S A FOUR ONE K.
OR- A CALPERS RETIREMENT PLAN
SCHOLARS SHEARED FIVE TWO NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS ARE
NOT AFFORD PROTECTION FROM
CREDITORS CLAIMS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF AN ACCOUNT OWNER IS FACED
WITH THE JUDGMENT THE CREDITOR
HAS THE ABILITY TO ATTACH THE
ACCOUNT TO SATISFY THEIR
JUDGMENT RESULT THE CAN BE
DEVASTATING TO THE FAMILY AND
THEIR LOVED ONES. PARTICULARLY
THE CHILD WHOSE EDUCATION IS ON
THE LINE. PRESENTLY CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF TWENTY TWO STATE OUT
A STATE CREDITOR PROTECTION FOR
FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGE
SAVINGS PLANS. THIS BILL EIGHT.
NINE EIGHT EXPANDS THE LIST OF
JUDGMENT EXEMPTIONS AND THE
CALIFORNIA BANKRUPTCY LAW IN
ORDER TO INCLUDE FAMILY SAVINGS
IN THE SCHOLAR CHEER FIVE TWO
NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS. PLAN
ACCOUNT. DOES THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT FOR OUR FAMILY
COLLEGE SAVINGS ARE PROTECTED
FROM JUDGMENT CREDITORS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REVISES
THE STATUTES SETTING FORTH. THE
AMOUNT THE VARIOUS TYPES OF
PROPERTY OWNED BY THE OWN BY
THE TETHER- THAT ARE
STATUTORILY EXAM FROM FOR SPEND
OF A MONEY JUDGMENT SO THAT THE
AMOUNTS MATCH THE CURRENTLY IN
EFFECT AMOUNTS IMPLEMENTED BY
THE JUDICIARY- CAP OUR JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
IT'S- A- EXPLAIN. QUITE NICELY
IN A STAFF REPORT SAWYER TO
VOTE AND SUPPORT TODAY WITH ME
IN THE ROOM IS OUR STATE
TREASURER THAT SPONSOR THE BILL
FEE ON A MARK. WHO IS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A LARGE
NUMBER OF. THANK YOU SENATOR Y.
KOWSKI AND AGAIN TO THE
CONSTRAINTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
HEARING AND TECHNOLOGY ASPECTS
OF THIS. WE ARE PERMITTING A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES PER SIDE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. IN
ADDITION TO. TREASURER MAR YOU
ALSO HAVE. HELLO TEACHERS STAND
ZITO FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
TREASURER TOO I GUESS ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND
OTHER THAN THAT. MS MOFFETT
LIKE TO PROCEED OF GIVEN THAT
THERE ARE NO OTHER IDENTIFIED
WITNESSES WHO ARE WISHING TO
GIVE TESTIMONY HERE. WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND GIVE YOU A GRANT TO
THOSE THREE MINUTES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL. UP
BASICALLY UNDER FEDERAL LAW
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLANTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH PROTECTION FROM
CREDITORS UNDER THE BANKRUPTCY
ABUSE PREVENTION AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
FIVE- BARK SCHOLARSHIP FIVE TWO
NINE WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. AND I'M
THE CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE-
AND- CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF
TWENTY TWO STATES WITHOUT STATE
CREDITOR PROTECTION. OUTSIDE OF
BANKERS BANKRUPTCY FOR FIVE
TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS SO SPECIALLY NOW GIVEN
THE- COVERED SITUATION WE'RE
NOT SURE. WHAT PEOPLE'S
FINANCIAL HEALTH WILL BE AND WE
MAY SEE PEOPLE ENTER INTO
BANKRUPTCY AND WE REALLY WANT
TO JUST PROTECT FAMILIES AND
THEIR KIDS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THESE ACCOUNTS SOMETIMES OUR
COMMINGLED. WITH FRIENDS AND
RELATIVES MONEY- AND WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THESE
KIDS HAVE THE NECESSARY MONEY.
TO GO TO COLLEGE AND THAT IT
WILL NOT BE- PART OF THE
BANKRUPTCY- PLAN- THA. WOULD
EMERGE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COURTESY HERE TODAY
AND- FOR JUST HEARING THIS BILL
AND MOVING IT ALONG ESPECIALLY-
TURN THIS SITUATION. IF I ALSO
HAVE A COUPLE EXPERTS HERE WHO
ARE. BOB HERE AND ABLE TO
ANSWER SOME TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE WE ALSO
HAVE JULIO MARTINEZ FROM YOUR
OFFICE AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE
LINE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AS WELL AS THE MAY
COME UP DURING THE- DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE SO ARE THERE
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. ANY IN
TWENTY FORTY NO ONE IS IN
TWENTY FORTY VERY GOOD- LET'S
GO TO THE PHONES. AND WE WILL
GO TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORBIS. MR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN. CERTAINLY
LADY IN GERMAN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR SHOW SUPPORT FOR
THIS YOUR PRESS ONE AND THEN AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT'S ONE
ZERO WE DO A FEW THAT ARE
ALREADY CUED UP. WE'LL GO TO.
ONE MOMENT WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO SEVEN TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BEFORE WE DO
THAT MISTER MODERATE COULD YOU
GIVE ME AN INDICATION OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE CUED UP TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. JUST TO VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SIR. PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PROCEED.
SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN I'M
ONLY SAYING BACKGROUND NOISE.
SHE WANTS HIM TO IS A PLAN TO
TALK ABOUT SB NINE THIRTY NINE.
WELL WE AREN'T THERE YET SO IF-
BUT IF YOU WOULD WE ARE ON SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO IS
DESIROUS OF SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. OKAY WATER
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN AND
SEE IF THEY ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY SPEAK.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON AND
MEMBERS THIS IS DANIELLE KENDO
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND
URGE YOUR EYES THE- THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES MISTER
MODERATOR WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT. NO ONE SHOULD UP AFTER
THOSE FIRST TWO PERSON VERY
GOOD LET'S GIVE THEM ONE LAST
CHANCE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT.
AN AFFILIATION. MISTER
MODERATOR OR HAS ANYONE
INDICATED THAT DESIRE. NO ONE
HAS AT THIS TIME. GOOD SO- WE
WILL THEN GO TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE WHO IS HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE I
WOULD NOTE THAT WE DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY WRITTEN OPPOSITION.
FIVE IS THERE. ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY NO ARE WILL THEN MOVE TO
THE PHONES MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE- CALLED- ON
ANYONE WHO HAS- LINED UP FOR IS
LINING UP IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT. CERTAINLY
WISH OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THAT'S ONE DâN ZERO. MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE WHO
HAS LINED UP TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME
WOULD GIVE ANOTHER TEN SECONDS
BUT AGAIN THERE WAS NO
OPPOSITION INDICATED. ALL RIGHT
OF ICING THERE IS NO OTHER
WITNESSES MISTER MODERATOR.
THAT IS CORRECT YOUR PERSON
RIGHT WE WILL THEN BRING IT
BACK SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS BY THE
PUBLIC WILL BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION. IN COMMITTEE- HIGH
NOTE THAT THE SENATOR BOARD
JUST HAS HIS HAND UP- SENATOR
BOARD USE OF FORCE YEARS. SIR
BRIDGES I THINK YOU HIT THE
BUTTON AGAIN AND YOU'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BECAUSE THEY'LL- ON
MUTUAL HERE DON'T ASK ME HOW IT
WORKS. THAT THERE YOU GO WE
HEAR YOU NOW. IT JUST SO YOU
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IS A BUBBLE
POPS UP AND ASKS ME TO PUSH IT
TO ON MUTE. SO I THINK. THAT'S
THE REASON WHY THERE'S A LADY I
APOLOGIZE I'M SURE IT'S- YOU
DON'T NEED TO POP. OKAY THANK
YOU IF I MAY POSE A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR. ON THIS IS A- AN
INTERESTING IDEA- I GOT A-
COUPLE OF QUICK QUESTIONS IS.
WHY IT. WAS WHY IS THIS PROGRAM
OR THIS THIS MODIFICATION
LIMITED ONLY TO GOLDEN STATE
SCHOLAR SURE FIVE TWO NINE
PROGRAM THE STATE MANAGED
PROGRAM AND NOT ANY OTHER
PROVIDER OF FIVE TO NINE. SET
ASIDES OUR THE SECOND IS
WORRIED ABOUT MULTIPLE ACCOUNTS
BEING OPEN AND INDIVIDUALS
WANTING TO USE THIS FOR-
NEFARIOUS PURPOSES TO MOVE
MONEY- WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE TO
ALLOW IT TO HAVE A CUMULATIVE
EVEN FROM ON EVEN FROM MULTIPLE
PARTIES ALLOW WHICH ONLY HAVE
ONE ACCOUNT. PER CHILD. DOES
YOUR DOES YOUR TO THE QUESTIONS
OUT OF THE GATES IF I MAKING
OUT- POSE THEM TO THE ALTAR
RESPONSE SURE- SO THERE IT
NEARLY NINETY DIFFERENT FIVE TO
NINE PLANS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. AND EVEN IF YOU'RE A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO OPEN UP A
SCHOLARSHIP FIVE TWO NINE WHICH
IS ARE CALIFORNIA ONE. A
DEPENDING ON YOUR FINANCIAL
ADVISER FOR EXAMPLE THEY MAY
RECOMMEND THAT YOU OPEN UP A
FIVE TWO NINE ACCOUNT IN SOME
OTHER STATE. SO THIS BILL IS
REALLY TO PROTECT OUR
CALIFORNIANS WHO OUT FILE
BANKRUPTCY AND TO YOU KNOW
PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES AND
THER CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS-
ARE YOU ASKING WHETHER THIS
BILL WOULD BE LIMITED TO. CHILD
UP FOR ACCOUNT THAT WOULD BE
PROTECTED UNDER BANKRUPTCY. BUT
LET'S GO BACK TO THE FIRST ONE.
GIFTS THIS ONLY PERTAINS TO THE
STATE MANAGED PROGRAM- MAYBE
YOU CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND THE
RATIONALE AS TO WHY IT ONLY
APPLIES. TO THE STATE MANAGED
PROGRAM AND NOT ANY OTHER FIVE
TWO NINE PROGRAM WHETHER IT'S
IN STATE OR OUT OF STATE. FOR
THE CHAIR PLEASE OKAY THANK YOU
YES SO- WE REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA
TO OPEN UP THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOLAR SHARE FIVE TWO NINE
ACCOUNT. WE CANNOT MANDATED
WE'RE ONE OF THE FEW STATES
THAT DOES NOT OFFER A TAX
CREDIT OR TAX INCENTIVE UP FOR
OPENING UP AN ACCOUNT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO A LOT OF THESE
ACCOUNTS ARE- IF YOU'RE WITH A
LARGE FINANCIAL ADVISER- MAYBE
VANGUARD OR SCHWALB WAR. ONE OF
THE OTHER- TO USE. TRY TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR CUSTOMERS TO.
INVEST THEIR MONEY INTO PLANTS
WHERE THEY GET SOME SORT OF
INCENTIVE RIGHT FINANCIAL
ADVISORS SO THAT'S THE REASON
THAT THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
RECOMMEND OPENING UP ON IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT FOR CALIFORNIA
BANKRUPTCY LAWS WE REALLY CAN
ONLY PASS LAWS THAT PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS SO THEREFORE IF
THEY OPEN UP A SCHOLARSHIP FIVE
TWO NINE THE COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT THOSE
CALIFORNIANS FILING FOR
BANKRUPTCY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO OPEN UP THE
ACCOUNTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS CENTER BORDERS IF NOT
WE'LL GO TO JUST. WORRIED ABOUT
PEOPLE MOVING. TOO MUCH MONE
AROUND- THERE'S AN AGGREGATE
LIMIT- BUT WOULD IT NOT BE
POSSIBLE TO ALSO ALLOWED TO
APPLY TO ONLY ONE. ONE ACCOUNT
HER CHILD. WHEN WE HAD S. C.
AUTHORED TO RESPOND TO THAT.
WELL FARM. ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
BILL IT JUST SAYS MONEY HELD IN
THE ACCOUNT. ON BY THE-
JUDGMENT DEBTOR AND ESTABLISHED
PURSUANT TO THE GOLDEN STATE
SCHOLARSHIP TRUST ACT. THE CITY
DOESN'T YOU KNOW IT DID YOU GET
INTO A DIFFERENT SECTION BUT
WE'RE JUST ADDING SECTION
TWELVE SO NO TYPICALLY IN
BANKRUPTCY IT'S WHETHER IT'S
REASONABLE MAN I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT COSTS TO GO
TO USC BUT IF YOU HAD FOUR
YEARS WORTH OF MONEY IN THERE
AND YOU HAD ONE KID OR TWO KIDS
THAT THE TRUSTEE IN BANKRUPTCY
FEWER BEFORE THEM- THEY WOULD
THEY WOULD THINK WHAT IS THIS A
REASONABLE AMOUNT TO GO IN LAST
PLACE SAID CIVIL. COURT JUDGE
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD LOOK AT THE
WOULD LOOK AT THE
REASONABLENESS OF THAT
EXEMPTION FOR JUDGMENT CREDITOR
CAME AND SAID THEY WANT TO
CATCH IT YOU CLAIM THE
EXEMPTION SAYS THE DEBTOR WITH
THE JUDGMENT DEBTOR AND THEN IT
THE FAX THE CAKE WHAT IT IS.THAT'S I THINK THE FACTS ARE
MOST THE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THERE
NOT AT THE HIGH END ON THIS
MOST PEOPLE GOT TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND BUCKS OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THE KIDS EDUCATION
GENERALLY IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. SENATOR JONES. REAL QUICK
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT A CO MINGLING- AND-
THAT HADN'T SHOWN UP AND SO I
WAS INTRIGUED BY THAT IF YOU
CAN TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT COMMINGLING OF FUNDS FROM
OTHER SOURCES PETER THE CHAIR
SENATOR JONES THAT THANK YOU I
MEAN ANYONE CAN OPEN UP A FIVE
TWO NINE ACCOUNT FOR A CHILD- A
LOT OF PEOPLE NOW ARE SAYING
WILL START OF. GIVING THE KID A
TOOL WHY DON'T YOU CONTRIBUTE A
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO THEIR FIVE
TWO NINE FOR THEIR COLLEGE
ACCOUNTS SO THAT'S WHAT
COMMINGLED MEANS. IT'S NOT
NECESSARYJUST THE PARENTS THAT
PUT IN MONEY COULD BE
GRANDPARENTS AUNTS AND UNCLES
GOT PARENTS. FRIENDS AND WE
YOU KNOW. SAVE OKAY INS AND SO
ONCE THOSE ONCE THOSE FUNDS
ARE. IN THE ACCOUNT ONLY THE
PARENTS HAVE CONTROL OF THE
ACCOUNT DOES THAT CORRECT
THAT'S RIGHT HELLO. YOU CAN ADD
ON I'M SORRY DO WE HAVE I'M
SORRY STATE YOUR NAME PLEASE
THAT'S A STAND ZERO- WITH THE
SCHOLARSHIP INVESTMENT FOR WORK
WITH IN QUICKEN TURNER'S
OFFICE- JUST TO ADD TO THAT- SO
EXPOSURE ACCOUNTS. AGAIN FISHER
CAN HAVE MULTIPLE SCHOLARSHIP
ACCOUNTS ON BY DIFFERENT PEOPLE
LIKE THE PARENTS OR THE
GRANDPARENTS FOR OTHER PARTIES.
AND ESSENTIALLY ALL OF THOSE
PARTIES CAN HELP SAVE FOR THAT
ONE BETTER FISHERIES COLLEGE
EDUCATION IS BENEFICIARY HAS A
MAXIMUM THAT THEY CAN HAVE SAY
WITHIN AN ACCOUNT AND THAT'S-
THAT'S ALL OF THE ACCOUNTS
UNDER THE BENEFICIARIES NAY.
THERE'S A LIMIT TO THAT- WITHIN
THE SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. AND
SO. AS FAR AS THE QUESTION
ABOUT. MINGLING THERE'S AN
OPTION TO IF YOU HAVE A SINGLE
ACCOUNT MULTIPLE PEOPLE CAN
MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS TO THEIR
FRIENDS FAMILIES. SO
ESSENTIALLY ONE BENEFICIARY IF
YOU ADD UP ALL THEIR ACCOUNTS
IS MEANT TO. SUPPORT THEIR-
EDUCATION- IS FAR AS A TELLING
ONE ACCOUNT VERSUS ANOTHER IT'S
KIND OF ALL TOGETHER. IS MEANT
TO FUND THEIR WHOLE COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND WITH A MAXIMUM
OUT SORRY TO THE CHAU CERTAINLY
THE MAXIMUM OUT FOR DISCLOSURE
PROGRAM IS FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO WHAT
THE BENEFICIARY REACHES THAT
AMOUNT. ALL OF THEIR SCHOLARS
ACCOUNTS. ON THE YOU KNOW THEY
CAN'T CONTRIBUTE ANYMORE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THAT'S AWFUL. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. BY
THE THERE IS A MOTION BY
SENATOR MONNING WITH THAT TO
THE CENTER Y. CASKEY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RANCHER MEMBERS
HE'S THE ONLY ACCOUNTS THAT THE
TREASURER MANAGES AND I'D URGE
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION OF BY SENATOR MONNING.
MADAM SECRETARY AGAIN I'D LIKE
TO REMIND EVERYONETO PUT THEIR
MICROPHONES ON AS THE VOTE.
THEM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION. IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
YES THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT WHY
CAL SKI. JACKSON HI JACKSON I
DID ALSO I DID ALSO I GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ I JONES. MONNING
AYE MONNING AYE STERN HI EARN I
BURKE WHY CAL SKI BY Y. CASKEY
I. THE CURRENT VOTE COUNTY IS
SIX SIX TWO ZERO WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR
UMBERG MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
THREE THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THREE SB NINE FIFTEEN.
SENATOR LEYVA GOOD MORNING.
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS REFERENCED
ON PAGES FIVE AND SIX IN AND
MARK UP FORM ON PAGES FIFTEEN
THROUGH EIGHTEEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. OF FOR MEMBERS. AND
SENATOR LABOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I'M HERE THE MORNING
EVERYONE. MANAGER IF YOU WOULD
INDULGE ME FOR A MOMENT I WOULD
LOVE TO LET MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KNOW JUST A LITTLE
HARDER THEY HAVE YEAH BUT I
DON'T THINK I'M ON YEAH OKAY.
NOT A WORRY THERE YOU GO I'M
WELL BUT THIRD AGAIN PLEASE
OKAY VERY GOOD GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS. MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD INDULGE ME FOR JUST A
MOMENT I WOULD LIKE TO LET EACH
MEMBER KNOW HOW MANY MOBILE
HOME PARKS THEY HAVE. IN THEIR
DISTRICT- MADAM CHAIR YOU HAVE
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE PARKS.
BY SURE BORCHERS YOU HAVE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE. SENATOR
RAWSON YOU HAVE THREE PARKS
SENATOR GONZALEZ YOU HAVE SIXTY
SEVEN PARKS. SENATOR JONES YOU
HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SENATOR MONEY YOUR WINNER WITH
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX.
SENATOR STERN YOU HAVE FORTY
TWO SENATOR NUMBER YOU HAVE
EIGHTY SEVEN AND SENATOR WHY
CAL SKI HAS FIFTY TWO. I LIKE
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW BECAUSE WE
DON'T ALWAYS KNOW HOW MANY WE
HAVE IN OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS.
ARE WHERE SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
LIVE A CONSTITUENTS LIVE AND IT
IS THE LAST BASTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. SBNINE
FIFTEEN WOULD CREATE A
PROTECTIVE PROCESS FOR MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. BY PREVENTING
THE MANAGEMENT OF MOBILE HOME
PARKS FROM TERMINATING OR
ATTEMPTING TO TERMINATE. THE
TENANCY OF AFFECTED RESIDENTS
DURING A DECLARED STATE OR
LOCAL EMERGENCY RELATED TO
COVERED NINETEEN. IT WOULD ALSO
GIVE MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS THE
RIGHT AN OPPORTUNITY TO REPAY
TO AVOID EVICTIONS. MOBILE
HOMES ARE VITAL TO OUR
COMMUNITIES THEY MAKE UP 10% OF
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK. IN MOST CASES MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS ARE COMPRISED OF
THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. INCLUDING SENIORS
VETERANS IMMIGRANTS AND LOW ARE
ON FIXED INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES. MOBILE HOMES ARE IN
FOR AFFORDABLE ALTERNATIVE BUT
THE RESIDENTS LIVING IN MOBILE
HOME PARKS FACE UNIQUE HOUSING
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE LAW DEFINES
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS AS BOTH
HOMEOWNERS AND TENANTS BECAUSE
THE RESIDENT OWNS THE MOBILE
HOME BUT THE PARK OWNS LAND
UNDERNEATH THE MOBILE HOME. TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES MOBILE HOMES FALL
UNDER A DIFFERENT CIVIL CODE
SECTION AND ARE GOVERNED BY THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LOT THE
M. R. L. OR THE BY. ALL WE ARE
WELL OF GOVERNOR NEWSOME SECOND
IN ORDER END TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY BANNING THE ENFORCEMENT
OF INFECTIONS OF RESIDENTS
AFFECTED BY COVERT NINETEEN BUT
THE ORDER WAS NOT SPECIFIC TO
MORRELL SECTIONS THE GOVERNMENT
WILL HOMES AND PROTECT MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS SB NINE FIFTEEN
ADDRESSES THE SPECIFIC GAPS BY
DEVELOPING AN EVICTION
PREVENTION POLICY PROTECTING
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS AFFECTED
BY COVERT NINETEEN WE BELIEVE
WITH CLARIFICATION THE OWNERS
SECOND ORDER COULD BE
MISINTERPRETED TO THE DETRIMENT
OF MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
ULTIMATELY SB NINE FIFTEEN TO
GIVE AFFECTED MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS. GREATER CHANCE IN IN
A MOBILE HOME BRING THIS
PANDEMIC AND REASONABLE TIME
AFTER THIS MORNING SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT IS BRUCE STATEN FROM
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE OR G. O. L.
THINK ABOUT HERE. THANK YOU ARE
SENATOR LEYVA OUT WE DO HAVE AS
I UNDERSTAND IT A MISTER
STANTON BY PHONE AGAIN- WE WILL
BE LIMITING EACH SIDE TO A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES OF
ACTUAL TESTIMONY. AND THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE- AFTER THAT WILL BE
ASKED TO JUST GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND INDICATE THEIR
PORT. AT THE LET US GO TO.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING
NONE THERE ARE NONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WE WILL GO NOW TO THE
PHONES FOR MISTER STANTON. AND
I BELIEVE OF THE TOTAL IS THREE
MINUTES SIDE I BELIEVE YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
THAT IS CORRECT TESTIMONY SO
MISTER STANTON YOU DON'T NEED
TO USE THE ALL THE THREE
MINUTES BUT YOU DO HAVE THREE
MINUTES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BRUCE STATUS GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR G. S. OF A WELL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I THINK WE
CAN AGREE THAT AT NO TIME IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AS THE
PROTECTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT LOCAL HOMEOWNERS. OR
EIGHT IT BACK NOW. THE
POPULATION PREDOMINATELY
COMPRISED OF SENIORS IMMIGRANTS
ABOUT FIXED INCOMES GLOBAL
HOMEOWNERS ARE UNIQUELY AT RISK
OF THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
RESPONSES TO DATE BUT IS
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER
IN MARCH. ESSENTIALLY WE- DEALT
WITH THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
FICTION IS DURING THE TO CLEAR
STATE OF EMERGENCY BUT DID NOT
SPECIFY. THAT ENTITIES COULD
NOT BE TERMINATED BY NOTICE OR
THAT EVE ADDICTION ACTIONS
COULD BE FILE. WE HAD ON APRIL
SIX THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ORDER
THAT SAYS THE COURT CANNOT
FILE- COMPLAINTS OR SEVEN
SPREAD LAWFULLY TATERS. BUT
AGAIN THAT WATER DID NOT
ADDRESS THE THREATENING OF
ADDICTIONS OR THE SERVING UP
THEY THINK SHOULD NOTICES OR
RENT INCREASE NOTICES OR ANY
PROCEDURE FOR A MOBILE HOME
OWNERS TO DEFER PAYMENT OF
FRANK'S. DUTY INCOME LOST
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE ENACTED
VARYING FORMS OF RELIEF
INCLUDING RANT JURISDICTION
MORATORIUM'S BUT AT PRESENT
THERE'S NO UNIFORMS STATE
LEGISLATION WHICH
COMPREHENSIVELY AND
SPECIFICALLY. ADDRESSES COPING
NINETEEN PROTECTION FOR MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS SB NINE ONE FIVE
ALIGNS. WITH FOUR TO FIVE.
PRIOR OR AND YOU NEEDED.
ADDRESSING COULD SITUATIONS
SHOES THAT CONTINUE TO BE
SPECIFIED. IN ANY STATE OR
LOCAL EMERGENCY RESPONSE. IT
PROTECTS RESIDENTS FROM THE
THREAT OF THE ADDICTION BY
PROHIBITING YOUR SHIPMENTS OF
THESE ACTION NOTICES THAT TO
DATE CAN STILL BE SIR. THEY CAN
INFLICT PANIC EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS POTENTIALLY SCARE SOME
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE KIDDING
THEIR HOMES. EVEN WITHOUT THE
FILING OF THE COURT ACTION. IT
ALSO IN THE IN THE INTERESTS OF
JUDICIAL ECONOMY AVOID THE
POTENTIAL COLLECT BIãU
UNLAWFUL DETAINER LITIGATION
WHAT THE COURT EVICTION PROCESS
REAL. PARK OWNERS ARE STILL
ALLOWED TO STIR BEEN COMPLETE
SIXTY DAY NOTICE IN THE INTERIM
AND THEN QUEUE UP THE FILE
EVICTIONS. IT PROVIDES A
PROCEDURE FOR REASONABLE RENT
DEFERMENT THAT READ FORGIVE AS
A PROCESS WHICH THE HOMEOWNER
CAN ELECT TO. ADD TO IT AND
ENSURES THAT PARK OWNERS WILL
BE REPAID. AND IT PROTECTS
HOMEOWNERS FROM BEING
THREATENED WITH SEVENTEEN
NOTICED USED TO CURE RULES
VIOLATIONS WHICH THEY MIGHT BE
UNABLE TO PERFORM DUE TO AN
INABILITY TO HIRE A CONTRACTOR
OR ANTI BACK DURING. THE
LOCKDOWN. IT PREVENTS PARK
OWNERSHIP NOTICING INCREASES A
TIME WHEN MANY HOMEOWNERS ARE
STRUGGLING ALRIGHT. MARIE THIS
BILL PURPOSES TO PROVIDE
HOMEOWNERS WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY RENT TO WHO ARE UNABLE TO
RESPOND TO BILLS VIOLATIONS.
PRECIOUS READING ROOM TO KEEP
THEIR HOMES AND AVOID
HOMELESSNESS. RESERVATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE GOAL
TO PREVENT INCREASED ALMOST AS
WHICH IS ALREADY PREDICTED
DERIDING THINK ONE THANK YOU
MISTER STANTON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ABOUT YOUR USE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY BACK WE ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU SIR
FIVE ARE THERE AGAIN I'LL TRY
ONE MORE TIME ANYONE IN THIRTY
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO
THE PHONES. MODERATOR TO THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELEPHONE- TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO DO SO.
AS LONG AS FEE NINE FIFTEEN WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTEEN ON THE PHONE LINES IN A
PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THAT'S ONE ZERO. WE DO WE
HAVE TO THAT HAVE Q. JUST ONE
MORE THAT IF YOU'RE UP LOOKS
LIKE ONE REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM
THE QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINE ONE
ZERO NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL GOOD MORNING YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
MY NAME IS ABOUT HER AUTO I'M
FROM THAT STATIC LEGAL SERVICES
ON LOS ANGELES WE SUPPORT THE
BILL AND APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
DOCTORS OFFICE. BUT WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS- THE NEW
AMENDMENT TO HELP YOU KNOW
WE'LL KEEP WORKING ON THIS FOR
EVERY REALLY SUPPORT THIS
SPELL. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS HERE IN LOS ANGELES
THAT ARE FACING COMMERCIAL
EVICTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE ONE FIVE IF
WE COULD THOSE ON THE PHONE.
WOULD LIKE YOU TO RESPOND TO
THE BILL AT HAND IN THIS CASE.
CENTER LEYVA SB NOT FIFTEEN
RELATING TO MOBILE HOME. OF
RENT. ANY ONE ELSE THE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR. ONCE AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL WE HAVE ONE MORE
THAT IS IN THE QUEUE THAT IS
LINE NUMBER NINETY NINE NINE
NINE NINE YOU MAY SPEAK. I
DIDN'T BELIEVE FAIR AND THE
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION IN
CARBONDALE AT PUBLIC LAWCENTER
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE ONE FIVE
AND WE HAVE- APPRECIATED THE
WORK WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO WITH
THE AUTHOR DR TO STRENGTHEN THE
BELL AND- ENSURE THAT IT- IN
LINE WITH THE OTHER PROTECTION
OKAY WIDE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU. PLEASE CHECK ONE
MORE TIME TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTEEN WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. BY USING JOHN
PHONE LINES TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB NINE ONE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IS ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE MISTER
MODERATOR CONTINUE. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE INTO IT THIS TIME YOU
MAY CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO
THE OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. I
KNOW WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS.
YOU WILL HAVE COLLECTIVELY A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES AND
TWENTY FIVE SECONDS HOWEVER YOU
WISH TO SHARE IT BUT WE WILL
CUT YOU OFF AT THAT POINT IN
TIME A GOOD MORNING IF YOU
WOULD TELL US- WE CAN'T TELL
NECESSARILY BEHIND THE MASK
YOUR NAME AND PLEASE THERE YOU
GO PLEASED TO. PROCEED GOOD
MORNING- CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CENTER LEYVA ANSWER
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WMA AND OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL- OBVIOUSLY THESE
ARE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES SOME
OWNERS ARE NERVOUS JUST LIKE
RESIDENTS AND HOW TO GET
THROUGH THIS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK AS WE GET THROUGH
IT- SO ANYWAY WERE SENSITIVE TO
IT AND WE'RE ACTUALLY ALREADY
WORKING ON PAYMENT PLANS WITH
RESIDENTS AN ABSENCE OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE DON'T BELIEVE
WE CAN EVEN WAIT FOR THE BILL.
THE BILL DOES TWO THINGS THE
FIRST PART CODIFIES THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THE
INDUSTRY BELIEVES THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER DOES
APPLY TO MOBILE HOMES WE ARE
NOT-PUTTING IN NOTICES FOR
VICTIMS YOU'RE NOT DOING ANY OF
THESE THINGS WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD BE CODIFYING THE
GOVERNOR'S DECADE OF ORDER INTO
THE CIVIL COME ON COLBERT
NINETEEN WE RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THAT DOESN'T OCCUR. PART WITH
THE WITH. ISSUE THAT YOU'RE ALL
BE DEALING NOT ONLY IN SENATE
BUT ASSEMBLY. HI YOU DO RETAIN
A PLAN WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE
THE OF RESTORATION OF MOBILE
HOME TENANTS. FOR CLOSING
KICKED OUT OF A PARK IT DOESN'T
DO ANYONE GOOD. BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS
WITH THIS BILL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST IT HAS US. COVER THE
UTILITIES AND OTHER CHARGES
THAT RESIDENTS CAN'T PAY. WE
ARE MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
THAT TO ROUTE THAT TAKE RENT.
WE ARE SIMPLY A PASTOR ON
UTILITIES WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS HOT THIS TO A PASS THROUGH
ANY KERRY. OF UTILITY AND OTHER
CHARGES STATE CHARGES FOR UP TO
A YEAR AND A HALF. NUMBER TWO.
THE SENATOR DID MODIFYING THE
COMMITTEE DID NOTE. THAT THE
LIABILITY PROVISION OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE EIGHT CD ISSUES
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS WE
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS.
THIS WANTS TO GIVE A SIX MONTH
LEEWAY. RESIDENTS NOT TO FIX
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS.
THE OWNERS WOULD ASK FOR
LIABILITY PROTECTION AND
THROUGHOUT TIS BECAUSE OF SOME
HAVE THE HOOK UP THE GENERATOR.
THAT IS GENERATING HOMES AND
THEY BURNED DOWN THE PARKER'S
HOMES WE'RE GOING TO GET
LIABILITY FOR IT. OBVIOUSLY NO
ONE WANTS TO SEE SOMEONEKICKED
OFF FOR A POTTED PLANT ON THEIR
PORCH. WITH EACH CD IS THE. ONE
THAT LOOKS AT HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS. SIX AT A MEETING. I
MADE WE WANT TO GET THROUGH
THIS WITH RESIDENTS AND WE WANT
TO FIND A WAY TO DO IT BUT WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT LANDLORDS
ARE ALSO KEPT HOLE BECAUSE OF
WE GO BANKRUPT AND WE GO
CHAPTER EIGHT YOU'RE GONNA OF
HEDGE FUNDS AND ALL THOSE BIG
CORPORATIONS BUYING PARKS THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO BUY PARKS
THEY'RE GOING TO RENT INCREASES
EVERYTIME THEY CAN AND ARE NOT
TO BE A SENSITIVE A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS LIKE US THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERYMUCH NEXT
WITNESS HAVE A MINUTE AND
FIFTEEN SECONDS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHASE AND I
COULD WITHOUT AUSTIN GILBERT
ROPES AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE THE LATEST TIME
I RATE THE MANY GOOD POINTS
MISTER GOVERNOR MADE BUT JUST A
COUPLE OF ADDITION. ON SIMPLY
HAVING A LOSS OF JOB OR INCOME
AND NOT FRANKLY IN AND ABILITY
TO PAY YOUR RENT THERE ARE
OTHER SOURCES OF INCOME THAT A
RESIDENT MAY CONTINUE TO HAVE
WHERE THEY MAY BE RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WHICH IS
INTENDED TO BE USED FOR
EXPENSES JUST LIKE RENT- AT A
HIGHER LEVEL WE GROUP THE
POINTS FOR GOVERNOR MADE ABOUT
THE UNCERTAINTY THE PARK OWNER
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. I'M
WHILE WE'RE SYMPATHETIC TO
RESIDENTS THE REAR IS THE
NUMBER AGREE WITH AUTHOR WE ARE
THE LAW BASS OF AFFORDABLE AND
IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS WE'VE
LOST HUNDREDS OF PARKS TO DO TO
CLOSURE AND WE'VE LOST
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND SPACES IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US HAVE THE
ABILITY. HOW MAY WERE WON'T BE
IN A TO RENT OR HOW WILL NOT
PAY THAT UNDER THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OR UNDER THIS.
CONSEQUENTLY MARKING FIRST IT'S
A ROLE OF THE DICE IN TERMS OF
A PARK OWNERS ABILITY THIS BILL
PASSES CONTINUE MAINTAIN THANK
YOU SIR. IN TEXAS IF I.
BUSINESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESS IN THE ROOM WHO IS LIKE
TO CHIU A THEIR NAME AND OF
PHILLY. WITH THE WE WILL GO TO.
OF ROOM TWENTY FORTY. KNOWING
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE GO TO
THE MODERN. ANY WITNESSES. ARE
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE TELL.
OR UP. FROM THOSE IN. MISTER
MOM. SO THE THEY CAN EXT.
THROUGH THEIR NAME. AND ENDED
OP THAT THEY'RE OPPOSED TO SB
NINE FOR. WE BEGIN. CERTAINLY
ALREADY HAVE ONE IN Q. WELL I
OVER. PIANIST ARE ONE THE END
THE ROAD TO PUT YOUR INTO THE-
WE WILL GO TO A LOT. NINETY
TWO. NINE TWO YOUR IS A YOU MAY
BE. GOOD MORNING CHURCH AND
MEMBERS CREE GREASY BEHALF OF
CAL SAYS OF REALTORS THE DISH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER. WITNESSES ARE WHO
WISHED EXPRESS THEIR NAME OF.
AN OP MR MODERATOR. WHAT IT
JUST CUED UP. ALLOW A MOMENT
PLEASE WHAT WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN US ONE.
ONE THREE. HI DEMON Y. LUNAR.
WORKERS AND LOWER. THAT POSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. WE HAVE.
ANY OTHER WITNESS SO MISSED MY
WOULD YOU CHECK ONE LAST TIME
TO SEE THERE ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESS WHO TO EXPRESS THEIR TO
S. BEING. FOR ONCE IT'S ONE
ZERO PUT YOURSELF INTO THAT CAN.
THE. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE
CHEWING UP THIS TIME VERY GOOD
YOU THEN OF THANK FOR THOSE OF
SUPPORT NOW WILL BRING THE
DISCO OUT BY TO COMMITTEE HARD
TO CHOOSE MAKE IT OR TWO I HAVE
OF LIKE CENTER LEYVA HAD A
STRONG COMMIT. TO THE PEOPLE
WHO IN ON MOLD HOME AS I
HAVEN'T LARGE IN OF THEM I DO
THE THEY TEND TO BE IN WHERE
THE CAR OF HOUSE ARE VERY. I
AND MOBILE HOME ON. AND MOVE
HOME. IS FIRST. OF ALL BASS. OF
THE HOMELESSNESS. AND UNLIKE
MOST OTHER CIRCUM. YOU MAY OWN
YOU HOME. BUT YOU DON'T ON THE
LAW. SO IF YOU ARE AT THE
SUBJECT OF AN- YOU LOSE YOUR
HOME BECAUSE SINCE OF WOULD BE
SAY A MOBILE THEY ARE MOBILE SO
TO PROVIDE TO PRE. TO THESE
PHONE ARE THINKING IS VERY VERY
CREDIT AND NECESSARY AND I WANT
TO THE OFF FOR BRING THIS BILL
BEFORE I WOULD HI I BELIEVE YOU
ARE EX. AS AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
THE AMENDMENTS PER IN THE
ANALYSIS YES YOU IT WILL NOT
THAT ARE. YOU KNOW THERE IS OF
COURSE THIS THIS. WORLD
EXPERIENCE THING IN TO I THINK
WE RECOGNIZE THE BIRD THAT THE
BILL DOES SHE OF. AND I AM MINE
OF THOSE CAN AND- I BELIEVE THE.
BEST POSITION TO HELP SHOULD
STEP UP AND I THINK THAT'S PART
OF WHAT YOU ARE CALLING FOR IN
THIS BILL- INDEED BECAUSE WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER OUR
GREATEST ASSISTANCE. I BELIEVE
HAS TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND THE MOST TO
LOSE AND AGAIN WHEN YOU LOSE
YOUR HOME. THE LAST THING WE
WANT TO DO IS ADD TO THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND SO WE
ARE ASKING EVERYONE TO PLEASE.
STEP UP AND DO THAT SO I HAD
SOME QUESTIONS BUT I DO KNOW
THAT THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL. TO REACH
AN ACCOMMODATION BUT I DO
BELIEVE THESE ARE FOLKS WHO
DESERVE- WHATEVER ASSISTANCE WE
CAN GIVE THEM THAT'S FAIR AND
REASONABLE TO ALL PARTIES. SO
WITH THAT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. SENATOR JOBS. I
THINK MA'AM CHARGES ONE MAKE A
BRIEF STATEMENT- I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M THE ONLY BUT ONE OF THE
FEW REPUBLICANS AND HAS A
HISTORY OF SUPPORT. MOBILE HOME
RENT CONTROL. BECAUSE OF THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THE
CHAIR POINTS TO ON THAT-
SITUATION. BUTTON FOR TRADE I
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
KIND OF FINE EXECUTIVE ORDER I
SHARE THE CONCERNS. OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- SO BE
VOTING NO TODAY- BUT TO KEEP AN
EYE ON IT AS IT PROGRESSES
THROUGH THE PROCESSING. THANK
YOU SENATOR JONES WHO HAVE BEEN
BORCHERS HAS HIS HANDS UP DON'T
TOUCH YOUR COMPUTER WE WILL GET
YOU ON RIGHT NOW. ARE WE THERE.
YET SENATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
SO YOU CAN HEAR ME STATURE
THANK YOU. I THINK ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE ABOUT NOT
JUST THIS BILL. NINE FIFTEEN
BUT OTHERS THAT ARE IN THE
PIPELINE IS THAT. WE ARE
LOOKING AT SOLVING HALF THE
PROBLEM. AT THE RENTAL LEVEL
WHETHER IT BE COMMERCIAL OR
WHETHER IT BEING ALL WITH
MOBILE HOMES OR RENTERS OF
APARTMENTS. IF WE MAKE ALL
THESE ARE IF WE IMPLEMENT ALL
THESE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
RANCHERS AND I THINK UNDER
THESE VERY UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF HOW BIG NINETEEN ARE THERE
ARE STRONG ARGUMENTS THAT
PEOPLE NEED SUPPORT. IT ONLY
RESOLVES HALF THE ISSUE AND I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE EQUAL
CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS WHETHER IT BE AT
THE STATE OR THE FEDERAL LEVEL
LEAST AT THE STATE WITHIN OUR-
IS THAT WE CREATE. FUNDING
MECHANISMS THAT WE'RE HELP OUT
THE PARK OWNERS WERE THE OWNERS
OF THE- THE LAND WHAT WERE THE
OTHER COMPLEX- BECAUSE IT SEEMS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR TO ME. TO
OFFER ALL THESE PROTECTIONS
OVER HERE. WHILE IGNORING THE
SIMILAR ON NEEDS OVER THERE ARE.
I WOULD ASK THAT AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD IS THERE ANY COMPATIBLE
OR OR ACCOMPANYING LEGISLATION
WITH THIS ARE COMING THROUGH
THE PIPELINE EITHER BY THE
ALTAR OR OTHERS THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR FUNDING MECHANISM THE
STATE TO HELP THE OWNERS ARE
WHERE THE LANDLORDS BECAUSE THE
PARK OWNER STILL HAPPEN
MORTGAGE TO START PART. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT IF ANY OF THIS
WERE TO MOVE FORWARD THAT IT BE
DONE WITH THE OTHER HALF OF THE
PROBLEM BEING ADDRESSED AS WELL
BECAUSE LOOKING AT ONLY THE
RANGERS ARE ONLY GETS A SO FAR.
THE OTHER IS. THE TWO POINTS
RAISED EARLIER BY THE
REPRESENTED AS IS THAT BEING
UTILITIES BEING BORN- BUYING AT
THE OWNERS AND ALL SO ARE BEING
HELD LIABLE FOR ANY IT CODE
VIOLATIONS- SO I WOULD ASK THE
AUTHOR. WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
INCORPORATE INTO THIS
LEGISLATION THROUGH A FRIENDLY
AMENDMENT THAT THERE ARE BEING.
LANGUAGE THAT IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT ARE THE PROPERTY ON THE
CART OWNER. IN SUCH A WAY THAT
UTILITIES CONTINUE TO BE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE RENTER.
AND WITH YOUR BE A LIABILITY
WAIVER PROVISION THAT WOULD
ALSO ALLOW FOR THEM TO RECEIVE
SOME DEGREE OF PROTECTION I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU- YOU COMMENT ON THAT THANK
YOU RIGHT WITH THAT- PERHAPS IN
YOUR CLOTHES SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. AGAIN I THINK JUST
BEFORE WE DO THAT I MENTIONED
THAT IT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
IF THE LENDERS WOULD ALSO STEP
UP- I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
CONTROL WE HAVE IS A STATE BUT
THAT CERTAINLY AN ISSUE THIS IS
ALSO NOT A PART OF THE- SUBJECT
MATTER OF THIS LEAD POLLUTION
BUT I DO THINK THAT. THE THIS
HAS NOT THAT PASSED UP WE CAN
GET CORPORATION THE LENDERS IN
THAT REGARD AGAIN MOST OF THAT
HIS ROLE. TO WELL BUT NOT PART
OF THIS LED AS I MENTIONED WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER WE
NEED TO ALL PART. WE NEED TO
BREAK THESE THE BILL WAY TO
WITH GET THROUGH THE BETTER OF
PEOPLE AND TO I HOPE WE'LL SEE
THAT AND WE. THE SENATE EARLY.
LIKE THE THANK MADAM CHAIR AS
THE CHAIR OF SELECT ON MOBILE
AMEND YOUR HOME FOR THE SIX I
WOULDN'T SAY I'M AN EXPERT BUT
I WOULD SAY THAT I HAVE A LOT
OF NEW AND I'VE LEARNED  LOT
ABOUT MOBILE AND MANUFACTURED
HOMES ONE THING THAT I HAVE
DEFINITELY LEARNED IS THAT
MOBILE HOMES ARE. TIMES
DISADVANTAGED AND NOT TREATED
THE SAME AS PEOPLE WHO OWN A
STICK BUILT HOME AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT- WHEN I HEARD THE
OPPOSITION SAY IT THIS WILL BE
A PARK ON INCREASE A RENT AT
ANY TIME THEY ALREADY. THIS IS
A CALL WE GET HUNDREDS OF CALLS
THAT WE GET UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- ASKING ABOUT RENT AND
RENT THAT HAS BEEN. RAISED WITH
BASICALLY IN A **** NILLY
MANNER- THIS I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT THIS BILL IS ONLY
DURING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN IS NOT AN INDEFINITE
IMMUNITY. FOR RENTERS THIS IS A
WAY TO HELP PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR JOB AND- AND WHEN
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT. WAT
OUR VISIONS THAT YOU MAKE WHEN
YOU'VE LOST CHURCH. YOU WANT TO
PAY YOUR RENT BUT YOU PROBABLY
ALSO WANT TO FEED YOURSELF AND
YOUR FAMILY SO YOU'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO BUY FOOD FOR YOU PAY
YOUR RENT. AGAIN THIS IS JUST A
THE FOR ALL THIS IS NOT- GIVEN
THIS THE REBELS. TO BE PAID. I
AM ALWAYS WILLING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE VIEW MA- TO THE ISSUES
THAT SENATOR POOR JUST RAISED.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
PART OF THIS BILL THAT MAY TAKE
A DIFFERENT BILL. BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT THAT. THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE IN A MOBILE HOME. PARK
ARE NOT EVICTED BECAUSE THEY
WILL END UP HOMELESS AND THEY
WILL HAVE A- PROBLEM THAN WE
HAVE NOW. I HAVE NOT FOUND.
OWNERS OF MOBILE HOME PARK IN
MY SIX YEARS AS THE CHAIR. TO
BE. REALLY HELPFUL TO THE
RESIDENCE AND TO THE FOLKS THAT
THEY COLLECT RENT FROM I'M SURE
THERE ARE GOOD AND I'VE SEEN
SOME. GOOD MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS BUT SO MANY MOBILE HOME
HOME PARK OWNERS. DON'T LIVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DON'T
LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY THEY OWN
THESE AS A MONEY MAKING PROFIT.
AND I FOUND THAT IT IS THE
RENTER'S. FOR WHO ARE TRYING TO
MAKE IT DAY TODAY ARE THE ONES
WHO SUFFER. SO I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO WORK. WITH MAY AT ADDRESS
CONCERNS BUT THIS IS ABOUT
HELPING EVERYDAY PEOPLE AND
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE A PLACE
TO LIVE. WITHOUT STRICTLY ASKED
ABOUT. THANK YOU. FOR THE CHAIR
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION HIS HER
MOTION. SENATOR MARK THE MO IS
TO PASS AS- TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOUR MIKE SERRANO AND
ADAM SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB NINE FIFTEEN
LEYVA- JACKSON HIGH ACCENT I
DID ALSO HI IT ALSO I GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ BY JONES OF.
JAPAN'S NO MONNING AYE AYE
MONNING AYE STERN HI STERN I
BURKE. WHY CAL SKI. RIGHT. FIVE
ONE THE ACCOUNT IS FIVE TWO
FIVE FIVE ONE NO WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
PRESENTATION MEMBERS AND NOW AT
THIS POINT WE WILL GO ON TO
FILE ITEM FOR WHICH IS S. IN
NINE THIRTY NINE. A SIMPLE ALL
WITH VERY LITTLE OPPOSITION.
THE SIX JOKINGLY HI. UNDERSTAND
THAT WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION BUT WHAT WOULD A
BILL BE FIRM SENATOR WARNER.
WIENER EXCUSE ME IF WE COULD
NOT HELPFUL. WELL THERE IS A
CENTER WONDER THERE WIENER IS
IT CAN BE PRONOUNCED EITHER WAY
AND SPELL THE WAY IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN I HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO
WINE FROM TIME TO TIME WELL.
THAT WAS. ONE OF THE OTHER. HE
EITHER WAY SENATOR WIENER. WE
WILL HEAR FROM YOU NOW AND SB
NINE THIRTY NINE AND-
APPRECIATE YOUR- A COMING
FORWARD WITH THE WITH THE YET
ANOTHER INTERESTING AND THE
CONFLICT IT DIDN'T. BLANK THE
BLANK THE MEASURE I THINK WE
ARE NO I GUESS THIS THIS SURVEY
ANALYSIS IS ONLY TWENTY SIX
PAGES LONG. WHICH IS CLOSE TO A
RECORD I THINK THIRTY TWO IS
THE RECORDS BUT I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE YOU'LL GET THERE AT
SOME POINT. HERE THOUGH WE HAVE.
THIS BILL YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENTED MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU'LL BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT ARE REFERENCED
ON PAGE EIGHT AND IN MARK UP ON
PAGES TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY
SIX IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT MA'AM THANK YOU SIR AND
WITH THAT- YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MANAGER WILL HVE TO
TRY HARDER TO GET UP TO THE
THIRTY THREE PAGES AND SET THE
RECORD. ON AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US- AND I
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE MY- LENSES
ARE MY GLASSES HAVE JUST
STARTED THE FOG NEVER GOOD ALL
MORNING. IT'S A SMALL PRICE OF
IT OVER REPUBLICAN- SO- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOU IN YOUR STAFF FOR
REALLY METICULOUS. CAME WITH US.
IN THE AMENDMENTS. THEY'RE VERY.
GOOD AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE
BILL BETTER MORE FOCUSED MORE
NARROW AND TARGETED SO THANK
YOU. I ALSO WANT TO THANK AND
ACKNOWLEDGE MY PARTNER IN THIS
BILL AND AUTHOR. SENATORS
DOLLARS TO. WORKING HANDING OF.
SOUTH ON. BUT I CALL DUE TO
FIVE TEAM HI CAL FACE THE REAL
PROSPECT OF A MASSIVE NUMBER OF
SMALL BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS
NOT SHUTTING DOWN FOR THE
SHELTER IN PLACE BUT
PERMANENTLY CLOSING. A MAP X.
EVENTS OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS BECAUSE THEY'RE PART
OF THIS BILL TO IN EVERY
NEIGHBORHOOD IN CALIFORNIA.
pOUR STATE PERMANENTLY. IT WOULD
SEVERELY HAMPER OUR ABILITY TO
RECOVER GIVEN HOW IMPORTANT
THESE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS ARE FOR EMPLOYMENT
IT WOULD DRAMATICALLY PARMER
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH BOARDED UP
STOREFRONTS. ANY WITH FARM
ARNOTT'S VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OUR NON PROFITS ARE
PART OF OUR SOCIAL SAFETY NET.
THIS BILL WILL ATTEMPT TO
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING-
BYE BYE. IN A VERY I THINK A
GOOD FAITH AWAY TRYING TO
TRIAGE HORRIBLE SITUATION AND
TO PREVENT THESE MASSIVE
ACTIONS IT DOES SO BY FIRST
PLACING A TEMPORARY MORATORIUM
ON COMMERCIAL AND NONPROFIT
EVICTIONS DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. AND THEN REQUIRING
GRADUAL REPAYMENT OF BACKGROUND
OVER TWELVE MONTHS WHEN
EMERGENCY ARMS BEARING
KNOWLEDGES THAT ONE PARTICULAR
SECTOR THE HOSPITALITY SECTOR
RESTAURANTS BARS CAFE. PLACES
OF ENTERTAINMENT ARE GOING TO
BE PARTICULARLY HARD HIT. NOT
ONLY WILL THEY BE CLOSING DOWN
OR ARE THEY SHUT DOWN. DURING
THIS ORDER IN PLACE NOT ONLY
ARE THEY GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BACKGROUND. BUT WHEN THEY
OPEN THE GOVERNMENT WILL BE
MANDATING THAT THEY
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THEIR
CAPACITY BY 25% 50% MAYBE EVEN
75% NOT VOLUNTARY NOT
GUIDELINES. MANDATORY CHOPPING
IN HALF OR THEREABOUTS OF
SOMEONE'S BUSINESS. YET THESE
RESTAURANTS BARS CAFES. ARE
EXPECTED TO TRUST FRANKLY SUCK
IT UP AND MAGICALLY COME UP
WITH THE HIGH RENT CONTAINED IN
THEIR LEASE THAT WAS NEGOTIATED
IN PRE CO THAT. CIRCUMSTANCES
THE RESTAURANT THAT NEGOTIATED
A LEASE BASED ON TWENTY TABLES
AND IS NOW TO HOLD FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE YOU CAN ONLY
FILL EIGHTY. IS SOMEHOW
EXPECTED. TO COMPLY WITH THAT
LEASE. THAT'S NOT REALITY. SB
NINE THIRTY NINE THEREFORE
CREATES INCENTIVES FOR
COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS TO
RENEGOTIATE THE RENT WITH THEIR
ATTENDANCE SO THESE BUSINESSES
CAN THRIVE. BASED ON THE
GOVERNMENT RAN MANDATED
REDUCTION. IT DOES SO BY GIVING
TENANTS IN AGAIN RESTAURANTS
BARS CAFES PLACE OF
ENTERTAINMENT THAT EXPERIENCE
EITHER A 40% DROP IN REVENUE OR
AT LEAST A 25% CAPACITY
REDUCTION TO TRIGGER A
RENEGOTIATION PERIOD WHICH
HOPEFULLYWILL SUCCEED IF IT
DOESN'T SUCCEED IT WILL GIVE
THE BUSINESS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TERMINATE THE LEASE. TO BE
CLEAR THE PURPOSE OF THIS LEASE
TERMINATION PROVISION IS NOT
FOR LEASES TO BE TERMINATED.
IT'S TO PROVIDE SPACE AN
INCENTIVE TO ACTUALLY GET THE
RENEGOTIATION BUT WE KNOW THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY THESE BUSINESSES
DON'T WANT TO CLOSE DOWN THIS
IS THEIR LIFE'S WORK THEY WANT
TO FIND A WAY. TO SURVIVE. I
ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT
STEREOTYPING OR DEMONIZING
ABROAD BRUSHING COMMERCIAL
LANDLORDS. MANY COMMERCIAL
LANDLORDS ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING RIGHT NOW. THEY'RE
WORKING WITH THE RENTERS
THEY'RE WAVING BACKGROUND THERE
RESTRUCTURING AND RENEGOTIATING
LEASES I WANT TO COMMEND THOSE
LAND WITH THESE IT. TO GET IT
WHO UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT IN
ANYONE'S INTEREST TO HAVE WE
CAN SEE FOR THE LANDMARK IT'S
NO REVENUE. TO PAY THEIR LOANS
OFF. BUT SADLY. ON THE OTHER
HAND ALL TOO MANY COMMERCIAL
LANDLORDS ARE REFUSING TO
RENEGOTIATE. ARE INSISTING THAT
THE PRE CODED UNREALISTIC RANDY
TATE. ARE IN VOTING LEASE RENT
ESCALATORS TRYING TO RAISE THE
RENT. OR IMPOSING LATE
PENALTIES LATE FEES ON
BACKGROUND THAT IS HAPPENING
ALL OVER THE STATE WE'RE
SENSITIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
PROPERTY OWNERS IN TERMS OF
THEIR LOAN OBLIGATIONS. IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE WE DON'T WANT
THESE PROPERTY OWNERS TO THE
FALL ON THEIR LOANS BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO BE CLEAR THESE LAND
THOSE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO COLLECT THE FREE COVERED
RENTS FROM THESE RESTAURANTS
BARS AND CAFES THAT IS NOT
REALITY. THE CHOICE IS IN
BETWEEN FULL RENT AND REDUCE
CRIME THE CHOICE IS BETWEEN
REDUCE CRIME I KNOW RENT
BECAUSE THE BUSINESS HAS SHUT
DOWN AND POTENTIALLY THE OWNER
HAS HAD TO DECLARE PERSONAL
BANKRUPTCY. THAT IS NOT GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIA. MASS
BANKRUPTCIES ENCLOSURES AND
VACANCIES SB NINE THIRTY NINE
IS A REASONABLE A REASONABLE
APPROACH. TO HELP AVOID MASS
CLOSURES OF THESE BUSINESSES
AND NONPROFITS. I WANT TO BE
CANDID IS S. NINE THIRTY NINE
PERFECT NO. IS IT DOESN'T NEED
MORE WORK IT DOES AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THAT WORK WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH OPPONENTS OF
THE BILL AND I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR DIALOGUING WITH US.
NEXT WEEK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
NUMBER A MEETING SCHEDULED THAT
CENTER GONZALEZ AND I ARE GONNA
BE TAKING WITH THE OPPONENTS TO
TRY TO COME UP WITH HIS COMMON
AS POSSIBLE. WE WANT TO GET TO
A POINT. WHERE WE HAVE A BILL
THAT WE EVERYONE CAN RALLY
AROUND TO SAVE. OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS. KOBE
BILLS ARE NOT THE SAME AS
REGULAR BILLS WE DON'T WE DON'T
HAVE SIX MONTHS. BEFORE SESSION
TO WORK ON THE BILL AND THREE
MONTHS FROM INTRODUCTION TO
COMMITTEE. TO METHODICALLY WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. THIS
PANDEMIC CAME UP FAST.
EVERYTHING IS FAST HERE AND SO
THIS IS NORMALLY WE WOULD HAVE
DONE EVEN MORE WORK BEFORE
COMMITTEE. BUT BECAUSE F THE
NATURE OF THAT TO SPEND THAT
MAKE THAT HASN'T HAPPENED THE
LEADERSHIP IS PROPOSING A
RENTER RELIEF. MEASURE WHICH IS
VERY PROMISING. IT'S NOT A
PRINT YET NOR WHAT I EXPECTED
TO BE A FRIEND CAUSE WE'RE IN
AN EMERGENCY EVERYTHING IS
MOVING FAST. SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
KOBE BILLS IT'S NOT ALWAYS IN
THE SAME PLACE AS THE LAST YEAR
OR THE YEAR BEFORE. AND SO
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR THE SPACE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
AND I MEANT. THE WORK SETTING.
IN MAKING. BUT THE LEASE
READING. PROVISION ONLY APPLIES
TO HOSPITALITY. THERE WAS
CONFUSION BASED ON AMBIGUITY IN
THE LANGUAGE AND THE COMMITTEE
HAS WORKED WITH US. TO REALLY
TIGHTEN UP WE AVE A DEFINITION
OF SMALL BUSINESS BASED ON
FEDERAL LAW AND THE P. P. P.
PROGRAM WHICH IS UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES SOME HAVE
QUESTIONED WHETHER IT SHOULD BE
LOWER- WE'RE OPEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION THERE'S NOTHING
BIBLICAL ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED.
AND IF IT NEEDS TO BE LOWER- WE
WILL DEFINITELY HAVE A
CONVERSATION WERE NOT OPPOSED.
TO THAT- CLARIFICATIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE OBJECTIONS ARE
ONLY BASED ON COVERT FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES- AND CLARIFYING
THAT THE LENGTH OF THE EVICTION
PROTECTIONS IN THE OTHER PART
OF THE BILL. CONSISTENT WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ROOM
EXPIRING NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
END OF THE STATE OF EMERGENCY.
IN ADDITION WE WILL BE PURSUING
AMENDMENTS AND APPROPRIATIONS-
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT THE TWELVE
PREPAYMENT YOU CAN'T WAIT TILL
THE THREE SIXTY. THE IT ALL OFF
WILL HAVE TO BE GRAY. WE WANT
TO TREAT THE LAWN IT'S FAIRLY.
SOMEONE WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
NEW LEASES BETTER BEING ENTERED
INTO OF COURSE ARE NOT COVERED
BY THIS BILL PEOPLE HAVE EYES
WIDE OPEN. SO COLLEAGUES I'M
ASKING YOU TODAY TO GIVE US THE
SPACE TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS BILL. WE KNOW THAT THIS
BILL HAS AN URGENCY COSTS IN IS
A TWO THIRDS VOTE ON THE FLOOR
OF THE SENATE WE KNOW WE HAVE
WORK TO DO. TO GET TO THAT
POINT I KNOW WE WILL GET THERE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFIED WITH THE- IN SPIRIT
UNDER. OR NICOLE FISH. OF
NATIVE CODE A RESTAURANT IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND WHEN IT BOARD IN
WITH THE BAY AREA HOSPITALITY
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER AND IF WE COULD.
GET TO THOSE ARE WITNESSES WHO
I BELIEVE TEST FLYING. BY
TELEPHONE. OF MS. AND IMPORTANT.
YOU HAVE CUT COLLECTIVELY THREE
MINUTES SO. WHO EVER WANTS TO
START BE MINDFUL OF THE AMOUNT
OF TIME BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO
THE- OTHER WITNESS. AND WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. AND INVITE YOU TO
PARTICIPATE. GOOD MORNING
TWENTY MEMBERS I'M NICOLE FISH
AND I'LL BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF NATIVE CO AT. COMPANY THAT I
STARTED EIGHT YEARS AGO WITH MY
FRIEND KILLING ME. I SUPPORT
THE BILL. IN A FEW SHORT MONTHS
OUR BUSINESS ALONG WITH SO MANY
OTHERS HAVE CRUMBLED. AS THEY
BEGIN TO REBUILD WE NEED
LEGISLATIVE HELP HAVE A FAIR
SHOT AT COMING BACK AT ALL.
THIRTEEN IN EARLY FEBRUARY WE
RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
OF COLOR NINETEEN AND TOOK
EVERY MEASURE TO PREPARE FOR
THEM THIRTEEN KIA HAD. HE
PRIORITIZE CASH RESERVES AND
THEREFORE HAVEN'T PAID A CENT.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC OUR
BUSINESS WAS EXAMPLE WE AVERAGE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND AND
MONTHLY REVENUES OF WHICH WE
NEED 325% AND PROFIT. LAST
MONTH DSL DURING PLACE I
REVENUES WERE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. THAT IS THE COST OF
OUR RENT AND WHY THIS SITUATION
IS UNTENABLE. NOT CHIU LANDMARK
ONE OF RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
THE TENANT AND OF THE WORKING
THAT'S REALLY BEGINNING TO
ARRIVE AT AN AGREEMENT THAT
BENEFITS OF BOTH. ONE CAN YOU
HEAR ME O. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
IF YOU G ON. OKAY GREAT. AND
SORRY AND WE HAVE TO ANALYZE
WHAT HAS RECOGNIZED OUR VALUE
ADDED TENANTS AND I'D WORK TO
THAT FROM THE BEGINNING TO
ARRIVE AT AGREEMENT THAT
BENEFIT BUT BOTH. THE OTHER HAS
ONLY AGREED TO A PARTIAL RENT
DEFERMENT. WE WERE SHOCKED EVEN
NOTED INCLUDING AT 10% LATE FEE
FOR BOTH APRIL AND MAY RENT.
AND ALSO A REMINDER OF THEIR
RIGHT THE LEGAL PROCEEDINGS
AGAINST THAT AT THE EARLIEST
CONVENIENCE. WE ARE COULD NOT
GUARANTORS ON THE LEASE AND
WITHOUT THE OPTION TO
RENEGOTIATE OUR RENT WILL BE
FORCED TO CLOSE BOTH OUR
LOCATION. PERMANENTLY LAID OUT
FOR EMPLOYEES. AND THE CAR
PERSONAL BANKRUPTCY WITHIN THE
NEXT THREE MONTHS. IT HAS NEVER
BEEN OUR INTENTION TO USE THAT
DEALT NEGOTIATED SCENARIO IN
WHICH BE UNDULY BENEFIT BALLER
LANDLORDS. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT MY NUMBER
LANDLORDS HAVE OFFERED AT THE
LIGHT BEIN WITHOUT BEING
REQUIRED YOU. SB NINETY NINE
INCENTIVIZE OUR LANDLORDS ARE
OTHER LAND THERE TO DO THE SAME.
TODAY WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING THAT
THE ONE WHO ON OUR BUILDING THE
ONE TO BE KEEP IN BUSINESS
CARDS BACK WELL AS THE REST OF
US WHEN IT COMES TO TAKING
STEPS TOWARD RECOVERY.
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE BUSINESS
BE FELT WE WANT NOTHING MORE
THAN TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING OUR
EMPLOYEES AND CONTRIBUTING FOR
EXAMPLE THE COMPANY. HAVE THE
NINETY NINE AND GIVE A FIVE
NOTHING THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
GOT ABOUT ONE MINUTE MS BORDEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROCEED. THANK
YOU CHAIR JACKSON AND SENATORS
MONEY ON AFFORDABLE DURING
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE BAY
AREA HOW THE COALITION AND WE
WORKED WITH THE FOUNDERS.
WIENER AND WALDRON WELL. FOR
MANY RENT AT THE LARGEST ACOSTA
DOES NOT FLUCTUATE WITH
BUSINESS PERFORMANCE. EXTREMELY
STRONG AND IF REVENUE DEPRESSED
YOU DECLINE. IT CAN ADDICTION
MORE TOWARDS. MORATORIUM IS
CRITICAL AND MANY BUSINESSES
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
UNABLE TO OPERATE. LATELY
SHATTERED HAD AB TO THEM PROP.
MANY BUSINESSES GIVEN TIME WILL
BE ABLE TO REPAY THEIR
BACKGROUND. AS THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO RESUME THEIR NORMAL
BUSINESS OPERATIONS HOWEVER
THIS IS NOT TRUE ABOUT
HOSPITALITY SECTOR. WERE SUMMER
SHATTERED INDEFINITELY IN ALL
OF THEIR BUSINESS OPERATIONS
REDUCE AND THEY SOCIAL THE
IMPACT IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
SHOULD BE NINE THREE NINE IS
ABOUT JOBS. TODAY IT WAS
ANNOUNCED THAT CALIFORNIA HAD
THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
SINCE THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND
HOW THE HOSPITALITY SECTOR
EMPLOYEES LEAD AN UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIM. THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
MANY OF THESE BUSINESSES WILL
BE ABLE TO RE OPEN HIGHER IT
DEPENDED UPON THEIR LARGEST CAR.
BRENT DEATH WANT TO RE OPEN.
AND THEY WANTED YOU IT'S SAFE
FOR IN THEIR- AND WHEN THEY SEE
A FINANCE PASSED FORWARD THANK
YOU MANY WILL HAVE YOUR THANK
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT.
MY APOLOGIES BUT WE ARE GOING
TO TRY TO GET HERE TO THIS
RULES OF THAT WAS A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES AND FORTY SECONDS
AND WE WILL LAW TO THE SAME TO
THE OPPOSITION TO SPEAK. AT
THIS POINT IN TIME ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. A CHEST IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES AND INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE FROM
TWENTY FORTY IS ALSO ON
OCCUPIED WE WILL THEN GO TO.
THE PHONES AND- MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF NINE
THIRTY NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU YES WE CURRENTLY
ALREADY SIXTEEN IN Q. I'LL
REMIND YOU IT IS ONE THING THAT
AND ZERO YOURSELF INTO THE
QUEUE ALL RIGHT AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO INDICATE THATWE
WILL ALLOW ABOUT TEN MINUTES
MAXIMUM FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT TO
A CHEST IDENTIFYING THEM THEIR
NAMES AND AFFILIATIONS AND WE
WILL DO THE SAME FOR THE
OPPOSITION SO. AND AGAIN JUST
NAME AND AFFILIATION WITH A
MAXIMUM UP TO TEN MINUTES OF.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE-
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE PLEASE PROCEED MISTER A
MODERATOR. WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
WILL STE. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR THAT IS LINE
ONE THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU I'M A SMALL BUSINESS
ON AN ORANGE COUNTY SUPPORTING
THIS INITIATIVE OUR EMPLOYEES
LOST THEIR JOBS AND I'VE LOST
MY BUSINESS I SHOULDN'T LOSE MY
HOUSE IN MY CAR THANK YOU SO-
IF WE HAVE TO THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT OUR WITNESS AGAIN YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
OBVIOUSLY. YOUR INDICATION OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WITH THIS. WILL
COME FROM MY NUMBER THREE THREE
THAT'S THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RICHARD HERRING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT OUR
LETTER THAT IN A LITTLE BIT
LATE THE WE'RE STILL DEFINITELY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU AND SENATOR WIENER
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT WITNESSES EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LONG. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX STORES A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF HUGHES MARINO INK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY SIX EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE
IS ALL ON. LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT. NO RESPOND
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
AT IS ONE TO YOUR LIFE AND IS A.
NINE ONE TWENTY TWO WOULD YOU
CHECK FOR ME. ONLY BACKER
UNLESS WE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
TWENTY SIX THAT IS ONE FOUR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IS ABOUT RADO FROM
THAT THAT IF WE GO SERVICES
WHERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
NINETY NINE. OPEN. I BELIEVE
THERE AND THE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION COME ON UP IN THE
PUBLIC LIFE AND YOU'RE IN
ORANGE COUNTY WE ARE IN
COMPORTED DISPEL WE HAVE A FEW
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AMENDMENT
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH SENATOR IN THE CENTER
OFFICE. TO SILICON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
FIFTY CHECK IT. HI THIS IS MATT
READING FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL I'M IN THE WRONG QUEUE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL MY
APOLOGIES RIGHT THANK YOU WELL
NO ACTUALLY REX WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX SEVEN
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JAMES
FOX AND I OWN TWO SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR TWENTY YEARS
THIS IS AN URGENT MATTER FOR
SMALL BUSINESS IT'S AN
EXCESSIVE BURDEN AS THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU GET YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
FIND ONE SELECT ONE ONE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK
YOU MISS JACKSON FOR LESS LET
ME EXPRESS MY OPINION ON THE
BILL HERE I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS AND I'VE NEVER MISTER
RENT PAYMENTS. I COULD YOU GIVE
US YOUR NAME IN A MALL. TEACH
ME COULD YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR HERE.
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION YOU.
BORDERLINE ONE BOOK ELECTRICITY
FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS ON ON BEHALF OF OUR
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT NINE. NINE THREE NINE
AM THANK CENTER WIENER AND WHAT
CENTERS METERING TEN DOLLARS
FOR ADDRESSING AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF OUR RECOVERY THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY NINE FIVE
NINE. SEVEN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JENNIFER ROW
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF GOODWILL INDUSTRIES
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. FOR ONE. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
KEITH MILLER FRANCHISEE
ADVOCACY CONSULTING SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF FRANCHISEES AND
DEALERS AND SUBWAY FRANCHISEES
OF CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS. LINE FOURTEEN IN ONE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ACT HELEN OUT
THE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU CAP
WHAT THEY'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THAT HE NINE THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWENTY NINE TWO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
ROBERTA ECONOMY THESE FROM G.
E. LAW GROUP IN SAN FRANCISCO
WE ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION SB
NINE THREE NINE THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. COULD YOU REPEAT THAT
MISTER MODERATOR I DON'T IT
WASN'T CLEAR TO US IT MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN CLEAR TO THE PERSON
ON THE LINE. THANKS LINE ELEVEN
AND WHEN ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MADAM CHAIR MATS SET
IN THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE- MORATORIUM AND
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS
LOOKING AT SECTION TWO OF THE
BILL WITH THE NEW AMENDMENTS.
AND THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE IN
THE LARGER DISCUSSION ON RENT
RELIEF AND THE NEW SENATE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS PROPOSAL ARE
THINGS THAT WE LOOK FOR TO
STAYING ENGAGE WITH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. FIND ONE THIRTY EIGHT
ONE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SIX WITNESS
PLEASE MR MODERN. THANK YOU
ONLINE ONE THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
THIRTEEN FIND YEAH HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME THAT'S YES. DAMON WYLER
FROM SAYING COMMITTEE I OPPOSE
NINE THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU WE
ARE STILL IN THE SUPPORT OF
POSITION BUT WE WILL KNOW CHORE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SIR OTHER
OF MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES CUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THIRTY NINE.
I HAVE. THREE CURRENTLY LEFT IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD GO AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVEN
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS WALTER SHIELD I SUPPORT SB
NINE THREE NINE A RESTAURANT
OWNER IN LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. ONE TWENTY EIGHT
ONE TWO WEEKS YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GO AHEAD ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT WE'RE
WE'RE WAITING FOR YOU THE LINE.
THANK YOU OVERTURN A LINE ONE
ELEVEN ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS KATIE COSTS AND I'M A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BACK THEN
WE NED TO HAVE GUESTS PASS
IMMEDIATELY IT EITHER THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS. OKAY
ONE MORE LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO.
LINE IS OPEN. IF I'M TWENTY TWO
YOUR VOLUME IS IT STRICTLY LOW.
WHAT SO THANK YOU YES. WALL ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THIS ROD
WRITER ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE WAITING TO
TESTIFY INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE THIRTY NINE. I HAVE
ONE MORE. THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED- CARL THANK YOU WILL
GET A LINE WE WANT ONE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TEN
PLEASED FOR MUTE. ARE THEY
STILL ON THE PHONE JUST MUTED
TO MISTER MOTOR INNER. NO
RESPONSE ON THE LINE IT DOES
EXHAUST THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THERE ARE
NO OTHERS WILL GIVE A MOMENTOUS
IF YOU WERE INTENDING TO SPEAK
AND SOMEHOW GOT DROPPED WILL
GIVE ABOUT FIVE SECONDS TO GET
YOU BACK ON THE LINE SO THAT
YOU CAN INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT.
BEFORE WE GO TO THE OPPOSITION.
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA RETURN TO
LINE ONE TEN ONE CHECK YOUR
OPEN. AND WE ARE NOT HEARING
AUDIO SELECT YOUR PHONE FOR ME
WHAT. ALL RIGHT WE SEEM TO BE
HAVING SOME CHALLENGES HERE. IS
THERE SOME A DIRECTIVE A MISTER
MODERATOR THAT YOU MIGHT GIVE
TO PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IT AND EXPLAIN WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE SO MANY EMPTY- SO MUCH
EMPTY HERE I SUSPECT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOPING TO SPEAK
BUT FOR SOMEHOW. SOME REASON
OTHER AND NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
THEIR THEIR CALLS. OKAY TO BE
CLEAR TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ENSURE THAT YOUR PHONE IS NOT
ON MUTE STATUS AND THE PLEASE
BE AWARE OF YOUR LINE NUMBER
ONE IT'S CALLED UPON. THANK
YOU. FIND ONE FORTY NINE. ONE
FOUR NINE WHATEVER LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS DAVE BUT WE'RE
REPRESENTING THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK A COALITION OF
LOCAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WILL NOTE
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO FINISH UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE LEFT IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THIRTY NINE
WHO'D LIKE TO GIVE US THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. MISTER MODERATOR FIND
OUT WILL GO TO. FIND NINE ONE
SEVEN. SO. WOULD YOU REPEAT
THAT MISTER MODERATOR IT WAS
MODELED AND I SUSPECT THE
INDIVIDUAL DIDN'T HEAR THEIR
NUMBER BEING CALLED. BY POP IN
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO. I
GET OPEN ONE SEVEN NINE. RIGHT.
WE CAN START WITH HER ONE MORE
TIME BE HELPFUL IF WE COULD GET
A SENSE OF WHO IS IN SUPPORT
AND WHO IS IN OPPOSITION WE ARE
STILL AT THE SUPPORT LEVEL.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR PHONE OFF OF
ME MUTE. WHEN THE MODERATOR
CALLS YOUR NUMBERS THEN JUST
SIMPLY. GO AHEAD AND START
SPEAKING YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
BY THE MODERATOR. LEAVE YOUR
PHONE- TAKE TAKE IT OFF THE
MUTE BUTTON. ALRIGHT LET'S TRY
AGAIN MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THIRTY NINE. AND YOU
ENTER IN ADDITION YOU MAY
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE
BY REPEATING THE ONE AND ZERO.
WE DON'T GO TO YOUR LINE. AND
IT WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN ONE SEVEN SEVEN
AND IT OPENS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME'S FRANCISCO A ON
BEHALF OF A GROUP OF MERCHANTS
AT PACIFIC KROLL- IN PLEASANTON
CALIFORNIA WE ARE YOU GOING TO
PART OF THE SB. THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT PLEASE BOOK
THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY TWO WINE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE NINETY TWO. HEARING
THE AUDIO FROM ONE ONE NINETY
TWO. HI AGAIN A MISTER
MODERATOR PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE
THEIR PHONES OFF OF MUTE YOU
ARE YOU WILL HOLD THEM ON MUTE
UNTIL YOU CALL THEIR NUMBER AND
THEN YOU RELEASE THEM. SO THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ON MUTE
INSECT CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT
ALRIGHT SO LET'S BE CLEAR LET'S
TRY ONE MORE TIME IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
THIRTY NINE. TAKE YOUR PHONE
OFF OF MUTE. AND THE MODERATOR
WILL CALL UPON YOU AND WILL
OPEN YOUR LINE. SO THAT YOU CAN
SPEAK IN INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE ITEM. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR PERSONAL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE ONE EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE
IS IN. ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. THIS IS JOHN
WEDGEWOOD AND CALLING IT
BEFORE- NOT THE COURT OF THE
BILL. SACRAMENTO REAL ESTATE
AGENT. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
ON THE LINE. WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE THIRTY
NINE WE WILL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION MOMENTARILY BUT ANY
OTHER ANY PEOPLE LEFT WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE THIRTY NINE. JUST
TO REITERATE IT YOU ARE IN THE
QUEUE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
THE SUPPORT CUBA BY PUTTING ONE
THEN IS HERO ONCE AGAIN. WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER WATER
AND HE THREE ONE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BETTER YES YOU
ARE WE CAN HEAR OPEN. I AM ONLY
ENOUGH TO DO IT WAS HOLLYWOOD
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE THREE
NINE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE BEEN ADVISED WE'VE GONE
OVER TEN MINUTES- ONLY BECAUSE
OF THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
WERE HAVING OF MISTER MODERATOR
AGAIN ONE LAST TIME IS THERE
ANYONE LEFT WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB. NINE THIRTY
NINE AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION. AT ABOUT DOZEN LEFT
IN Q. CORRECTION I WILL GO TO
LINE A- HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
ONE SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS EDDIE NUMBER
AT WITH THE INDEPENDENT
HOSPITALITY COALITION FOUR
HUNDRED INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS
LOS ANGELES CAP. WE WILL ASSUME
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT BECAUSE YOU
ARE IN THE SUPPORT Q. NEXT ONE
PLEASE MISTER MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE NINE WE
FIND FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT NUMBER WAS CENTER. NINETY
FOUR. BRENT WOODS THE MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ONE. THANK YOU LINE
WONDERED IN TEN ONE TEN IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE HUNDRED AND
TEN WE'RE HEARING AUDIO. WE'VE
GOT TO RE QUEUE THEY MAY HAVE
INADVERTENTLY PUT THEMSELVES
BACK INTO THE QUEUE ONCE AGAIN
WILL GO TO LINE NINETY SEVEN
NOT. IS OPEN. AGAIN TAKE YOUR
PHONE OFF OF THE MUTE BUTTON IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. TAKE IT OFF
THE MUTE. ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ONE PLEASE. WHAT A
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND ONE. ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE TO A ONE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR PHONE OFF OF
MUTE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. JIM
CARE PROPERTY OWNER OF WHAT IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS IS IT WILL
CAUSE ME TO. ALL RIGHT THIS IS
A SUPPORT Q. AND THAT DOES
ACOSTA SUPPORT Q. AT THE TIME.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION AND-
AGAIN WE WILL HAVE TO WITNESSES
ARE THERE ANY THE PEOPLE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB NINE THIRTY
NINE. SEEING NONE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S NO IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MILE
UNDERSTANDING ALSO IS WE HAVE
TO- OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. ROB LAPSLEY AND SIR AND
SHAPIRO. IS THAT CORRECT ARE
YOU ON THESE CALLS ON THE PHONE.
YES MEDICARE HEART YET SO-
PLEASE PROCEED YOU WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES AND
FORTY SECONDS- YOU CAN DIVIDE
IT ANY WAY YOU WISH. BUT YOU
MAY GO AHEAD AND START AND THE
I WILL BE KEEPING THAT TIME. SO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS THE MORNING MY NAME IS
ROB LAPS WE PRESENT A
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE
AND JOINING ME TODAY TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE THIRTY
NINE. DURING THIS CRISIS WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EMERGENCY
ORDINANCES AND RUN CAPS
ADDICTIONS. AND OTHER ISSUES
AND MULTI FAMILY AND COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES SECTORS. YOU KNOW WE
SUPPORT THESE PUBLIC POLICY
MATTERS AND WE CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THEY WORK
SUCCESSFULLY FOR PROPERTY
OWNERS AND FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES. BUT DURING THIS
INCREDIBLY STRESSFUL TIME WE
FOCUSED ON THE CHALLENGE THAT A
CRISIS IN ONE OR MORE SECTORS
OF OUR ECONOMY DUE TO THIS
PANDEMIC COULD NOT AND SHOULD
NOT BE A CATALYST FOR PUBLIC
POLICIES THAT CREATE IN CASCADE
A CRISIS. IN OTHER SECTORS SUCH
AS HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY BUT WE FACE SAID AGAIN
TODAY IN SB NINE THIRTY NOT. SO
MADAM CHAIR AT THE GOAL IS TO
HELP RESTAURANTS THE STATE
SHOULD PRIORITIZE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND HELP SUPPORT
RESTAURANT. NOT UNFAIRLY SHOULD
TO CRISIS TO PROPERTY OWNERS
WHICH WILL IN TURN SHOULD THE
CRISIS TO BANKS AND THEN TO
SHAREHOLDERS. WHICH IN REALITY
OR MANY OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO ARE TRYING TO HELP.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT THIS BILL
IS SIGNIFICANT CONSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEMS WE HOPE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE CLEAR AND PERSUASIVE
ENOUGH TO VOTE NO ON THE
MEASURE. IF NOT WE WILL BE
PURSUING THESE ISSUES IN THE
COURTS AS NEEDED. I KNOW
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING DISCUSSED
WE WILL LOOK AT THESE UNDER
CONSIDERATION THAT THEY DO NOT
CASCADE A WHOLE NEW CRISIS. AND
OTHER SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY.
SB NINE THIRTY NINE CANNOT SEND
THE WRONG MESSAGE. FOR THE
FUTURE CAPITAL INVESTMENT WE
NEED TO GROW OUT OF THIS
RECESSION. AND TO BE ABLE TO
RETURN WORKERS BACK TO THEIR
JOBS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER LAPSLEY AND THAT'S WHERE
WE HAVE THE COURTS IF. AT SOME
POINT THERE THERE'S A CONCERN
ABOUT THE LEGITIMACY OF ANY
MEASURE THAT PASSES
LEGISLATURE. WE ARE DELIGHTED
TO OPEN UP THE COURTS FOR THAT
RESOLUTION SHOULD IT BE
APPROPRIATE SO. WITH THAT- MID
SHIP HERE ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
HERE AND SHAPIRO WITH BY MY
CALIFORNIA. STANGEL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL ON PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS NOT APPROPRIATE OR
REASONABLE AND THE BILL IS
THERE FOR CON ON
CONSTITUTIONAL. WE THEREFORE
SUGGEST THE FOLLOWING ONE
FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS ARGUES
THAT IF YOU ARE GOING TO FOR
RENT THE PORTION OF RENT TO BE
DEFERRED SHOULD BE PRO RATED
BASED ON THE PROPORTION OF LOTS
OF REVENUE. ABSOLUTE TENANTS
REVENUE IS DOWN 40% BUT ONLY
40% OF RENT SHOULD BE DEFERRED.
DID YOU OTHERWISE GIVE THEY
WOULD FALL TO THE TENANT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE LANDLORD. IF
TENANTS DO NOT PAY THE DEFERRED
WRITTEN ON TIME UNDER THEIR NEW
SCHEDULE AND ALL LATE FEES AND
INTEREST CHARGES SHOULD BE
REINSTATED. THIS WOULD
INCENTIVIZE TENANTS TO PERFORM
THEIR PART OF THE DEAL AND DOES
NOT ADD ANY BURDEN TO THEM IF
THEY PERFORM. THREE REQUIREMENT
THAT LAMBERT'S HAVE TO SEND
NOTICE ABOUT TWO O'CLOCK. AND
THE DAY. BURDENSOME IT WILL
COST. OF DOLLARS. INSTEAD THIS
LED. SHOULD ONLY REQUIRE A
DISCO IN ANY NOTICE THAT
THREATENS FORFEITURE OF THE
LEAST FOR MONETARY DEFAULT. TO
THE INFORMATION GETS TO THE
TENANT WHEN IT MATTERS. FINALLY
SECTION TWO OF THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY AND SHOULD BE
DROPPED IN ITS ENTIRETY.
SECTION ONE COVERS ALL TENANTS
AND RESTAURANT SHOULD NOT GET A
BETTER DEAL. IT IS NOT
NECESSARY TO COUNSEL LEASES AND
GUARANTEES TO SERVE THE STATED
PURPOSES OF THE BILL. IF THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL THAT
JUSTIFIES CUTTING INTO
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT JUST TO
KEEP THEM. IN THEIR SPACES AND
GIVING SOME TENANTS THE RIGHT
TO TERMINATE THEIR LEASES TURNS
OUT ON ITS HEAD. AND EXCUSING
GUARANTORS WHO ALWAYS RAN THE
RISK OF THE TENET GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS IF I'M CALLED FOR I
REASONABLE AND INAPPROPRIATE.
WE ARE EARNING NO VOTE ON THE
NINE THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NARROW
STE GO TO. THE PHONE SING.
OTHER OTHER WOULD. ON
OPPOSITION HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE. SEEING NON AND NO ONE'S
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONES. FOR PEOPLE TO
GIVE THEIR NAME. AND
AFFILIATION. AND INDICATE THEIR
OPPOSITION. ARE WE GONNA GIVE
THIS TEN MINUTES AND MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD.
CONTINUALLY RE ASSURE PEOPLE
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE THEIR
PHONES TAKEN OFF THE MUTE
BUTTON SO THEY CAN BE HEARD. OF
WOULD YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
QUEUE UP THOSE PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. SB NINE THIRTY OR
NINE. GOING OUT OF THE CALL FOR
REASONABLE AND INAPPROPRIATE WE
THEREFORE URGE VOTE ON SB NINE
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU WE THINK
WE ARE WE NEEDING TO TAKE A
BREAK SO WE CAN GET OUR SYSTEM-
MORE EFFECTIVELY OPERATING.
WE'LL SET. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
AHEAD THEN MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE REMIND PEOPLE
TO ON MUTE THEIR PHONES AS THEY
GET IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE THIRTY
NINE MISTER MODERATOR.
CERTAINLY. ONE THAT YOUR PHONE
IS NOT ON MUTE STATUS WE WILL
GO TO A LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN AND WOULD YOU MISTER
MODERATE. EXCUSE ME EXCUSE ME
WHICH YOU INDICATE HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT.
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN ALL
RIGHT IF ALL OF YOU WANT TO BE
HEARD YOU GO TO MAKE IT QUICK
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES
PROCEED PLEASE. YOUR LIGHTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS
COUNCIL THE BILL CONFLICTS WITH
FAA REGULATIONS THANK YOU YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. NEXT WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE. THANK
YOU LINE ONE NINETY ONE ON YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
HARGROVE IN ORDER TO SAVE YOU
TIME I'M EXPRESSING OPPOSITION
ON BEHALF OF EIGHT SEPARATE
GROUPS CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL OF
SHOPPING CENTERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS OF THECOMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION
NAY OP BUILDING OWNERS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. RETAIL INDUSTRY
LEADERS ASSOCIATION REAL ESTATE
MANAGEMENT. NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF REAL ESTATE
INVESTMENT TRUST AND I OUR C.
R. T. WE RESPECTFULLY URGEA NO
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO
YOU'RE IN. AND SIX ZERO. ONE
SIXTY YOUR. MIND OPEN. NEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW. I HAD
THIS ROCKING I REPRESENT- THREE
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS
AND- IN THE BAY AREA AND WATCH
CHANGE WAS AN ORANGE COUNTY AS
WELL AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION WE. AND
YOU ARE OPPOSITE TO NINE THIRTY
NINE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN ONE FOUR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ADAM REGULAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT. AND AMENDMENTS WE ARE
OPPOSED UNLESS FURTHER
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKEN AND WE
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU SO SIX
WITNESS PLEASE. IT A LINE IN
NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT WILL GO TO LINE HE NINE
SEVEN YEAR ONE NINETY SEVEN
BLACK. NUMBER NINE. HI MISTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. IT IT
WAS A LITTLE LINE NUMBER NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN NINETY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN THIS IS JOHN BAKER
AMOROSOS ATTORNEY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YEAH I OPPOSE THE
BILL BECAUSE HE DOES NOT.
FACTORED OKAY SIR THANK ROBERTS
LONG. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO TONIGHT ON
YOUR LINE IS A YEAH MY NAME IS
JEFF PALMER I'M A SMALL
LANDLORD IN LOS ANGELES I HAVE
BORROWED MUCH MONEY TO BUILD
OUT MY TENANT SPACES THANK YOU
TO MY TENANTS ARE STRONGER THAN
ME THEIR HEDGE FUNDS. IN EQUITY
COMPANIES THANK YOU SIR YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE IT NEXT NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK OR LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY. ZERO ONE
FIVE ZERO. DO I'M SORRY MR
MODERATE WHAT WAS THAT NUMBER
AGAIN PLEASE. YOUR ACTORS ZERO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR PHONE OFF OF
MUTE NUMBER ONE FIVE ZERO.
ALRIGHT MR MODERATOR WOULD YOU
MOVE TO THE NEXT WITNESS. I
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE IN A
FIFTEEN. FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU ANDY LEAVE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
HAPPILY WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ON AMENDMENTS BUT CURRENTLY
MUST BE RESPECTFULLY OF. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. SIXTY SIX
THAT IS ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING AT YOUR
JACKSON MEMBERS KAREEM GREASY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OFREALTORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWO TWO ZERO TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
FAITH FORGIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE TWO
ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR THERE MIGHT FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE SB NINE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT ONE
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS PATRICIA
TOWARDS BRUNO AND I AM
REPRESENTING A LOT. NUMBER OF
COMMERCE. THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE HUNDRED AND SEC ONE I. FELT
I'M SORRY WE TRY THAT AGAIN
WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE YOU'RE
SOUNDING MODELED WHAT IS THE
NUMBER MISTER MODERATOR. NUMBER
IS ONE HUNDRED AND. SEVENTY
FIVE ONE SEVENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MORE A TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MA'AM SIX WITNESS PLEASE. AT I
WONDERED IN EIGHTEEN ONE ONE
EIGHT. HI THIS IS A TEACHER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. FROM
LINE TO HUNDRED AND SAID. ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LONG OPEN TO SEVEN
DANAN COMBINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA UILDERS YEAH
ALLIANCE AS WELL AS TALK ON A
REGIONAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE AND
MARKETS ANALYST CHAP COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE INVESTMENT SERVICES
RESPECTFULLY. TWENTY FIVE ONE
TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS KELLY A FATHER FROM
SACRAMENTO AND AYE OPPOSED SB
NINE THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
BUT IN FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS A LIVE LOOK CLOSE MASK ON
BEHALF OF BURKE FOR PROPERTY
GROUP IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND NINE TWO ZERO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS PAT D'ANGELO I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION
WEBER OPPOSED POSITION ON SB
NINE THREE NINE. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WITNESS. NOT A LINE OF
ONE. SIXTY FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE
ONE IS DONE. ONE SIXTY FIVE
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ANTHONY ANTHONY HELP
AND RESCUE CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. I MEAN WE CAN.
TWO ONE THE COURT FOR EXCEL
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AND I'M
SORRY SEVENTEEN TURNING. YES
JOHN POWER WITH POWER BACK TO
BILL THANK YOU WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB NINE THREE NINE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
WE'VE GOT TWO MINUTES LEFT NEXT
WITNESS. FIND SEVENTY ONE SEVEN
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI OUR
TRAVEL FROM SANTA MONICA FAMILY
MEMBER OF THE COMMERCIAL THEIR
LORD PUT IN THE BILL BECAUSE
LITTLE INCREASE OUR RISK
FORECLOSURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WHAT'S
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE UP MISTER
MODERATOR HOW MANY FOLKS ARE
LEFT IN THE QUEUE. ABOUT TEN
VERY GOOD LET'S GO AHEAD WITH
THE NEXT ONE PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY LINE EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING GENE
SOUTHWEST CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL SOUTHWEST
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS EXPRESSING STRONG
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITE. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS. LITTLE. I DID
LIKE DON'T JUMP AROUND ON ME
HERE ONE MOMENT. FINE EIGHTY
EIGHT. IT OPENS. GOOD MORNING
HOW TO GIVE ALL THE BEHALF
MARKETS MILITIA ACCORDING
CALABASAS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ALIGN
NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINETY EIGHT.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. EUROPEANS CAME A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER SMALL FAMILY
OFFICE WE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE THEY WERE LIKE YOU SIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDICATION
OF OPPOSITION NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LITTLE LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN TO ONE EIGHT TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KEVIN GOAL TO
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WHAT A LINE. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT ONE THREE
EIGHT. ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON PLEASE
WE'LL HAVE WHERE WE HAVE I
BELIEVE FIVE MORE. AND WE ARE
PASSED OR TEN MINUTE LIMIT-
WILL HAVE ONE MORE AND THEN THE
REST WE WILL ASSUME ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION LAST WITNESS PLEASE.
NAME AND AFFILIATION NUMBER
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU ONE
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE ONE
EIGHT NINE. FOLLOW US ON
WEDGEWOOD BROKERS SACRAMENTO IN
OPPOSITION OF AT THE NINE THREE
NINE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE
WILL SHIP AGAIN THE OTHER FOR
FAR THE LINE ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. WE WILL NOW BRING
THE MATTER TO THE DYESS AND
START WITH SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
MOVE THE ITEM AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AFTER WE HAVE
DISCUSSION. YES AND I JUST SAY
THANK YOU TO MY PARTNER AND
COLLEAGUE AS SENATOR WIENER- I
KNOW THIS IS NOT AN EASY
pSOLUTION AND CERTAINLY WERE WE
WERE WE TO WORK WITH ALL STAKE
MYSELF AND SENATOR WIENER HAVE
MET WITH BAY AREA HOSPITALITY-
BOMA LALONG BEACH COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY OWNERS AMONG MANY
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS
SMALL. THIS IS. THE FACT IS
THAT WITH THE NUMBER SEE THE
STATE HAS THE UP RESPONSIBILITY
TO STEP IN. MANY OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND RESTAURANTS WERE
DIRECTED TO GO OFF LINE IN
OPERATIONS FIRST. AS WELL AS
NONPROFITS AND MANY DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO SB A OR P. P. P.
LOANS THAT WERE. AVAILABLE AT
THREE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
M. IN IN REGARD TO THE P. T.
LOANS MANY OF US HAVE TOLD US
THAT THERE'S A VERY SHORT EIGHT
WEEK WINDOW THAT THEY HAVE TO
FILL. NEARLY 75% OF THEIR
PAYROLL THEY CANNOT DO THAT AT
THIS TIME. AND 25% OF THE
FORGIVENESS WOULD POTENTIALLY
GO TO RENT AND UTILITY BUT
AGAIN THEY HAVE. A CUP. OR
OPERATING INCOME TO BE ABLE TO
PAY UP. TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THEIR THEIR EXPENSES AS MANY OF
US KNOW AS WELL AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED AT THE THREE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN CAPITAL RAN
OUT IN TWO WEEKS. AND MANY OF
THEM ARE NOW ON. PENDEK
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
ALL SELF EMPLOYED AND THEY HAVE
NOWHERE ELSE TO TURN. GO BUT I
BUT I WILL SAY IS THAT YOU
KNOW. MANY COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
OWNERS I KNOW THEY HAVE. A
ISSUES NOW- WITH THIS BILL IN
TERMS OF LENDERS THEY WANT TO
KNOW. THANK YOU ARE. GOING AND
HAVE. THING AND WAS PART IN
GOOD FAITH WITH MANY OF THEIR
SMALL BUSINESS TENANTS AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH US SENATOR
WIENER AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
AS WELL TO ENSURE THAT WE GET
THIS RIGHT- AND WE REALLY
THINK. SINGLE STAKEHOLDER FOR
CALLING IN TODAY TRENCH. DO
WHAT'S BEST FOR CASH BORN IN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SO CENTER Y. KOWSKI.
YEAH I HAVE I. I'M BEING
CONSTITUTIONALLY CHALLENGED
HERE AND I'D WANT TO MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND ON THE DEFINITIONS
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH IN SECTION.
A HIGH IT'S DONE SIX OR SECTION
ONE IN. HER STARTING A
PARAGRAPH SIX IT STARTS ABOUT
ELIGIBILITY YOU'VE GOT 20%
DECLINE IN YOUR SALES YOU
COULDN'T OPEN BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC IN AND IT SAYS FIFTEEN
PERCENT. DECLINE IN YOUR
CAPACITY DUE TO A PUBLIC.
HEALTH ORDER AN OFFICIAL PUBLIC
HEALTH- THEN YOU DROP IN THIS
SECTION TO AND IT LOOKS AS
THOUGH IT'S GETTING MORE
GENEROUS ON ELIGIBILITY OF
RESTAURANT IT SAYS YOU HAVE A
TWENTY HE GETS INTO THE THIRD.
COMPOUND TWENTY FIVE FIRST US
OF A CAPACITY TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH MINISTER. IT WHY THE
DIFFERENCE I'M NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENCE
AND THEN I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION I BUT WHAT IT'S THANK
YOU ARE TO THE CHAIR. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU I THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION BECAUSE THESE
ARE TWO COMPLETELY DIFFERENT-
SECTIONS AT THAT ADDRESS
DIFFERENT SOME OVERLAPPING
DIFFERENT ISSUES ON SECTION TWO
WITH THE 25% DROPPING CAPACITY
OR FORTY PERCENT. REDUCTION IN
REVENUE IS NOT MORE GENEROUS
IT'S LAST TIME YES IT'S MUCH
MORE RESTRICTIVE AND THE REASON
WE WENT THERE IS SECTION
SECTION ONE APPLIES TO EVERYONE
BUSINESSES NONPROFITS. IT'S
SIMPLY A TEMPORARY PAUSE IN
ELECTIONS AND YOU REPAY ALL
YOUR ROUNDS PLACE TO EVERYONE
AND SO IT IS MORE IS PROPER
SECTION TO WHICH OF COURSE
PLANTLIFE ACOSTA TALLY IS WE
ARE KNOWLEDGE IS A MUCH MORE.
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH AS A RESULT
WE MAKE YOU HAVE TO BE IN MORE
EXTREME TRAITS START THAT
BRUSHES OFFER THIS. BETWEEN THE
TWO WE WHAT WE'RE BEING MORE
GENEROUS WITH SECTION ONE THE
BLIND A MORATORIUM. ON ME MUCH
MORE RESTRICTIVE IN WHO CAN
QUALIFY FOR THE RENEGOTIATION
POTENTIAL LEASE TERMINATION
BECAUSE IT IS A MORE AGGRESSIVE
APPROACH I WAS THE RATIONALE.
SO I GUESS WITH THE AS I
UNDERSTAND ARE AT A PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS WE'VE GOT IS WE
LOOK IN THE AUDIENCE HERE WE
HAVE A LOT TO SIGN THIS IS A
SIX. PART WHAT IS THIS IS.
AFFECTED BY 15% OF CAPACITY
WITH THE PUBLIC- YEAH THE GIRL
AT THE PUBLIC. HEALTH ORDER I
DO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO
THAT WOULD BE THE GOAL THE
GOAL. ON SECTION ONE THE-
EVICTION MORATORIUM THE GOAL IS
TO BE BROAD. BECAUSE WE WANT TO
HAVE STABILITY SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THESE OBJECTIONS AND THEN
PEOPLE PAY BACK THE RENT. GOAL
IN SEARCH TO. BE MUCH MORE
RESTRICTIVE I IN TERMS OF THE
MOST IMPACTED BUSINESSES SO
WE'VE INTENTIONALLY BEEN MORE-
BROADER IN SECTION ONE. BECAUSE
IT IS A LESS AGGRESSIVE POLICY
INTERVENTION IT'S SIMPLY A
DELAY IN PAYING THE BUT THE
RENT WILL BE PAID BACK- AND SO
THAT THAT'S WHY. WE ARE WE'RE
INTENT THE BROADER THAT I DON'T
WANT HIM IN THE COMMITTEE
BEFORE THE AMENDMENTS. THE
COURSE OF ACTION OF MORE
TRANSLATE TO THERE WAS NO
REQUIREMENT FOR A DROP IN
REVENUE. FOR AND I OUR CAPACITY
WE TOOK THAT AS A COMMITTEE A
I'M AND WE APPROPRIATE AS- BUT
BUT I'M I'M NOT. BUT THIS. TIME
THE TO BE MORE CONFIDENT CONTRA.
SOME CHAIR IF I LOOK AT FOR OF
BLADE BETTER EXCELLENCE BEFORE
ONE AGAIN FROM WHOEVER WROTE TO
STAFF REPORT AND IN SPEND
TEACHES US THAT THE STATE CAN
IMPAIR ONTRACTS BUT THEY HAVE
TO BE REASONABLE AND
APPROPRIATE. FIFTY RESULT IF
EVERYBODY'S COLLUDED IN IN THE
CATCH WORSE THAT. WHERE IS THAT
LIMITATION ON THE IMPAIRMENT OF
CONTRACTS BECAUSE I AGAIN I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE IS
THE BUSINESS THAT HASN'T HAD
15% OF THEIR SPACE. LIMITED BY
PUBLIC HEALTH WATER. SO AND WE
AND AGAIN THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE- FOR THE DISTINCTION
SECTION TO. THIS LIMITED TO THE
HOSPITALITY AND IS A MORE
AGGRESSIVE INTERVENTION WITH
THE POTENTIAL FOR LEASE
TERMINATION. WE TOOK A HIGH
SENATE FOR THE ADDICTION
MORATORIUM BECAUSE IT IS A LESS
AGGRESSIVE INTERVENTION- I
THINK IT WOULD BE A MUCH WEAKER
CASE FOR IMPAIRMENT CONTRACT.
AND WE HAVE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. WE HAVE EXISTING
COMMERCIAL MORATORIUM. NORTH
KOREA IN OUT IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
FOR THAT DO NOT REQUIRE ANY
DROP IN BUSINESS THEY SIMPLY
PUT A MORATORIUM IN PLACE ONE
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL. TO
MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO AND SO
WE'RE ACTUALLY BEING MORE
RESTRICTIVE IN SOME WAYS AND IS
LOCAL MORE TORIA THAT ARE
ALREADY BEING FORCED RIGHT NOW.
I AM SURE ONE MORE QUESTION AND
JUST IT IT SEEMS THAT THE-
ELEMENT HERE IS THE COMMERCIAL
BANKS TO HOLD THE PAPER. ARE
YOU KNOW ON THAT AND FUND THE
MANAGER OF THE- OLD ORDER OWNER
OF THE BUILDING AND IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THEY- ARE NOT. FOR
CLOSURES WHICH IS WHAT
EVERYBODY USES AT THE LANGUAGE
ONCE YOU GO INTO THE OLD. A ANY
PARTIAL PAYMENT IS THE TEAM AS
A CURE YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU.
DON'T LET AP SHOW ME PAYMENT.
NUMBER TAKE THE THERE'S AN
ONLINE FIRST TO REAL HAVE THESE
PAR PAY HEARD SOMEBODY OPPOSITE
SAYING WE WOULD LIKE TAKES WHO
PEOPLE TO DO THE THAT THEY OF
YOUR BILL WITHOUT FORTY PER
PLAYED 40% THAT'S IN HERE AT
ALL AND THERE'S NO DISCUSSION
OF DEAL ADDRESSING THAT DEFAULT
AND ACCEPTING PARTIAL PAYMENTS
WITH THE COMMERCIAL BANKS AS
PART OF THE THREE WAY THAT'S-
IT'S A TWO WAY NAY SO IN TERMS
OF THE LOANS IT. IS CHALLENGING
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW AND I'M
HAPPY TO FOR CONVERSATION WITH
YOU BECAUSE I'M THIS IS YOUR
SISTER AROUND SENATE YOU'RE A
YOU'RE YOU'RE DEFINITELY AN
EXPERT HERE AND- WE- IT IS MUCH
MORE LIMITED JURISTIC UNDER
BORROWER RELATIONSHIP AND SO WE
HAVE A CHALLENGE WITH THIS
PANDEMIC BUT THERE'S SOME
THINGS THAT ARE FEDERAL THERE'S
SOME SORT OF STATE THERE'S
SOMETHING SORT OF LOCAL AND
SOMETIMES PART. ENTER BLOCK
THAT. WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK ON
WAYS TO ADDRESS- THE LENDER-
ISSUE AND IN TERMS OF PARTIAL
PAYMENTS WE TRY NOT TO BE
MICROMANAGING ABOUT HOW THINGS
GO RENEGOTIATED. AND SUPPORT
YOU KNOW- TO SAY WHAT THE RENT
SHOULD BE OR WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO BE. BROAD AND JUST TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE BRINGING PEOPLE
TO THE TABLE SO THAT'S THE-
THAT'S THE TRUTH. THANK THANK
YOU SIR ASKING THE- RON SO.
YEAH THIS IS A BIT IT BROUGHT
UP A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS
AND I TALKED TO. OF BOTH SMALL
BUSINESSES SMALL LANDLORDS AS
WELL AS- LARGE- LARGE LAND
OWNERS AND- SAUCE I WAS
THINKING ABOUT HOW. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL HERE OF OUR OUR
APPROACH YOU KNOW IN THE
RESIDENTIAL. THERE'S A GREATER
IMBALANCE BECAUSE- THE SUPPLY
IS SO SMALL AND THE DEMAND IS
SO MASSIVE. SO ARMED MEN A
STATE IS. REALLY TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BRING A LITTLE MORE
BALANCED TO AND I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THE SAME THING
HERE. THIS BUSINESS SMALLERAND
SMALLER BIGELOW TRYING TO GET
THEM TO THE POINT OF TAKING
DOING SERIOUS NEGOTIATIONS SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO GET INTO
THE WEEDS OF IT AND TRY TO-
FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION THAT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME TIME- NO
YOU WANT TO WE DO WANT TO
PROTECT THE SMALL COMMERCIAL
TEN. TEN AND UP AND I AGREE
WITH OF PROTECTING SMALL
BUSINESSES WE'VE WE'VE HEARD
THAT MANY MANY TIMES IN MY
DISTRICT THERE'S- THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
SMALL RESTAURANTS- NEIGHBORHOOD
SHOPS. I BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
LARGER COMMERCIAL TENANTS-
DON'T OF WITH RESOURCES THAT
THEY DON'T AVOID PAIN RENDON
THEY DON'T SLIP THROUGH HERE SO
I WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE ARE
LARGE RETAILERS WHO ARE-
FLOURISHING. I KNOW THAT'S OF.
THAT'S THAT'S A THAT'S THE KIND
OF BUSINESS THAT I DON'T THINK
SHOULD SLIP THROUGH HERE SO.
WITH BAD ARE A- A NEW AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS IS HOW
DO WE- JUST SOME IDEAS IN TERMS
OF- WHO. COULD BE OR SHOULD BE
EXCLUDED OR NOT GIVING THAT
KIND OF PROTECTION- YOU INCLUDE
PUBLICLY TRADED TENANTS- MAYBE-
EXPANDING TO COVER TENANTS THAT
ARE FROM MULTINATIONAL
COMPANIES AN AFFILIATE. OF I
KNOW YOU HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES AS THE AS THE
DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESS. I
DON'T SEE FIVE AND AS A SMALL
BUSINESS- AND I WOULD REALLY
URGE A MUCH MUCH SMALLER NUMBER
BECAUSE THAT'S WERE REALLY
TRYING TO DEFEND THE TIME AND
PROTECT. OF THE TEND TO HAVE OF
EXCLUDE THOSE WHO HAVE MORE
THAN THREE LOCATIONS SO I THINK
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS- TO MAKE
SURE AGAIN THAT IT'S REALLY THE
SMALL BUSINESS AND NOT A LARGER
BUSINESS. UP SOME. I ANOTHER
CAR HERE I'D LIKE TALK ABOUT IT
IS. THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
LOCAL CITIES AND ORDINANCES AND
THE STATE COULD YOU DESCRIBE IF
THERE'S A CONFLICT OR THE SO
MANY OF THEM HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH THAT YOUR SMALL
BUSINESS EDITOR THE CHAIR-
BILLS CHAIR PLACED SO- IN TERMS
OF THE DEFINITIONS WELL
BUSINESS AS I MENTIONED A
BEGINNING AND I IN OUR
CONVERSATION FOR- REPUBLIC FIVE
HUNDRED I BELIEVE BECAUSE-
YEAH. THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
THAT'S ABOUT DEFINITE BUSINESS
NOTHING MAGICAL ABOUT THAT
NUMBER WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
THROUGH. THOSE OF ISSUES THE
BILL WAS REQUIRED TO THE OWNER
OF COURSE AT BE PUBLICLY TRADED
FEWER THAN FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES- AND THOMAS PILED IN
CALIFORNIA- I REMEMBER THAT WAS
AN AMENDMENT IT'S NOT WE TALKED
ABOUT IT AND WE THINK IT
SHOULD. NOT LOOK FOR CERTAIN
NATIONAL. FINISHED AND MORE
TOWARD THERE'S IN THIS BILL
THAT FOR THANKS LOCAL
ORDINANCES ARE EXACT ORDERS
THAT HAVE BEEN ISSUED- AND I
TOOK WE WOULDN'T DO THAT IF THE
CITY WANTS TO GO BEYOND OF
COURSE WE WANT ALSO AVOID AT
THIS CONFLICT AND SO IT'S
SOMETHING WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT-
BUT I KNOW THE TYPICALLY WE
THOUGHT- PREEMPTS LOCAL
EGULATIONS ARE. BY THE TIME BY
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THAT ONE
I READ- AND WE'LL TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THAT. FINALLY ONE THING
I DIDN'T WE DIDN'T GET A CHANCE
TO TALK ABOUT. I KNOW THAT A
LOT OF THE SUPPORTERS- MENTION.
THEIR EMPLOYEES GETTING
EMPLOYEES BACK TO WORK THE
OPPOSITION MENTIONS EMPLOYEES
AS- THE ONES WHO GOING TO BE
HEARD- WE SHOULD CONSIDER. WHAT
IS IT THAT WILL BE DONE FOR
EMPLOYEES- WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF ORDINANCES PASSED IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AREA. ABOUT
RECALL AND MAKING SURE THAT AS
BUSINESSES- BEGIN TO. GET
BUSINESS AGAIN. THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE TO RECALL THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE WORKING
FOR THEM BEFORE- WAY TO TALK
ABOUT. RIGHT CAN A- THE
TRICKLED THAT SOMEHOW EMPLOYEES
JUST BENEFIT. IF THEIR
EMPLOYERS BENEFIT- SO. JUST
PUTTING THAT FOR CONSIDERATION
I THINK THERE IS NOT THANK YOU
SENATOR RUSS SO SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- PHASE
CENTER FOR ENGAGING HERE AND I
KNOW WE'VE HAD A FEW
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS.
RUSSELL THIS YOU KNOW THIS
CRISIS THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
TRYING TO WRESTLE WITH- YOU
KNOW IT HIT IT HIT TENANTS
INCREDIBLY HARD AND I AM
WORRIED ABOUT THE FUTURE WOULD
WHERE I GO HOME THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND I CAN'T.
HEATED THE LITTLE TALK ARENA
THAT I'VE BEEN GOING TO FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS OR- YOU KNOW
THAT THE SMALL HOLE IN THE WALL.
PLACE TO DRINK A BEER FOR THOSE
THINGS THAT SORT OF MAKE OUR
CULTURE SO SPECIAL. I AM
WORRIED ABOUT AS LOSING THEM
INTO SEEING A FUTURE RETAIL
FRANKLY THAT'S THAT'S MUCH MORE
CORPORATE AND- AND REALLY IS AN
OF THE COMMUNITY GOING FORWARD
SO WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE
BILL OF THE ADDED- BUT I ALSO
WANT TO BUT THE TO CRISIS. IN
SOMETHING WITH THE IT'S NOT THE
LANDLORD'S FAULT EITHER
BENNETT'S FRANKLY EVEN OTHER
LENDERS FAULT- THIS SOMETHING
THAT NO ONE PREDICTED SO. I'M
WRESTLING WITH THE MECHANICS IN
SECTION TWO AND I KNOW WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS AND I
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS YOU'VE ALREADY MADE
IN TERMS YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
CERTAINLY WORK ON SIZE- SURE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF MY
COLLEAGUE ABOUT THE SIZE BUT-
BUT MY FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE RIGHT.
NOW WITH CAN EXES THIS THE
UNILATERAL RECISION. ABILITY
AND JUST THE PRESIDENT THAT
THAT KIND OF- THAT THAT KIND OF
LAW WOULD HAVE- AYE AYE. WITH
DUE RESPECT I DO. DISAGREE WITH
THE NOTION THAT THIS SHOULD BE
SORTED OUT THE COURTS IF YOUR
GOAL IS TO GET URGENT RELIEF
HERE- AND YOU PUT A TWO THIRDS
ON THIS WHICH I REALLY RESPECT
YOU PUT IN THAT. HURDLE IN
FRONT OF YOURSELF- IT WAS THE
LEAD MISSY OF THE AGENCY- WE
CAN'T THEN GET THIS WRAPPED UP
IN LITIGATION LET THE COURTS
SORTED OUT- THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY
GOING TO DELIVER RELIEF TO
ANYBODY. I SAW THE ARGUMENT
ABOUT APPROPRIATE AND
REASONABLE IN THE TAILORING IN
THE ANALYSIS I STILL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER WOULD
PASS CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER AND
EXACTLY WHAT PRESIDENT- WE'D
BE. HEARING THIS UNDER- BUT I
WONDERED I MEAN HAVE YOU TAKEN
A- I THINK JUST DID A DIFFERENT-MECHANISM HAVE YOU STARTED
THINKING ABOUT ALTERNATIVE
MECHANISMS OTHER THAN. THIS
SORT OF UNILATERAL RECISION
RIGHT I KNOW I'D FLOATED WITH
YOU THE IDEA OF. A BAD FAITH
CONTINGENCY IF THEY WENT INTO A
RENEGOTIATION BUT THEN. THE
LANDLORD WAS AN ACTING IN IN
GOOD FAITH THAT THEN THAT WOULD
GIVE A RIGHT TO UNILATERAL
RECISION OR SOME OTHER TRIGGERS
I RECOGNIZE THAT SOME OF THIS
IS. ADMINISTRATIVELY DIFFICULT
BUT I. WANTED TO SEE SORT OF.
YOUR THOUGHT ON ON BAD FAITH
TRIGGER CONCEPT. OR POTENTIALLY
SOME OTHER MECHANISM OTHER THAN
UNILATERAL RECISION SO GIVE ME
A CHANCE THANK YOU. PERHAPS IT
YOU'RE IN YOUR CLOTHES. THE
MENTION THAT AS WELL. WE DO
HAVE SENATOR MOPPING UP THE
QUESTION. OF MORE QUESTIONS.
WELL IN YOUR CLOTHES IN IT
WOULD ADDRESS AT THE HIT CENTER
THAT CAN ANSWER MY QUESTION
WELL I WILL CLOSE OKAY. OKAY IS
IT UNDER YOUR NAME I'M SORRY
SAID ON THE SAME ISSUE YEAH I
WAS JUST LOOKING FOR FEEDBACK
ON THAT BUT- AT WHAT DON'T YOU
GO AHEAD SENATOR WE KNOW
LISTEN. I WASN'T AWARE THAT YOU
HAD A QUESTION SO WHY DON'T YOU
GO AHEAD AND ANSWER ONE ORDERED
REFRESHER. IN TERMS OF- THE BAD
FAITH IDEA THAT WOULD ONLY
APPLY IF THE LANDLORD WAS NOT
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH. SO I
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT. THE
QUESTION IS UNITED DISCUSSES.
HOW DO YOU WRITE THAT IN A WAY
THAT'S OF FORCIBLE BECAUSE BAD
FAITH GOOD FAITH IS SO
SUBJECTIVE. AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT I CAN THINK OF ENFORCING
NINE. IS THROUGH LITIGATION AND
A SENSOR JURY DECIDING WHAT
COULD PICK THAT FAITH. THAT
PRESIDENT AND COURTS FOR YEARS
HE'S A SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO HIRE A LAWYER
THIS IS GONNA. CLOSE UPS. SO
WHAT I EXPRESSED EVEN OFFERS
AGAIN F WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY. TO MAKE THAT WRITEABLE
IMPLEMENTABLE ENFORCEABLE.
THAT'S THAT'S AWESOME I JUST
WANT TO TALK MY HEAD. I CAN
FIGURE THAT OUT BUT WE WILL
GIVE THEM MORE THOUGHT. THE
OTHER MODEL. ON THE AND I'VE
EXPRESSED SAYS TO THE
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE PEOPLE
AND SOME PEOPLE HAVE COME
FORWARD IDEAS ALREADY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. THERE'S
NOTHING MAGICAL OBSERVE LOCAL.
ABOUT THIS EXACT STRUCTURE WE
HAVE AN OPEN MIND TO
CONSIDERING OTHER APPROACHES.
OTHER IDEAS TO GET TO THE GOAL
OF STABILIZING BY THESE
BUSINESSES SO YES WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO HAVE A
BROAD BASED DIALOGUE. AND O
THE LAST QUESTION WE JUST. THE
COMPREHENSIVE NATURE THE
SOLUTION I THINK WE ALSO TALK
TO IN YOUR YOUR CO AUTHOR
MENTION IT TO THE NEED FOR SOME
KIND OF RENT RELIEF FOR SOME
OTHER STRUCTURE SOME COROLLARY
STRUCTURED ACTUALLY MAKE THIS
WORK. I'M ON THE MORTGAGE SIDE
OF THINGS. DO YOU SEE ANY-
DAYLIGHT ARE THERE THINGS WE
CAN POINT TO HEAR I MEAN. IS
THERE A POSSIBILITY THERE
SENATE PACKAGE LOOKS AT THESE
ISSUES I KEEP HEARING FEDERALLY
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO FEDERALLY
BACKED. COMMERCIAL MORTGAGES
THAT. IT'S REALLY IT'S A VERY
NARROW HOPE RIGHT NOW IN TERMS
OF GETTING SOME KIND OF FEDERAL
RELIEF ON THIS FRONT BUT JUST
CURIOUS HOW THIS COMING SEASONS
OF DEVELOP THE RESTAURANTS HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATING AT THE FEDERAL.
LEVEL FOR A RIDE. THE HOUSE.
FOR SMALL BUSINESS I. KNOW I
IT'S EVERYONE YES THAT WILL.
HAVE I'M SURE THERE A LOT OF IN
THIS THAT ARE. FOR THAT. ONE
BUT YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE
GREAT I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
WILL HAPPEN. IN TERMS OF THE
SENATE PACKAGE RIGHT NOW THE
LEADERSHIP IN CENTER BRADFORD.
HAVE PROPOSED A RESIDENTIAL.
RENTER BOB RED FORGIVENESS WITH
THE TAX CREDIT PAYMENT- I'M NOT
TRANSLATE THAT TO COMMERCIAL
BUT AGAIN. WE'RE OPEN TO ALL OF
THIS DISCUSS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- COM AND YOU KNOW IF THIS
BILL DOES MOVE FOR ALL THE
CERTAINLY BE CAN A- CLOSER LOOK
AND WE KNOW. YES INSERT PLACES.
AND T. EIGHT LIKE YOU ALWAYS
DOING GOOD FACE APPRECIATE YOUR
HARD WORK HERE AND I THINK. YOU
KNOW WE GOTTA DO SOME HERE TO
SOLVE IT SO THANKS FOR POINTS
FOR. THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU CHAIR I WANT TO THANK.
CO AUTHORS BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- WE'RE IN CRISIS AND
HIS SOME OF POINTED OUT THE
CRISIS ISN'T LIMITED TO TENANTS
IS NOT LIMITED TO SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. IT'S ACROSS
THE BOARD. I DO THINK THE
FRAMEWORK THAT YOU'RE
DEVELOPING. FIRST AND FOREMOST
SHOULD INCENTIVIZE NEGOTIATION
NOT STRICT MANDATES BUT
NEGOTIATION BECAUSE- AS WE HEAR
SO OFTEN ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT
ALL AND WE HAVE. YOU MIGHT HAVE
A SMALL FAMILY RESTAURANT IN
THE MIGHT BE HAVE A LEASE IN
THE BUILDING. ALSO OWNED BY A
FAMILY THAT'S FACING TOUGH
MORTGAGE GADGIL VERSES. MAYBE A
CHAIN OF THREE RESTAURANTS THAT
RENDON DIFFERENT PROPERTIES
FROM ALL LARGER COMMERCIAL
LANDLORDS SO. TO ME THE
STRENGTH OF THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD IS TO INCENTIVIZE
ENCOURAGE NEGOTIATION IN MAY BE
WITH SOME GUIDELINES I SHARE
THE CONCERN OF SENATOR TO ROSS
SO I KNOW THE FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES IS A FEDERAL
DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESS
FIVE HUNDRED OR LESS. TO ME
THAT SEEMS. LIKE A LOT OF
EMPLOYEES IN DOESN'T REALLY
CAPTURE. THE SIZE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES OPERATING IN MY
DISTRICT SO I WOULD BE. OPEN TO
SOME REVIEW OF THAT OF THAT CUT
OFF TO REALLY. FOCUS IN ON. HE
REAL SMALL BUSINESSES FAMILY
BUSINESSES NIGHT CORPORATE
CHAINS THAT HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES. I
THINK ON THE GUIDELINES OR OR
LOOKING NOT TO MANDATES BUT
MAYBE SOME GUIDELINES- IN SOME
OF THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD.
THERE WAS A SUGGESTION OF.
BECAUSE OF LIMITED CAPACITY IN
A RESTAURANT OR BAR. THE OWNER
OF THAT BUSINESS LET'S SAY
MAKES 50% OF WHAT THEY WERE
MAKING PRETTY COVE IT- AGAIN
MAYBE A GUIDELINE NOT A
DIRECTIVE THAT IN THE FRAMEWORK
WOULD BE TO LOOK AT WITH THE
LANDLORD AT A 50% ADJUSTMENT.
ON THE RENTAL OBLIGATION- OR
SOME PROPORTIONAL SO THE
LANDLORDS NIGHT. SUBSIDIZING
THE ENTIRE OPERATION ON THE
RENT SIDE WHEN THE OPERATION IS
BRINGING IN REVENUES SO THAT
MIGHT BE A GUIDELINE. ANOTHER
MIGHT BE SOME ENCOURAGEMENT FOR
MEDIATION- MANDATORY MEDIATION
IS KIND OF AN OXYMORON WE KNOW
THAT THAT EXISTS IN FARM LABOR.
UNDER THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
LAW INTACT TO MANDATORY
MEDIATION. MAYBE SOME MANDATE
THAT WITHIN A CERTAIN WINDOW OF
TIME THE PARTIES HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER IN LOOK AT SOME OF THE
GUIDELINES OR CRITERIA
SUGGESTED IN THE BILL- I THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN UPHILL
FIGHT IS YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF
ON THE TWO THIRDS THE URGENCY
BECAUSE BUT IT IS URGENT NEEDS
THE RELIEF IS NEEDED NOW. NOT
NEXT YEAR. SO I APPLAUD YOUR
WORK WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED IN. BEING
OPEN TO SOME MAYBE MORE INPUTS
THAT WOULD MOVE PEOPLE TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION- IN MAYBE
AGAIN THROUGH A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE PROPORTIONAL. GUIDELINE IS
SUPPOSED TO A MANDATE ON.
ADJUSTMENT OF RENT OBLIGATION
SO THOSE ARE MORE COMMENTS NOT
REALLY A QUESTION BUT THROUGH
THE CHAIR FEW WANT TO REACT TO
ANY OF THAT I WOULD. WELCOME
THAT THROUGH. THIS VERY
BRIEFLY- I APPRECIATE ALL OF
THAT A AND WE WILL- KEEP THAT
VERY MUCH IN MIND- AND I WILL
ALSO SAY. THAT I AGREE WITH YOU
IT'S ABOUT ENCOURAGING
NEGOTIATION WITHOUT
MICROMANAGING BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS GONNA BE DIFFERENT ONE
THING I WANT TO STRESS. THIS IS
NOT ABOUT LIKE YOU KNOW SOMEONE
HAS FIVE OR TEN YEARS UNDER A
LEASE. THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
WE WANT WHEN YOU'RE GONNA
AUTOMATICALLY RESTRUCTURE THE
LEASE TO PERMANENTLY CHANGE IT.
IT COULD BE BUT YOU GET A RENT
REDUCTION FOR THE NEXT FOUR
MONTHS BECAUSE WE ALL ARE
PREPPING THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS
BE A MORE EFECTIVE TREATMENT
OR VACCINE. THE BACK TO THE WAY
THEY WORK. SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS OF YOU KNOW READING SHE IN
A WAY THAT'S NOT STREET. AND
THAT'S TAILORED TO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN TIME TABLE
CANCER THANK YOU CENTER THANK
YOU SO WILL THAT. AS YOUR
SERVICE YEAH I JUST TWENTY A
COUPLE CALL. HERE IN A WE
MENTIONED LEAVE WE WALK IN THIS
IS A TWENTY. PAGE AND NOW. IS A
CALL. IS THERE IS MORE WORK TO
BE DONE AND I DEFINITELY.
APPRECIATE THAT IN KNOWING YOUR
WORK KNOW THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO- WE YOU KNOW
WE DON'T USUALLY REGULATE
COMMERCIAL TENDENCIES LIKE WE
DO RESIDENTIAL TENANCIES
BECAUSE WE PERCEIVE THAT
THERE'S GREATER PARITY BETWEEN
THE PARTIES. TO A COMMERCIAL
LEASE IT'S NOT ALWAYS TRUE BUT
BY AND LARGE COMMERCIAL
TENANTS- KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND CAN HOLD THEIR OWN
AGAINST COMMERCIAL LANDLORD.
STATE DOESN'T USUALLY GET
INVOLVED WITH CLEARLY. WE ARE
IN A VERY DIFFERENT WORLD AND I
THINK WE ALL HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT YES WE COULD LITIGATE THIS
AND MAYBE THAT IS WHAT WILL
HAPPEN BUT THE EXPECTATIONS ON
WHICH RESTAURANTS AND BARS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES GROUNDED THEIR
DECISIONS WHEN THEY SIGNED
THEIR LEASES HAS BEEN TOTALLY
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN. AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WE ARE
LIVING IN A WORLD THAT MOST OF
US COULD NOT HAVE IMAGINED. AND
SO- I HEAR WHAT THE OPPOSITION
SAYING ABOUT HOW THE- THE BILL
INTERFERES WITH CONTRACT AND-
IN ALL THOSE TRADITIONAL OLD
CONCERNS THAT ARE EXPRESSED
BUT- YOU KNOW THIS IS A WORLD
WHERE WE'RE REQUIRING SOCIAL
DISTANCING KEEPING PEOPLE HOME.
RESTRICTING DINING IN
RESTRICTING. HOW FOOD CAN BE
PRESENTED ESSENTIALLY
RESTRICTING PROFITS. AND SO WE
ARE ALREADY RADICALLY ALTERED
IN THIS REALITY UPON WHICH
THOSE CONTRACTS WERE BASED AND
I MEAN A YOU KNOW CORONAVIRUSES
THE ONE THAT INTERFERED WITH
THESE CONTRACTS. AND I JUST
THINK WE HAVE TO READ AND SAID
TO PRETEND THAT THIS HAS NOT
IMPACTED EVERY PART OF OUR
DAILY LIVES. IS JUST TO BE
LIVING UNDER A ROCK. I MEAN WE
ARE ALL EXPERIENCING THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE TO HEAR WITH THESE
STUPID MASKS ON. THE THAT ARE
FAR UP GLASSES I DON'T KNOW BUT
ANYBODY ELSE BUT IF YOU'VE GOT
A WAY TO AVOID THAT LET ME
KNOW- BUT OUR JOB. AS I SEE IT
IS TO DO A THING WE CAN TO GIVE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
RESTAURANTS AND BARS AND- OTHER
BASED ON ARE. THE TOP OF THE-
THIS. SHOULD NOT BE A FINANCE
BENEFIT. TO ANYBODY ESPECIALLY
AT THE EXPENSE OF OTHERS AND I
THINK YOU HEARD FROM US SENATE
DERIVE SO. THE CENTER MORNING
SENATOR STERN AS WELL CONCERNS%
ABOUT CREATING AN UNFAIR
PLAYING FIELD WHICH IS NOT WHAT
I THINK YOU. WANT TO DO AND SO-
I APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE
MEMBERS I THINK THAT THEY'VE
GREATLY TIGHTENED AND
STRENGTHEN THE BILL- AS HE
ANALYSIS NOTES. THERE'S FURTHER
REFINEMENT TO BE DONE I THINK
YOU'VE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT AROUND
WHAT TENANTS OBLIGATIONS WILL
BE IF THEY BREAK THE LEASE.
AGAIN THIS IS NOT TO GIVE
ANYBODY UNFAIR ADVANTAGE. AND
I'M AWARE THAT THERE ARE LEASES
STRUCTURED IN A WAY WHERE THE
LANDLORD HAS. ACTUAL INVESTMENT
UP FRONT PARTICULARLY WITH
TENANT IMPROVEMENTS AT ALL AND
I THINK THESE ARE THINGS AGAIN
THAT HAVE TO BE. INCLUDED SO-
KNOWING THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE
WORKING AND DOING YOUR BEST
EFFORT I. WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD I THINK
WE'D ALL LIKE TO RESERVE OUR
RIGHT TO- AND TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE DEPENDING UPON HOW THIS
BILL. OF ALL THIS AND I KNOW
WITH A TWO THIRDS VOTE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO REALLY WORK HARD
TO TRY TO. CREATE BALLOTS THAT
EVERYBODY- IS LOOKING FOR SO.
WITH THAT. IF YOU LIKE BRIEFLY
CLOSER IF YOU'RE ALL SET WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. I DON'T. A COMMOTION BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASKING SENATORS TO PLEASE
TURN YOUR MIKE SOMEONE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB NINE
THIRTY NINE WIENER JACKSON HI
JACKSON I DO RUSSELL HI US SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I JONES.
JONES NO MONNING AYE AYE
MONNING AYE STERN BURKE. WHY
CAL SKI HI Y. CASKEY I. FIVE TO
ONE RIGHT FIVE TO ONE WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER THE SHAKING WAS
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE- THE NEXT BUILT NEXT TO
BILLS ARE SENATOR UMBERG'S
BILLS BUT HE HAS NOT ARRIVED
YET SO I BELIEVE WE WERE GOING
TO GO NEXT TO- FILE ITEM EIGHT
WHICH IS SB TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE FOR THOSE. WHO ARE.
IN THE U. TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF EITHER SB NINE EIGHTY OR SB
NINE NINETY NINE. THAT WE WILL
DEFER HEARING THOSE BILLS SO
UPON ARRIVAL OF- SENATOR UMBERG
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE SENATOR SKINNER. BUT I
DON'T SEE CENTER SKINNER I'M
SORRY IS HERE AND SHE WILL BUT
NOW BE PRESENTING A FILE ITEM
EIGHT SB TEN SEVENTY NINE. OUR
HER MEASURE DEALING WITH
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY. IN WITH
THE ACT OF GOOD MORNING STILL
SENATOR SKINNER- PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PROCEED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- MEMBERS-
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO. PRESENT
SB TEN SEVENTY NINE TWO TODAY I
THINK MANY OF US REMEMBER THAT
DURING THE LAST RECESSION WHICH
WAS GREATLY PRECIPITATED BY A-
OF MANIPULATION OF FINANCIAL
MARKETS AROUND MORTGAGES AND
SUCH THAT THEY WERE RAMPANT
FORECLOSURES IN CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND DURING
THAT TIME LARGE CORPORATE AND
OTHER INVESTORS BOUGHT UP
FORECLOSED HOMES AT A DISCOUNT.
OWNER OCCUPIED HOMEOWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA DROPPED BY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND RENTER
OCCUPIED SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
INCREASED BY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND SOME HOMES WERE LEFT
VACANT THAT IN THE
CONCENTRATION OF OWNERSHIP BY A
SMALL NUMBER OF LARGE
CORPORATIONS IN MANY
NEIGHBORHOODS ARTIFICIALLY
RAISED HOME PRICES. THE VACANT
PROPERTIES IMPACTED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND- THERE WERE
LOTS OF NEGATIVE IMPACTS THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC FALLOUT OF OUR
PANDEMIC COULD CAUSE ANOTHER
WAVE OF FORECLOSURES WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN EXECUTIVE ORDERS
TO TRY TO- MINIMUM FORECLOSURES
AND PROTECT OWNERS BUT- DO YOU
BELONG SUCH EXECUTIVE ORDERS
WILL BE ABLE TO STAND AFFECTED
WHEN WE RECOVERY ECONOMICALLY
IS TOO SOON TO TELL. THE INTENT
OF SB TEN SEVENTY NINE IS TO
PREVENT THE SCENARIO THAT KURD
DURING THAT RECESSION SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE HAS THREE ELEMENTS
IT CREATES A WINDOW FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PUBLIC AGENCIES
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND PERSPECTIVE DAVE OWNER
OCCUPANTS MEANING THE TENANTS
OF A SAY A HOME THAT'S PERHAPS
GOING TO GO AHEAD. GO PROCEED
ON FORECLOSURE TO PURCHASE
HOMES AHEAD OF INVESTORS. BY
CREATING A WINDOW FOR THAT
PURCHASE PRIOR TO OPENING IT UP
TO AUCTION IN A AYE OTHERS. IT
MAKES PURCHASE A LARGE NUMBER
OF FORECLOSED HOMES AT A SINGLE
ACTION MORE DIFFICULT. AND IT
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
INCREASE THE FINES ON VACANT ON
MAINTAIN PROPERTIES I HAVE A-
VIVID RECOLLECTION DURING THE
RECESSION OF WALKING THROUGH
THE HOODS IN WHEN A RICHMOND
WITH CITY OFFICIALS WERE BY.
HOMES THAT WERE ABANDONED I
WORK FULL OF RATS THE COPPER
HAD BEEN STRIPPED THERE WAS
RASH SOME WERE TURNED INTO
SHOOTING DANS MEANING A DRUG
INJURED IN SHOOTING. OPERATE
OWNER SO- DE THE ABILITY TO
INCREASE THE FINES WOULD
HOPEFULLY CREATE SOME INCENTIVE
OF THAT ORDER TO EITHER
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY OR SELL
IT OR PUT IT OUT TO WRITE. SO
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
AND I HAVE A GREAT WITNESS
ROBERT APODACA FROM CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS TO SPEAK IN
UPPORT. THANK YOU AND TO A WE
WILL LOVE PROVIDE TO SIR WITH A
THREE MINUTE SO I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE OTHER. THAT YOU'VE
WORKED I WANTED TO GIVE HIM THE
FULL TIME ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
YOU HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES
MISTER OFF DHAKA. MISTER
MODERATOR. OF PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE FOR MISTER A DOCKET TO
SPEAK. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING WHY MORNING GOOD MORE
GOT SURE JACK AND I'M OF THE
DID COMITTEE. MY NAME IS BOB
TOP OF ON THE COLD OF CAL CAN
YOU BILL. ALSO KNOWN AS THE TWO
HUNDRED OF OUR THIS TO YOU
RIGHT POVERTY AND NOW THE GAP
OF UNDER TO ME THROUGH HOME.
AND WILL LIKELY RESULT IN A
LOSS WITH MANY MANY HOME.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME OWNERSHIP
RATES AS OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE LATEST DATA
AVAILABLE SHOWS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WHITES ONLY SIXTY
THREE BARBARA HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE OF SIXTY THREE POINT 4%
ALL OF THIS FORTY SEVEN POINT
6% AND BLACK JUST FORTY FOUR
POINT 3% FOR ARE LAGGING BEHIND
IN IN TERMS OF THE PARODY BY A
LONG SHOT. SB TEN NINE OF
DESIGNED TO PREVENT CORPORATION
FROM BUNDLE PURCHASE OF HOMES
AND CONVERT THEM TO RENTALS.
SENATOR ALREADY A SUBSCRIBER
MORE- I WOULD CERTAINLY WHAT
WHAT THE WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF
WE- ENTER A NEW WAVE OF
FORECLOSURES AND WE DON'T WANT
OR CALL HOME TURN INTO RENTALS
THE FIRST TIME BUYERS CANNOT
COMPETE WITH THE CORPORATE
BUYERS. WE'RE CALIFORNIA'S
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE AMONG PEOPLE
CODE NEEDS TO IMPROVE. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE WHEN I SAY WE I'M TALKING
ABOUT- OTHER MEMBERS OF THE TWO
HUNDRED LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
WHICH INCLUDE FORMER SO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOE KOTO A JOHN
GUMBO OF FOUNDER OF THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE AND ALSO A CO
FOUNDER. OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS WE STILL
HAVE WITH THOSE SO BERMAN GUY
EAGLES THE FOUNDER OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL RUSSIA AND-
ALSO A SPORTS BAR. THE COUNCIL
GREG MCCAW. THE OF THE OF
HOUSING COALITION OPEN UP
FORMER CABINET NUMBER STUDY
LIKE PEAK AND FORMER SENATOR
DON PRODUCT. WE ALL ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS WELL-
BEFORE WE PROCEED I WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT YOU WILL BE TAKING
IS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PUBLISHED
IN THE ANALYSIS YES ABSOLUTELY
AND APPRECIATE STAFF'S HELP ON
THAT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- ARE
THERE ANY MRS IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE THAT WANT TO USE THE
OTHER MINUTE THAT'S AVAILABLE.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY WE DO NOT. LET'S
GO TO THE PHONES AND MISTER
MODERATOR WHICH YOU QUEUE UP.
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO GIVE THEIR
NAME. AND AFFILIATION IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TEN SEVENTY NINE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION MISTER
MODERATOR. OF IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE SIR PROCEED. CERTAINLY
CHAIR FOR SYNDICATE PLACES
OFTEN A CUTE SHOW SUPPORT IN A
PRESS ONE AND THEN IS THERE- AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
ZERO AND PLEASE TAKE YOUR PHONE
OFF OF MUTE. THE MODERATOR WILL
A TRUST FOR YOU TAKE YOUR
PHONES OFF OF MUTE NOW AS YOU
ENTER THE QUEUE. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX THAT IS TWO TWO SIX.
GOOD MORNING JOSH ARE DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR THAT IS TWO FOUR FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OF. NINE TO
FORTY FOUR YOU ARE FREE TO
SPEAK. PLEASE TAKE YOUR PHONE
OFF ON A- YES THIS IS DAVID CAN
TANA ON BEHALF OF POPULAR
NONPROFIT HOUSING PROVIDERS AND
ADVOCACY GROUP IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. IS LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO THAT TO. LINE EIGHTY
TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR FEELINGS
OFF MUTE. PINE EIGHTY TWO.
MISTER MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE EIGHTY TWO.
FINALLY TO INDEED CUED UP THEY
MUST BE MUTED ON THEIR OWN OR
ARE NOT SPEAKING RIGHT PLEASE
ON MUTE YOUR PHONE LINE EIGHTY
TWO SO THAT WE CAN HEAR YOU ON
MUTE YOUR PHONE. MOVING ALONG
TO THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. IT
WAS THE LAST ONE IN Q. I'LL
REITERATE ITS ONE AND ZERO TO
PUT YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT ONE THEN ZERO ANYONE
ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THIS
IS TEN SEVENTY NINE. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES MONEY TO. I
NEED TO IS REALLY CUTE WILL TRY
TO GO BACK TO THAT LINE TO LINE
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE. TAKE YOUR PHONE OFF OF
ROUTE. ALL RIGHT WILL BETTER
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES I'M NOT SURE BUT
NO ONE'S RESPONDING FROM THE
LINE AND THERE ARE NO MORE Q.
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT. WE
WILL THEN GO TO. OF IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE DO
WE HAVE ANY ONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- AND- I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A MISTER. JIM
LIGHTS FROM THE NATIONAL RENTAL
HOME COUNCIL ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION MR
MODERATORS ARE CORRECT. DOUBLE
CHECKING FOR YOU. I'M HERE YEAH
HIS EYES OPEN YOU MAY PROCEED
HI MR LIGHT SO IF YOU WERE THE
ONLY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION THE
DO YOU HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE IT BUT
YOU HAVE IT AVAILABLE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR GYM LIGHTS ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL RENTAL
HOME COUNCIL THERE ARE NUMBER
OF PERSISTENT MISCONCEPTIONS
ABOUT THE OWNERSHIP- NATIONAL
CORPORATIONS OF SINGLE FAMILY
RENTAL HOMES COLLECTIVELY
MEMBERSHIP OWNS ONE TENTH OF 1%
OF SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA- I'D I'D ALSO LIKE
TO POINT OUT THE ANNAPOLIS JUST
COVERS THE FIRST. PROGRAM AND-
NO THAT ALL OF OUR COMPANIES
HAVE THE OWN. LOOK PROGRAM
THAT- MAKES YEAH THAT HOME
AVAILABLE TO THE CURRENT
TENANTS IF WE DECISIONS OR SELL
IT IS MADE. ONE FEATURE OF OUR
PROGRAMS HOWEVER IS THAT WE
WILL CREDIT THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT AND OTHER AMOUNTS. FOR
THAT TENANTS TOWARDS THEIR DOWN
PAYMENT ON THE HOME AND TRYING
TO SYSTEM. ALSO PART UP. AMONG
OTHER LENDERS WITH HOW LATE.
CAL HFA TO HELP OFFER FINANCING
TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THE
BILL ITSELF WE THINK MAKES THE
PROCESS MORE INITIATIONS FOR
TRYING TO- MOVE HOMES THAT HAVE
GUESTS ON THEM ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE DONE IS WE
PAY TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN THE PURCHASE PROCESS- BY
COVERING AND BRING IN CURRENT
BACK TAXES AND OTHER FEES THAT
MAY BE OWES. AND THEN YOU KNOW
THE FORECLOSURE PROCESS IS IT
IS NOT FOR THE FAINT OF HEART
OFTEN THE HOMES THE A LOT OF
WORK WE PUT THE- MAN TO THOSE.
AND BRING THEM OVER VERY
QUICKLY THEY THE ONE ONE
MILLION THEY CAN ALL. SITE IS
CERTAINLY OUT OF THE WHOLE THAT
WE ARE THAT THERE'S NO RICH ON
THE- IF THERE IS TENANTS IN THE
HALL. AND SO WE MOVED QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS OUT OF STOP THEIR MADAM
CHAIR AND- WE OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR- NOW LET'S GO TO THE- LINES
UNLESS THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT WISHES
TO JUST STAND WITH THEIR NAME
AND- AFFILIATION IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO THE
PHONES MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD Q. UP PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE AND WE WILL URGE
THEM TO REMOVE THEIR PHONES
FROM THE MUTE BUTTON NOW. AND
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD GO AHEAD
AND LINE THEM UP. THANK YOU IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE THEN IN HERO
REMINDER TO MAKE SURE YOUR ON
MUTE IT AT THAT POINT. WAIT A
FEW SECONDS AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE LINED UP. MISTER
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE PEOPLE
LINED UP TO- ADDRESS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE. THERE IS NO OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME
YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL GIVE IT ANOTHER TEN
SECONDS AND THEN- WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE DYESS.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE MISTER MODERATOR.
THERE IS STILL NONE ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WE WILL THEN BRING
THE MATTER TO THE DíAS WE'LL
START WITH SENATOR Y. KOWSKI
AND I SHE DID SENATOR BORCHERS
HAS HIS HAND UP AS WELL SENATOR
Y. KOWSKI WHY DON'T YOU START
BY I JUST HAVE A CLARIFICATION
I SEE THAT THE VALUE OF NOT
ALLOWING BUNDLING ON TRUSTEE
SALES THAT THAT THAT OCCUR IN
THAT I THINK OF GOOD. WHAT AM
AND I THINK I UNDERSTAND THAT
IF THE IF THERE'S NO BID AT
TRUSTEE SAID AND THE BANK TAKES
IT BACK THAT YOU'RE THERE FOR
LOOKING CLOSE TO ALLOW- THE
FOLKS TOO BAD. IT OVER. OWNER
OCCUPANCY GO AND I SEE THE
PUBLIC POLICY BENEFITS OF THAT.
THE CONCERN IS I HAVE IS.
SOMETIMES IF YOU HAVE A SINGLE
TRUSTEE SALE SOMEBODY WILL BID
ARE OVER ON THE BANKS NOTE. AND
BY YOU KNOW. THESE THESE PEOPLE
COME IN AND THEIR THEY'RE AT
THE- SEE TAPE. THE AMOUNT AND
THEY COME IN AND I THINK. AND A
PURCHASE IT I THINK THAT'S THAT
YOUR THIRD ONE THAT IT RAISES
THE FINES IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY AT
THE TRUSTEE SALE. AND YOU PAY
AND YOU GET IT NHIáU LET IT
GO DERELICT. IF YOU BUY IT FROM
THE BANK AFTER THE FOR CLOTHES.
ARE YOU STILL IS IT YOUR
INTENTION OR DO YOU THINK THAT
THAT IF IT WAS FAKE IN THE
MAINTAIN. AGAIN THE OPPOSITION
SAYS THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
PEOPLE DO THIS PROFESSIONALLY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT COVERS
THAT THEY FIVE FIVE BY FROM THE
BANK THE DAY FOR CLOTHES
BECAUSE- I DIDN'T FOR CLOTHES.
I BOUGHT I BOUGHT THE- PART OF.
ABOUT ALLOWS HEALTH. IS AT. SO
THERE MAY BE OUR TO THE INTENT
IS THAT INDEPENDENT UP THAT THE
FINES THE PROVISION OF THE BILL
THAT WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO INCREASE ITS FINE
SWITCHES SELECTIVE ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PART THEY MAY
CHOOSE NOT TO BUT THAT
PROVISION IS ON THE ON
MAINTAINED VACANT PROPERTY
REGARDLESS OF OWNERSHIP IS MY
UNDERSTANDING NOW THERE MAY BE
SOME- WORDING AT ITS LIKE MANY
THINGS AND WE KNOW THERE'S MANY
OUR CODE SECTIONS AROUND THERE
SO I WILL. ASK STAFF TO GO
THROUGH MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ISN'T A CONFLICT THERE BUT THAT
WAS THE INTENT OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
SENATOR BORCHERS. ALL RIGHTY WE
TO HAVE HIM ON THE LINE. OKAY
YOU MAY GO AHEAD DON'T DON'T
TOUCH. THE. YOU DID WE CAN HEAR
YOU. TO ME IT IS CANNOT HEAR
YOU. BE THERE. START IT'S NOT
JUST THE POWER OF THE I'M
MUTING ALL OF THEM THANK YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO YOU ARE
POSTING QUESTIONS. OUR I MORE
OF A CLARIFICATION ENQUIRING IS
CAN A LOT OF THESE CONCERNS NOT
BE RESOLVED ALREADY BY THE
POWERS OF THE LOCAL OF FORTIES
AND WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS. CAN
A COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE NOT
KICKING THE COUNTY CREATE LOCAL
PREFERENCE. FOR BETTING
PURPOSES I THANK YOU FOR
BEATING ALL THE PUBLIC WORKS.
TWO ONE TWO ONE ANSWER THE
QUESTION THROUGH THE CHAIR
THANK YOU SURE JACKSON SO. AS
THESE ARE. OUR ACTIONS THAT THE
BANK THE MORTGAGE HOLDER AND IF
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTION IT
WOULD RUN I'M NOT SURE I WOULD
IMAGINE THERE MAY BE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE COUNTY
MAY BE ABLE TO EFFECT BUT I
DON'T THINK ACROSS THE BOARD
THIS COULD BE DONE JUST BUT
COUNTY BY COUNTY. I THINK THAT
FOR US TO ENSURE THAT ANY THAT
WE LIMIT THE BUNDLING AND SUCH
WE WOULD NEED THIS STATE OF A
STATUTE. OKAY IN TERMS OF.
LOCAL CONTROL FOR ENFORCING
VIOLATIONS. IN MY PREVIOUS
CAPACITY ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE VALLEY. IS
THAT THE COUNTY OR A
MUNICIPALITY HAS THE ABILITY TO
ENFORCE VIOLATIONS AND IF THEY
DON'T MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY
WHICH IS WHAT WE EXPERIENCE
WHEN THE BANK OWNED PROPERTIES
WERE- OCCURRING YOU KNOW
CIRCUIT TWENTY TEN TWENTY
ELEVEN. IS THAT THE COUNTY
COULD STEP IN AND MAINTAIN THE
PROPERTY AND THEN ATTACH A LEAN
TO THE TITLE WHENEVER.THAT WAS
TO BE TRANSFERRED I GUESS WHAT
I'M GETTING AT IS I SEE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING. TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE BUT I'M LOOK AT A FROM A
LOCAL AUTHORITY STAND. THAT THE
POWER EXIST WITH THOSE ENTITIES
TO ACHIEVE YOUR DESIRED OUTCOME
WITHOUT US ARE CREATING
STATEWIDE RULES THAT MAY HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. IF YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL THOUGHTS ON THAT
THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE. I'M
AS I INDICATED ABOUT WITH THE
QUESTION THAT SENATOR Y. CASKEY
ASKED THE STATUTE BEFORE YOU IF
WE ADOPT SB TEN SEVENTY NINE
JUST CREATES THE ABILITY FOR A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO INCREASE
ITS FINE. THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
NOT CHOOSE TO IT DOES NOT FORCE
THEM TO. AND WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING PERHAPS COUNTIES
COULD HAVE DONE THAT DURING THE
LAST RECESSION IN FORECLOSURE
CRISIS. BUT IN- BUT I THINK NOT
ONLY MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE BUT
THE EXPERIENCE OF MANY
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE WHEN- BUT MANY OF THE-
PROPERTIES WERE LEFT VACANT THE
CITIES WERE PUT IN EXTRA NEARLY
DIFFICULT POSITION. TO IT TO.
IT HAVE TOOLS THAT WOULD FORCE
THE OWNERS TO EAT TO MAINTAIN
THE PROPERTIES OR TO. PUT THEM
ON THE MARKET OR PUT A TENDON
IN THEM AND- SO WHAT WE REALLY
WANT TO DO IS PREVENT THAT
SCENARIO- AND THAT IS THE-
INTENT OF THAT PART OF THE
LEGISLATION BUT AGAIN IT IS
COMPLETELY ELECTIVE IF THE- IF
CITY X. OR Y. CHOOSES NOT TO
THAT IS THEIR CHOICE. AND I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE FINES
NOW ARE A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY THAT'S THE MAX THE CAN BE
UNDER STATE LAW AND THAT IF WE
REACHED OUT TO A THOUSAND BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT DUE
TO THIS PROBLEM BUT IT WAS NOT
ADEQUATE. INCENTIVE FOR SOME
ENTITIES. THANK YOU WELL I
APPRECIATE- ON YOU RESPONDING
TO MY QUESTIONS I THINK OF THE
OUTCOME I THINK HAS MERIT THE
DESIRED OUTCOME HAS MERIT I AM
CONCERNED. THAT LIMITING THREE
PROPERTIES- IS GOING TO CREATE
CHALLENGES FOR COUNTIES WHEN
THEY HAVE THEIR PROCESS ALL AT
THE COURTHOUSE WERE THE BEATING
BECAUSE THEY WANT ONE LO THESE
PROPERTIES. AND I THINK MAKING
IT DIFFICULT FOR LARGER
ENTITIES TO PURCHASE IN MARKET
PLACE- MAY HAVE AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THAT CARRIES MAY
NOT UP FOR BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS LET ME
CHANGE TO CLOSE THE WITH AN
OBSERVATION THAT I. RECOGNIZE
HIS BILL STILL RELATIVELY.
PATIENT IN ITS CONCEPTUAL PHASE
AND I THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE HAVE HELPED TO FLUSH OUT OF
THE CONTENT MORE AND HOPEFULLY
THE ANALYSIS HELPS TO POINT
OUT. SOME OF THE REMAINING
CHALLENGES- WORK IN PROGRESS
THE BILLS ARE SOMETIMES
PROBLEMATIC AND WE DON'T
GENERALLY IN THIS COMMITTEE
LIKE TO SEE THEM BUT- UNDER THE
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES IN WORLD
WE LIVE IN- I THINK THIS BILL
IS TOO IMPORTANT NOT TO
CONTINUE- AGAIN ESPECIALLY
SINCE WE ARE LIKELY TO FACE A
NEW FORECLOSURE WAVE. IN THE
NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE I HOPE
NOT BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC AND- THIS BILL MAY
NOT REVERSE A DYNAMIC TOTALLY
BUT- YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS
THAT MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS A WE
DON'T DO ENOUGH- THE AS WE SAW
FROM LAST THE LAST TIME IT
REALLY CAUSED. ENORMOUS A PAIN
AND SUFFERING TO WAY TOO MANY
PEOPLE SO. WITH THAT- ALL MOVED
BILL ART WE HAVE CENTER WHY
BECAUSE GIVE THE MOTION I WANT
TO KEEP AN EYE ON THIS- I THINK
MOST OF US. WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
THIS GOING WE'LL FIND OUT BUT
CERTAINLY RESERVE THE RIGHT
PROCEEDING- GOING FORWARD TO
SEE HOW THE BILL ULTIMATELY
COMES OUT SO WITH THAT- MAY I
HAVE A MOTION AND- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR SKINNER
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT. THE IF
FIRST OFF I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS DOES NOT PREVENT A
SAY A BLACK STONE FROM
PURCHASING A FOR CLOSE TO IT
DOES NOT PREVENT IT WOULD LIMIT
THEM TO DURING AN AUCTION ONLY
BUYING THREE TO TIME THAT IS
CERTAINLY THE CASE BUT IT DOES
NOT ELIMINATE THESE LARGE
CORPORATE AND IT FESTERS FROM
PURCHASING HOMES BY JUST NOTE
THAT BEFORE TWENTY TEN
INSTITUTIONAL AND LARGE DID NOT
EXIST IN THE SINGLE FAMILY
RENTAL MARKET ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY AND BY 201695% OF
DISTRESSED FANNIE MAE AND
FREDDIE MAC MORTGAGES WERE
AUCTIONED OFF TO WALL STREET
INVESTORS. THERE'S BEEN MANY
MEDIA REPORTS ABOUT HOW THIS
CREATION OF THIS NEW ASSET
CLASS THE SINGLE FAMILY RENTAL
HOME HAS AFFECTED NEIGHBORHOODS
AND IS AFFECTED THE TENANTS IN
THOSE HOMES THE- LEASES FOR
EXAMPLE ALLOWED MORE THAN
ANNUAL RENT HIKES PUNITIVE FEES
AND THE RENTERS WERE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE AND MORE
THINGS THAT WE'D NORMALLY
THOUGHT OF AS REALLY THE ONLY
RESPONSIBILITY THINGS LIKE
LANDSCAPING MOLD REMEDIATION OF
THIS COURT ALL THOSE THINGS. I
FEEL THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL
TOOLS TO HELP PREVENT WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THAT RECESSION
FROM HAPPENING DURING THIS
ECONOMIC CRISIS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND WITH THAT AND-
WITH THE AMENDED BILL ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND CERTAINLY WILL
TAKE VALUABLE- CONSTRUCTIVE
IMPROVEMENTS AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU SIR
SKINNER WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER Y. CASKEY TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE PUT YOUR
MIKE SONG. AND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THEM SECTOR THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TO SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE SENATOR KENNER.
THAT JACKSON HI. JACKSON I DID
ALSO. I WITH THE THANK YOU. DID
I SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
JONES NOW JONES NO MONNING AYE
MONNING AYE STERN AYE STERN
AYE- BURKE HI- BURKE I WAKE
HOUSE SKI BY WHITE HOUSE SKI I.
OUR SIX AT SEVEN TWO ONE AND
SEVEN TO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO BACK TO CENTER
ON BIRDS FILE ITEM OF FIVE SB
NINE EIGHTY AND YOU GET IF YOU
WOODS I THINK WE ARE ASKING
THAT ALL. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE BILLS 2%
JUST PRESENT THEM FROM THERE
ARE A CHAIR SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROCEED SENATOR ON BURKE THE
MAN CHAIR ON I GOT A MESSAGE
FROM CENTER RUBIO THAT HER
PLANE IS- LEAVING RELATIVELY
SOON SO WITH THE CONSENT OF THE
CHAIR HAPPENED EVER GO BEFORE
ME. OUT I THINK WE CAN MANAGE
THAT- WE GENERALLY TRYING NOT
TO BUT IF YOUR FLIGHT IS
LEAVING WE WANT YOU WANNA SO
SENATOR. RUBIO YEAH. ALL RIGHT
YEAH WE DO HAVE A THE DRY
THAT'S TRUE WE WERE DON'T HAVE
THE SAME FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
USED TO HAVE. OR RIGHT. WHAT DO
WE DO THAT IS THERE ARE MISTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU LET US KNOW
IF THERE'S ANY- SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IT'S CUED UP ON
SENATOR ON BIRDS SB NINE EIGHTY.
I'M SORRY. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ON THE PHONE LINES.
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS NO NOT
TIME OUT HOLD ON ONE SECOND
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A MOMENT
HERE. WELL JACK.
THANK YOU
MISTER BURKE REALLY PLEASE HOLD
ON ONE SECOND I NEED TO
ANNOUNCES ALRIGHT SO WE'RE
GOING TO- MOVED TO FILE ITEM TO
HAND AT THIS POINT THIS ISA
SENATOR RUBIO IS SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE- WE DO HAVE HER
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE SO THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO TESTIFY AND
SENATOR RUBIO ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
I THINK IT'S STILL MORNING OUT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY
IMPRISONING SB LEVIN FOR A
FORTY ONE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COURSE OF CONTROL THE FIRST ONE
I THINK THE CHAIR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO DILLON
WITH ME AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND THE
ANALYSIS AND AFTER MEETING WITH
ADVOCATE GROUPS AS WELL I
DECIDED TO PLACE THE DEFINITION
OF COURSE OF CONTROL AND THE
FAMILY CODE. THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS NOT LIMITED TO
PHYSICAL ABUSE IT ALSO INVOLVES
A PATTERN OF POWER AND CONTROL
THROUGH WHICH ABUSERS DOMINATE
EVERY ASPECT OF THE VICTIM'S
LIFE. UNFORTUNATELY PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON
THIS ISSUE AS WE SEE NOW. MORE
CASES ARE RESURFACING AND WE
HEAR FROM. ADVOCATES AND SAFE
HOUSES AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT THE CALLS ARE INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY. A RECENT LA TIMES
ARTICLE STATED THAT WE ARE IN
THE WORST CASE SCENARIO FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DURING
SHELTER IN PLACE. AND I BELIEVE
THAT SOCIAL ISOLATION IS THE
IDEAL SITUATION FOR AN ABUSER.
IT GUARANTEES FULL CONTROL AND
POWER. AWAY FROM PEOPLE EXAMPLE
OF COURSE OF CONTROL CAN
INCLUDE. BUT NOT LIMITED TO
CONSTANT MANIPULATION. AND-SURVEILLANCE THE GRADUAL
ISOLATION AWAY FROM FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. WHAT HOLDING FINANCES
IN BASIC NECESSITIES. WHICH CAN
INCLUDE EVEN PROHIBITING A
VICTIM FROM GOING TO SCHOOL OR
GETTING TOGETHER WITH
COWORKERS. AND IT MAKES IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR VICTIMS
TO ESCAPE THAT ABUSE. THE
PHRASE OF CONTROL EXPLAINS THIS
PARTICULAR RANGE OF BEHAVIORS
MANY STATES ACROSS THE US HAVE
ALREADY IDENTIFIED THE
IMPORTANCE OF USING COURSE OF
CONTROL. AND IN THE STATUTE AND
DONE. THE TEAM PORTION TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT INCLUDING NEW
YORK THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
DIVISION FOUND THAT
APPROXIMATELY. FORTY THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION VICTIMS IN
THE U. S. REPORTED.
EXPERIENCING PSYCHOLOGICAL
AGGRESSION BY AN INTIMATE
PARTNER DURING THEIR LIFE.
HOWEVER TO ME THE MOST ALARMING
STATISTIC FOUND. THAT CONTROL
WITH AN INTIMATE PARTNER
RELATIONSHIPS INCREASES THE
ODDS OF HOMICIDE. SURE YOU WILL
HEAR FROM A MOTHER MY DISTRICT
WILL TELL YOU THAT CHRIS OF
CONTROL SCARRED HER FOR LIFE.
UNFORTUNATELY I ALSO PERSONALLY
UNDERSTAND CURSE OF CONTROL IN
THE PARALYZING IT HAS ON
VICTIMS. THROUGH MY RESEARCH I
HEARD COUNTLESS STORIES FROM
VICTIMS ABOUT DIFFERENT WAYS
CHORUS OF CONTROL IS USED WHICH
INCLUDED STARTING VICTIMS. ARE
THEY WERE SLEEP DEPRIVED AND
COURSE OF CONTROL THAT WAS SO
DEVASTATING THAT ALMOST PUSHED
HIM TO COMMIT SUICIDE.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT INCLUDE
COMPREHENSIVE DEFINITION OF
COURSE OF CONTROL AND ANY
EXISTING STATUTE. NOW IS THE
TIME TO STRENGTHEN OUR LOSS FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND INTRODUCE THE DEFINITION.
OF COURSE THE CONTROL. TODAY
WITH ME I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HONEST DAVIS A MOTHER AN
ADVOCATE IN MY DISTRICT. I ALSO
HAVE A LINE EVAN RACHEL WOOD. A
SURVIVOR AN ADVOCATE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN A LEADER
OF THE PHOENIX ACT PROGRAM AND
LASTLY JUST TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ON THE PHONE I HAVE
THE EXPERT. PAHLAVI TO ONE AN
ATTORNEY AND DIRECTOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE POLICY AND PREVENTION
AT THE LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WITH THAT. I
WILL LET MY MIGHT WITNESSES
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR AND
TO BE CLEAR FOR THOSE TWO
WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE- WE ARE
PERMITTING A TOTAL OF ONLY
THREE MINUTES PER SIDE SO
BETWEEN YOUR TWO WITNESSES.
WILL GIVE THEM THREE MINUTES
TOTAL THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DECIDE HOW TO BEST USE THAT
TIME I APOLOGIZE BUT GIVEN. THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
AND SO FORTH WE HAVE TO THE
LIMIT THEM AT THIS POINT SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED TO YOUR FOR YOUR FIRST
WITH. BELIEVE WHO IT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE HERE. A TWO. MY LEFT
IN YOUR RIGHT. AND IF YOU WOULD
GO AHEAD AND WE'LL GET YOU
STARTED. RIGHT ABOUT NOW
AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN JACKSON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY I STAND BEFORE YOU
AS A MOTHER A VETERAN OF THE
UNITED STATES ARMY A FORMER
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PRINCIPAL BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY AN ADVOCATE
FOR THOSE WHO SUFFER AT THE
HANDS OF AN ABUSIVE PARTNER OR
PARENT. THE LAW AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN DEFINES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY IN PHYSICAL TERMS
MEASURING THE SEVERITY OF
INJURIES AND BEATINGS IT DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
HARM. THE PERCEPTION THAT ABUSE
IS SOMETHING THAT IS SEEN AND
NOT HEARD IS A GREAT
MISCONCEPTION I AM HERE TO GIVE
TESTIMONY ON HOW LIFE
SHATTERING PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA
CAN BE ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE
ARE NO LAWS TO PROTECT VICTIMS
WHEN. NOT BE SEEN AND
PHOTOGRAPHED. EARLY IN MY
MARRIAGE TENSION AND AFFECTION
THAT MY EX HUSBAND AFFORDED ME
WAS UNPRECEDENTED IN MY LIFE HE
MADE ME FEEL LIKE I WAS THE
WORLD TO HIM AND NOTHING ELSE
MATTERED UNFORTUNATELY THAT DID
NOT LAST. AFTER HAVING FIVE
MISCARRIAGES MY EX HUSBAND MADE
HURTFUL COMMENTS ABOUT MY
INABILITY TO HAVE CHILDREN. HE
TOLD ME THAT I WAS NOT A WOMAN
IN HIS EYES. IF I COULD NOT
HAVE A BABY. AND AFTER SEVERAL
YEARS OF HEARTBREAK I WAS
FINALLY BLESSED WITH A BABY BOY
MY ONLY CHILD. WHO I LOVINGLY
CALL BEAKY. MY EX HUSBAND WOULD
CALL ME SEVERAL TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE DAY WHILE I WAS
AT WORK. HE REPEATEDLY ASKED
WHAT I WAS DOING AND WHO I SAW
IF I MISSED A CALL HE WOULD
INTERROGATE ME AS TO WHY DID
NOT ANSWER MY PHONE. HE
INSTALLED SPY WERE ON MY PHONE
WITHOUT MY KNOWLEDGE AND HACKED
INTO MYLINKEDIN ACCOUNT.
CREATED A SECOND ACCOUNT AND
SEND REQUEST. TO COLLEAGUES
PRETENDING TO BE ME. ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS MY EX HUSBAND
THREATEN TO TAKE OUR SON TO WE
RUN. OR HE IS FROM. HE MADE IT
A POINT TO SHARE THAT WOMEN
WERE SECOND CLASS CITIZENS AND
I WOULD NEVER SEE MY SON AGAIN.
HE ALSO TOLD ME THAT I WOULD
NEVER LAST ANY RON BECAUSE I
WAS TOO OPINIONATED AND THEY
WOULD SIMPLY SHOOT ME AND I HAD
TO TAKE CARE OF ME. HE STOLE MY
CREDIT CARDS IN MY PASSPORT. HE
ACCESS MY MEDICAL RECORDS
WITHOUT MY PERMISSION. AND WHEN
I TOLD HIM I WANTED A DIVORCE
HE CONFISCATED MY BELONGINGS MY
CLOTHES MY HEIRLOOMS MY
MILITARY MEDALS. EVERYTHING
THAT DOT THAT DID NOT FIT IN MY
CAR THE DAY I LEFT. IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN I FILED FOR A
RESTRAINING ORDER THE JUDGE WHO
PRESIDED OVER MY CASE. WAS
GIVEN EVERY FEW DOUBLE
EVIDENCE. DOCUMENTING MY EX
HUSBAND'S HORRIFIC BEHAVIOR. IN
ADDITION TO THE EVIDENCE I
SUBPOENA THREE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO WERE DENIED THE
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY. THE JUDGES
READ THE JUDGE'S RESPONSE. WAS
THAT THEY WERE THERE FOR
CUSTODY REASONS NOT ABUSE. BY
RESTRAINING ORDER WAS DENIED.
HOWEVER HAD I WALKED INTO THE
COURTROOM WITH THE BLACK ARE
BROKEN ARM PERHAPS THE OUTCOME
WOULD BE DIFFERENT. AS OF TODAY
I HAVE LIVED ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE DAYS
WITHOUT MY SON. ON APRIL TWENTY
FIRST. OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. SUFFOCATED MY SON IN
THE BACKSEAT OF HIS VEHICLE
WELL MY SENSE LET. TRAPPED INTO
HIS CAR SEAT. AFTER A DAY LONG
TRIP AT DISNEYLAND. ACCORDING
TO HOMICIDE DETECTIVES MY SON-
BOOK DURING THIS VIOLENT ACT.
IN HIS FIRST ATTEMPT OF
SUFFOCATING MY SON FAILED. AND
MY SON SAID HELPLESSLY IN HIS
CARSEAT BODY TWITCHING MY EX
HAS SUFFOLK HIM A SECOND TIME.
HE USE MY SON SWEATER. AND THEN
HE PROCEEDED TO DUMP MY SON'S
BODY IN A HEAVILY WOODED AREA
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. MY
GIVE FIVE YEARS. TWO MONTHS AND
TWO DAYS OLD. ACCORDING TO
DETECTIVES EVIDENCE SEIZED
DURING THE HOMICIDE
INVESTIGATION SHOWED THAT MY EX
HUSBAND BEGAN PLANNING THE
MURDER SHORTLY AFTER MY REQUEST
FOR A RESTRAINING ORDER WAS
DENIED. MY EX HAS BEEN
COMMITTED THIS HEINOUS CRIME
BECAUSE HE COULD NO LONGER
CONTROL ME. DURING HIS
CONFESSION HE TOLD DETECTIVES
THAT HE HATED ME AND HE WANTED
TO HURT ME AND HE DID. HE HURT
ME IN THE DEEPEST AND MOST IN
HUMANE WAY POSSIBLE. COULD YOU
I'M SORRY I HATE TO DO THIS
THIS IS THIS IS MY LOVING HEART
WRENCHING COULD YOU WRAP
NOTHING THAT I DO I KNOW WILL
BRING MIGHT BE KEY BACK. BUT
EVERYTHING THAT YOU WILL DO
TODAY. AND FROM THIS POINT
FORWARD CAN SAVE LIVES. AND I
IT IS MY HOPE THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND RECOGNIZE THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND I KNOW EVERYONE
SHARES OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
FOR YOUR LOSS THIS IS WHERE THE
SYSTEM HAS FAILED US ALL.
CASTING THANK YOU. BY WE'VE
USED OVER THE THREE MINUTES BUT
I AM GOING TO THIS IS I THINK
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE UP. THE NEXT WITNESS ON
TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK AND THEN
WE WILL GO ON WITH OTHER
WITNESSES IF YOU IF YOU WOULD
TO. THE FLOOR SURE. AT TWO I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS EVAN
RACHEL WOOD AND I AM A SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- IT'S HARD
TO UNDERSTAND THE MISTER
VIOLENCE ARE ALSO UNDERSTANDING
COURSE TO CONTROL BECAUSE WHEN
DISCUSSING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PEOPLE USUALLY TALK ABOUT THE
INCIDENTS OF PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
WHICH ARE SO HORRIFIC THEY
WONDER WHY THE KING DIDN'T
LEAVE IMMEDIATELY BUT THEY
DON'T ALWAYS ACCOUNT TO THE
MONTHS OR YEARS OF COURSE TO
CONTROL THE TOOK PLACE BEFORE.
THE TEENAGER I WAS GROWN BY AN
OLDER MAN INTO AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP IN THE BEGINNING
HE WAS NICE CHARMING I NEVER
THOUGHT HE WOULD HURT ME THE
LONG WE WERE TOGETHER HE SLOWLY
CHIPPED AWAY AT MY FREEDOM
YOU'VE GOT THE TOUCH MY
RELATIONSHIP WITH MY FRIENDS
AND FAMILY BY BECOMING IRATE
INCONSOLABLE WHEN I CONTACT
WITH THEM EMOTIONAL ABUSE WITH
THAT. BEHAVIOR SCARED ME INTO
COMPLYING YOU MONITORED WHEN I
EAT AND CONTROLLED WHEN I
BLOCKED WHICH LEFT ME HUNGRY
PRIDE AND DISORIENTATED HE
BECAME OBSESSED WITH HOW I LOOK
AND WE'RE CERTAIN THINGS WHAT
ALLOWED TO WHERE HE WOULD NOT
ALLOW YOU TO PAY FOR ANYTHING
AFTER WE MOVED IN TOGETHER I
REALIZED I HAD NO RIGHT TO
ANYTHING HE WOULD ALLOW ME TO
PAY MY SHARE OF THE RENT HE
MADE IT CLEAR HE COULD THROW ME
OUT AT ANY TIME. HE THREATEN MY
REPUTATION BY TAKING PHOTOS OF
MY NAKED BODY AND AT TIMES
THREATENED TO RELEASE AND
PUBLICLY WITHOUT MY CONSENT
WHICH I LATER CAME TO KNOW IT'S
CALLED REVENGE PORN OR NON
CONSENSUAL **** YOU HAPPEN TO
MY PHONE AND SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS I CANNOT REACH OUT FOR
HELP HE WAS MONITORING ME. ON
THEIR OWN ISOLATION ALONG TO
CONTROL RT DANGERS WILL SCARY
BUT MULTIPLE FORMS AGAINST ONE
PERSON CAN BE DEADLY THINGS CAN
HAPPEN TO ME ALL AT ONCE BUT
ONCE THEY WERE ALL IN A I FELT
TRAPPED THEN BECAME SEXUALLY
INTO WE DO AS ISOLATION
CONTROLLER PEOPLE WHO HARM
CLEAR THE PATH PROVIDE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T MAKE ME CREE MORE TO
PROTECT TO ESCAPE. ESCALATED TO
VIOLENCE OR WHEN THE VICTIM WAS
DEAD. AND I BELIEVE
STRENGTHENING OUR KNOWLEDGE OF
COURSE TO CONTROL OUR STATE
WIDE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING COMMUTING. WELL DONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR THIS
A EVAN. RACHEL WOOD AND-
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY WITH
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND OPEN UP THE- OF PHONE LINES
IN THE SEARCH ANYBODY IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WANTS TO ADD
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION. AND
THEIR INDICATIONS SUPPORT. IF
NOT MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND QUEUE UP THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK. BRIEFLY WITH HER
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY IN
SUPPORT OF OUR SB ELEVEN FORTY
ONE. AND AGAIN REMINDER TO
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE QUEUING UP
TAKE YOUR PHONE OFF OF MUTE.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT MISTER
MODERATOR. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN ON THE PHONE IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE YOUR SUPPORT KNOWN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO
AT THIS TIME.AGAIN THAT'S ONE
DâN. ZERO DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
AT THIS TIME. RIGHT WE HAVE ONE
THAT JUST POPPED IN ALLOWS A
MOMENT TO PROVIDE A LINE NUMBER.
I DO HAVE THAT INDIVIDUAL NOW
WILL GO TO LINE NMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE TWO FOUR
NINE NINE NINE OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS. KONG AND MAKE IT AT A CAL
WHERE A MOMAND A VICTIM OF
COURSE THAT CONTROL ECONOMY
HALF OF MY CHILDREN ALL
CHILDREN- IN SUPPORT OF SB WHAT
ONE FOR ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE WE'LL GIVE IT ONE
LAST- CALL MISTER POTTER RAIDER
WOULD YOU GO AHEAD AND THE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WITH THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE LINES AND WISH TO QUEUE
UP TO VOICE SUPPORT YOU MAY DO
SO BY PRESSING ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE IS NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER MODERATOR WILL
LONG AGO TO OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO IS A WITNESS DESIRING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
ELEVEN FORTY ONE. IF YOU'RE A
LONG LINES AND WISH TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL YOU MAY
DO SO BY PRESSING ONE AT BEEN
IS ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE
SHOWING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. I'M SORRY THERE IS
NOT. THERE IS NOT. LET'S GIVE
IT TEN MORE SECONDS THEN WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY UP OF
INDIVIDUALS CUED UP TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
THERE ARE NONE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- BEFORE WE COULD GO TO
ANY QUESTIONS ARE. YOU
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
SENATOR CORRECT THANK YOU. AND
OF COURSE- I THINK WE ALL SHARE
SUPPORT FOR. THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL. WE KNOW DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT POWER
AND CONTROL. WHETHER IT'S
PSYCHOLOGICAL OR PHYSICAL OR
JUST INDUCING FEAR. IT IS SO
THE CHALLENGES JUST MENTION IS
OF PHYSICAL VIOLENCE THE SHOW
WILL BRUISES A LOT EASIER TO BE
ABLE TO PROVE THEN THE
EMOTIONAL ON THE MENTAL
DISTRESS. THAT IS CREATED
OFTENTIMES BY. THESE PEOPLE WHO
WISH TO CONTROL OTHERS AND IT'S
A CHALLENGING ISSUE BUT- I KNOW%
THAT YOU WERE WORKING ON TRYING
TO MAKE IT AS CLEAR AS WE CAN.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE-
WHICH IS SIMPLY CANNOT TOLERATE
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR IN OUR
SOCIETY- WILL WELL IT IS
SOMEWHAT RAMPANT IN THE STORY.
THAT WE HEARD EARLIER IS JUST
HEARTBREAKING THERE ARE SO MANY
STORIES LIKE THIS AND SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD AND- I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME. ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS THAT SOME OF THE-
GROUPS THAT WOULD NORMALLY
SUPPORT THESE MEASURES HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS AND I KNOW
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK SO THAT WE GET AS MUCH
CLARITY AS POSSIBLE. AND MAKE
THIS EFFECTIVE LAW GOING
FORWARD ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
ANY COMMENTS SENATOR WHITE
CASKET. YEAH I HAD A QUESTION
ON JUST SOME SOME CLARITY AND
SO THE VAGUENESS OF SOME OF THE
MEETINGS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
COERCIVE CONTROL YOU KNOW CAN
BE COMMITTED DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY AND I GET THAT IN
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL SAYS.
OR THROUGH THE USE OF THIRD
PARTIES AND BY MEANS OF ANY
INSTRUMENTALITY SO I GUESS
MAYBE YOU WERE HERE YEAH
EXPERTISE I DON'T KNOW WHAT ANY
INSTRUMENTALITY DOES. AND HOW
WOULD EIGHT DOES THIS COURSE OF
CONTROL DOESN'T OCCUR BETWEEN
THE TWO PARTIES IT'S HAD AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT THIRD. PARTY
THAT'S IN THERE ONLY THAT
THAT'S THERE'S NO DIRECTOR
INDIRECT. ACTIVITY OR SO IF YOU
COULD THANK YOU ARE THOUGHT SO
I WILL START WITH THE FIRST
PART- AS I HAD VERY LENGTHY
CONVERSATIONS WITH HONEST OF US
ISHERE AND- ABOUT HER COURT
CASE IN WHICH SHE EXPERIENCE-
HAVING BROUGHT FOR THE FACT
THAT HER EX HUSBAND WAS
THREATENING TO KIDNAP HER CHILD
TAKEN TO ANOTHER COUNTRY WHAT
WOMEN DIDN'T HAVE RIGHTS DRAIN
INTO HAVE A SHOT IN A DIFFERENT
COUNTRY LIKE NONE OF THAT. WAS
ACCEPTED BY THE COURTS IN HER
CASE AND STILL ARE AT TEN
REALLY WAS TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
SOMETIMES A USE A THIRD PARTY
LIKE IN THIS CASE FOR CHILD
ABOUT EIGHT KNOWLEDGE YOUR
CONCERN AND WE WILL CONTINUETO
EXPLORE THAT BUT WE WANTED TO
MAKE IT CLEAR EYED THE
MISCONCEPTION IS THAT MOST
JUDGES WOULD UNDERSTAND THIS
AND I HAVE TO SAVE FOR.
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT. THE
JUDGES DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
THAT THAT DODD LIVED EXPERIENCE
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENS IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO WE
WANTED TO CLARIFY. THAT A THIRD
PARTY CAN BE USE LIKE IN THE
CASE OF ANNA- IN YOU KNOW IN MY
CASE IT WAS A THIRD PARTY AND
THEY WOULDN'T ACCEPT TESTIMONY
CELL. MY POINT IS THAT WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN ON
THIS CASE HAD THEY BEEN BLE TO
BRING AND HER SITUATION ALL
THE- THREADS HER EX HAS BEEN
MADE AND- IN REGARDS TO HURTING
HER SON'S KIDNAPPING HIM AND
ALL THAT. MAYBE WE WOULD HAVE A
DIFFERENT OUTCOME BUT I WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE THE FISH
AND SEE HOW WE CAN. CLARIFY IT
I MEAN IT SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR
CUT DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY.
BUT IN HER CASE IT DIDN'T WORK
SO WE WANT THE SYSTEM TO WORK
AND MAKE SURE THERE'S NO BAKE
NOUS. BUT I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
CANCER WE CAN CLARIFY THAT OR-
SEE IF IT'S NECESSARY BUT I
WILL LOOK FURTHER INTO IT. YEAH
I THINK I THINK INCLUDING
COURSE OF CONTROL IN THE
DEFINITION WILL HAVE A THIRD.
OUR BENCH DECIDED THIS IS THIS
IS A APART OF ABUSE THAT THAT
LEVEL LIKE IT. AND I GET
DIRECTLY INDIRECTLY SHE'S
THROUGH ANY INSTRUMENTALITY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IT MAY I
ADD IN YOUR RIGHT WE'VE HAD
THAT DISCUSSION ABOUT
INSTRUMENTALITY AND I WANT TO
WORK ON CLARIFYING THAT. WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE- WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA JUST GROWING AT SUCH A-
FAST PACE FOR EXAMPLE TWITTER
AND FACEBOOK WAS IN OUT. AROUND
IN THE EIGHTIES NINETIES IT
GETS- THERE'S MORE ODDS TOOLS
THAT ABUSES CAN USED TO
MANIPULATE EMBARRASS HER
HUMILIATE INDIVIDUALS. AND SO
WE WERE TRYING TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS
BUT IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT AND
WE START NAMING THE TOOLS THAN
IT LIMITS. THE ABILITY FOR
SOMEONE TO SAY. YOU KNOW A NEW
TOOL COMES UP LIKE SPY WARE AND
I WAS IN PART OF THAT. YOU KNOW
WHAT WE NAMED SO WE DIDN'T WANT
TO BE VERY- PRESCRIPTIVE SOUL
SB STOOLS ARE COMING ON. TERRY
BUT I USE IT BUT I WILL ALSO
COMMIT TO SEE IF WE CAN. AT
LEAST GIVE SOME EXAMPLES
CLARIFIED A LITTLE SELL ANY
JUDGE WOULD EASILY SEE THAT
THEY'RE LIKE SOCIAL MEDIA TOOLS
AND OTHER TOOLS THAT HEY CAN
EMBARRASS A PRINTER. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU CENTER
Y. KOWSKI AND PART OF THIS TOO
IS WE PROBABLY NEED TO DO OME
BETTER EDUCATING OF OUR JUDGES-
AND I KNOW THAT WE DO WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT SO THAT THEY
BECOME MORE SENSITIZED. TO
THESE ISSUES BECAUSE SO MANY
STORIES ARE. SOHORRIFIC. IN
THE BEHAVIOR SO OUTRAGEOUS IT'S
HARD TO SOMETIMES BELIEVED BUT
IT'S THERE AND WE KNOW IT'S
THERE IN THE COURTS NEED TO BE
EDUCATED. WE HAVE. SENATOR AND
SAW FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MORNING
AND THEN. DOROS YES THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- WE SPOKE AND YOU
CERTAINLY AND LIKE ME ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF COURSE OF CONTROL
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S SO
MANY NUANCES AND GRAY AREAS IN
THIS WHOLE. SCHEME OF THINGS I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS
WELL AS MRS THAT AS I KNOW-
THIS IS PROBABLY THE HARDEST
THING YOU'VE HAD TO DO IS TO
CONTINUE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
ISSUE I REMEMBER SEEING YOUR
YOUR- YOUR SON'S FACE AND HIS
BEAUTIFUL FACE ON TV SO JUST
KNOW THAT ANY OF US YOU KNOW.
HAVE CERTAINLY- THAT YOU KNOW
WITH US AND WE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TESTING TESTIFYING
EVEN DURING THE CIRCUMSTANCES-
I TO LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THIS YOU KNOW DEVELOPS WITHIN
THE COURTS AS WELL BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
EDUCATION WE NEED TO DO TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THIS FORWARD AND
ENSURE THAT THERE'S JUSTICE FOR
ALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A SENATOR MONNING. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. I TO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR. BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. YOU'VE BEEN A
LEADER IN THIS AREA AND I KNOW.
HOW TOUGH IT IS I WANT TO THINK
YOUR WITNESS TO AND EXPRESS OUR
CONDOLENCES FOR HER LAWSON
THINKER FOR THE COURAGE TO
SHARE THAT STORY WITH THIS SOME.
SO COURSE OF CONTROL THE
EXAMPLE OF YOUR WITNESS WAS
EXTRAORDINARY RESULTING IN
DEATH THE MURDER OF HER SON. IN
MANY CASES IT'S NOT AS EXTREME
IN TERMS OF THE OUTCOME BUT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL VIOLENCE-
VIOLENCE TO THE SPIRIT. THAT'S
WHAT'S NOT BEEN RECOGNIZED BY
THE COURTS IN YOUR BILL SEEKS
TO INCLUDE THAT IN THE RANGE OF
FORMS OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
VICTIMS AND THE COURTS HAVE
BEEN NARROW IN MY VIEW-
LIMITING IN INTERPRETATION OF
VIOLENCE TO PHYSICAL VIOLENCE-
VIOLENCE TO THE SPIRIT VIOLENCE
TO THE HEART CONTROLLING.
SOMEBODY'S ACCESS TO RESOURCES
CONTROLLING ACCESS TO FAMILY
MEMBERS THREATS THREATS OF.
ELIMINATING ACCESS TO A CHILD.
IN MANY WAYS THAT VIOLENCE IS
MORE PAINFUL MORE LASTING VAN.
THE PHYSICAL VIOLENCE THIS MAY
RESULT IN THE WOUND HEALS BUT
THE TH THE VIOLENCE TO THE
SPIRIT THE VIOLENCE TO THE
HEART IN SOME CASES NEVER HEALS
SO. I WILL BE FULLY SUPPORT OF
TODAY AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING
SENATOR RUSSELL. YES AS AS
OTHERS I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
VERY MUCH FOR. EDUCATING MANY
OF US ON THE PARTICULARS- AND-
AND TO THE EXAMPLES OF THE
COURAGEOUS WOMAN WHO SPOKE
TODAY THAT. YOU'RE GIVING THEM
THE PAIN A NAME- AND
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IN A MORE
FORMAL WAY SO I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING-
ON A ON A MORE OF A OF A LEGAL.
ISSUE IS- HOW DOES THIS BECAUSE
WE ALSO ARE VERY PROUD IN OUR
SYSTEM OF THE- PEOPLE HAVING
THE WAY TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
RIGHT WHEN THERE ARE ALL OF
WRONGFUL ACCUSATIONS SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS HOW. HOWEVER
THERE PROTECTIONS THERE FOR
PEOPLE OF- WHO GET ACCUSED OF
THIS ESPECIALLY WHEN CHILDREN
ARE AT STAKE AND CHILD CUSTODY.
IS AT STAKE- WE REALLY IN A LOT
OF TIMES SEPARATIONS AND
DIVORCES AND- THOSE KINDS OF
WHEN THAT HAPPENS THERE ARE.
ALL SORTS OF. THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE GET ACCUSED OF- AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CHILDREN
I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW PROBLEMS
LIKE THAT HOW WITH THIS HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT. PEOPLE STILL
HAVE THE WAY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION- CARRIER INTENT IS NOT
TO CATCH ANYONE IN THE SYSTEM
OR THEIR FALSELY ACCUSE BUT I
LIKE THE KEY WORD THROUGHOUT
THE BAIL AND THE KEY WORD IS ON
POINT PATTERN. AND STILL DO YOU
STILL HAVE TO PROVE THEIR THEIR
CASE IN COURT BUT FOR LIKE ON A
STATUS FOR EXAMPLE THE
TESTIMONY WASN'T EVEN ALLOWED
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T A NAME TO
IT SO IT IS ON BOWLING PATTERN
AND IT'S ALSO STILL UP TO THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE JUDGE TO
TEAM DAD EVIDENCE OR TESTIMONY.
REASONABLE IN HIS OR HER EYES
SETTLED ON THE STILL HAVE TO
PROVE THEIR CASE IS NOT JUST AN
AUTOMATIC ONE INCIDENT ITS
ONGOING. THANK YOU ARCHING
FURTHER. QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR RUBIO I THANK THE
THREE FLEE IF YOU WOULD THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO THINGS SAID EVAN
RACHEL WOOD SAID AND- AND- SHE
SPOKE FAST BUT SHE HIGHLIGHTED
SLEEP DEPRIVATION AND
STARVATION AND CLEARLY THESE
ARE TACTIC TO USE IN THE
MILITARY AND WE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE FAR TO BREAK DOWN THE
OPPOSITION AND MAKE SURE THAT.
THE STRIP ANY SENSE OF DIGNITY
SO JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR EVAN RACHEL WOOD ON A WHO
SHARED HER HEART PHIL'S STORY.
THIS WITNESS MANY TIMES I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY WE'RE
GOING TO BRING THROUGH THE FOR
THE PAIN AND THE ANGUISH AND
THE NEED TO REALLY AND THIS.
GOING TO BE. IT'S GONNA FAR TOO
LONG AND IT HAS. IT LEADS TO SO
MANY. OF REAL HUMAN PROBLEMS
THE WITCHES CANNOT MINIMIZE. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- THE CHAIR
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOTION
BY SENATOR AND GONZALEZ THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS IF
MEMBERS WOULD PLEASE PUT THEIR
MICROPHONES ON. THEM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATE JACKSON HI ACCENT I DID
ALSO HI RUSSEL BY GONZALEZ HI
SALAS I JONES HI. JONES BY
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE HI I'M BURKE
AYE WACO SKI HI THE CASKET I.
YEAH SORRY BY MIKE WAS NOT ON
MY MARROW I'LL DO THAT AGAIN
STERN'S MIKE WAS IN ON TO STERN
BY STERN AYE. SO THAT'S.
1-234-567-8982 ZERO- THAT
MEASURE IS OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO HI AND THANK YOU
TO YOUR WITNESSES AS WELL BY
CONSTRUCTION IT AS A TIME CHECK
FOLKS IT IS TWELVE THIRTY WE
STILL HAVE. A FOR BILLS TO HEAR
WE ARE GOING TO MY
UNDERSTANDING SENATOR A
BRADFORD IS YOU ALSO HAVE A
PLANE TO CATCH OKAY THIS IS
TOTALLY AGAINST THE RULES BUT
ON THE CHAIR SOME ALLEGED COME
ON UP AND PRESENT. BILLS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THAT
CONSIDERATION I APPRECIATE IN
OUR NEXT EXCUSE ME SENATOR
WOULD YOU STEP BACK FOR A
MOMENT THEY'RE GOING TO CLEAN
OFF THE MICROPHONE. M. PERHAPS
CLEAR OFF THE TABLES FOR. WHAT
AFTER PLACE. YOU KNOW THESE.
YEAH THAT'S TRUE THE MONITOR
THE PROBABLY RAN OUT OF. ALL
RIGHT. I BELIEVE THE SENATOR DO
YOU HAVE A WITNESSES THAT YOU
ARE HOPING TO HAVE A TESTIFIED
BY A PHONE I BELIEVE SO YES TO-
ARE CAN WE JUST MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE. AVAILABLE IN ONLINE.
HE MIGHT EVEN HAVE TO HAVE THEM
ON THE PHONE YEAH ALL RIGHT SO
CAN WE CALL THEM OUT HOPEFULLY
THEIR WATCHING OR IF YOUR STAFF
CAN TEXT THEM. AND SO WE CAN
HAVE THEM ON THE PHONE TO SPEAK
WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO BE
HEARD. I BELIEVE SEE. YOU HAVE
ON THE PHONE SEPARATE CHEN
VISION. I HOPE I GOT THE RIGHT
IN JOSE CAN- CAN KNOWN CAN ONUS
ON THIS CAN HONEST- IF WE COULD
ASK THEM TO PLEASE CALL IN SO
THAT THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY WHEN YOU HAVE CONCLUDED
CHORE- OPENING REMARKS OF
SENATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SENATOR MADAM CHAIR
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY PRESENT SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN AND I ASK A
KNOWLEDGE TO. THE MEMINTA THE
COMMITTEE IS WORK WITH- PAGES
SEVEN AND EIGHT- OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN IS WILL BE THE
FIRST BILL IN THE NATION IT
REQUIRES LANDLORDS MANAGE
SUBSIDIZE MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES TO
OFFER. THAT TO NOT OF HAVING
THEIR RENT PAYMENT. MAJOR RULES.
THREE MEASURE MANY TIMES YOU
SEE CRY BUREAUS USED TO NOT.
INDIVIDUALS ARE RIGHT TO RANT
WE JUST SAY USES TO ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO BUILD CREDIT. BY
FOCUSING ON SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
BILLS TAILORED TO THOSE TENANTS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE GREATEST
BENEFIT FROM ESTABLISHING OR
IMPROVING THEIR CREDIT SCORES.
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ALSO
INCLUDES A DELAYED- OPERATIVE
DATE OF JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO ALLOW TIME FOR LANDLORDS
TO DETERMINE. HOW BEST TO
COMPLY AND WHAT MAKES THE BEST
SENSE FOR THEM. ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN IS A SIMPLE GOAL TO
REVIVE RUNNERS A WAY TO
ESTABLISH OR PROVE THEIR CREDIT
SCORES TO THE PAYMENT AROUND ON
TIME. WE ALL KNOW A RENTERS TO
HAVE LIVED TO LEASE I DO AND
ONE PLACE FOR. THOUSANDS OF
YEARS AND NEVER MASS MISSED A
RENTAL PAYMENT BUT AS SHOWN NO
BENEFIT TO THEIR CREDIT SCORES
THIS WILL FOR THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY. WE ALL KNOW THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF WORK THE
CONSEQUENCES WHEN YOU FAIR BILL
THE PAY YOUR RENT SO. THERE'S
NO REASON RUNNERS WHO REGULARLY
PAY THE RENT ON TIME SHOULD
RECEIVE POSITIVE IMPACTS. OF A
CREDIT SCORE BY TWO- AND OUR
WITNESSES AT STATUS SEARCH AND
THEN FROM THE CURRENT OF
BUILDERS ALLIANCE AND JOSE
QUINONES. FROM THE MISSIONS
ASSET FUNDS IF THEY'RE
AVAILABLE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
TO WE HAVE THOSE WITNESSES NOW
ON THE LINE. THEY ARE ON THE
LINE VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY.
SEEING NO ONE THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE WILL GO TO
THE TWO WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE
ON THE PHONE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO CAUTION THEM- THAT THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF THEIR TIME
COLLECTIVELY IS THREE MINUTES-
WE ARE KEEPING TRACK. SO THAT-
THEY CONSISTS AND- SURE IT
ANYWAY THEY WISH BUT IT THERE
WILL BE A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES SO YOUR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE GO AHEAD INTRODUCE
YOURSELF YOU MAY START. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN.
I'M THIRTY AND THEN WITH
CRITICAL- ALLIANCE A NATIONAL
NON PROFIT THAT SEEKS TO HELP
ORGANIZATIONS MOVE PEOPLE FROM
POVERTY TO PROSPERITY THROUGH
CREDIT BUILDING- A GOOD CREDIT
HISTORY AS WE ALL KNOW IS
CRUCIAL IN TODAY'S ECONOMY AND
IT'LL BE EVEN MORE IMPORTANT AS
WE EMERGE FROM THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. ADDRESSING CREDIT
MARKETS ALREADY TIGHTENING.
WITHOUT A CRIME CREDIT SCORE
INDIVIDUALS PAY HIGHER INTEREST
AND FEES ARE ALSO PRODUCTS. AND
SPEND MORE ON THE SOCIAL
SERVICES LIKE CAR INSURANCE YOU
CELL PHONE. THIS CREATES WHAT
WE IT SHOULD. X. INEQUALITY AND
COMPOUNDS HARDSHIP MAKING IT
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR
HOUSEHOLDS TO GET AND STAY
AHEAD. WINTERS ARE ALREADY MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE LOWER INCOMES.
WELL THEN THERE HOMEOWNER
COUNTERPARTS AND SEVEN TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE MINIMAL
CREDIT HISTORY THAT IS BEING
DONE FOR. FURTHER MORE MANY
HAVE FEWER OPTIONS THE BILL
THEIR CREDIT HISTORIES AND RENT
RECORDING. OF THE PRUDENT
STRATEGY TO HELP THEM. YEARS
AGO SHE CAN A PILE THAT
INCLUDED A THOUSAND LOW INCOME
RENTERS 79% OF THOSE SAW THAT
THEIR CREDIT SCORES INCREASED
BY AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY THREE
POINT IN THAT THE RESULT. 15%
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS MOVED INTO
A LOWER RISK CHAIR EVERY RENTER
YOU START WITH THE PILOT-
CREDIT AND DIFFICULT BECAME
SQUABBLE DURING THE PROGRAM AT
A HIGH OF NON PRIME OR PRIME
LEVEL. THE FUEL BY THESE
FINDINGS AND SUBSEQUENT EFFORTS
YEAH I HAVE SEEN GREATER
INTEREST IN RENT REPORTING AT
HIGH IN AS A HIGH IMPACT-
DILUTION IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
THE PLACE BASED IT'S SIMPLE AND
SCALABLE. WE'VE ALSO BEGUN TO
SEE POLICY IN STATES LIKE NEW
YORK MASSACHUSETTS AND YOU SEE
PROMOTE RENT REPORTING IS A
VIABLE AND POWERFUL CREDIT
BUILDING STRATEGY. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE THE FIRST
IN THE NATION TO REALLY MOVE
THE NEEDLE FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME RENTERS SPEAKING TO
ESTABLISH ONE THROUGH THEIR
CREDIT SCORES WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO REACH AN ESTIMATED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF LOW.
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
OF THE RESULT OF. TWO SEVEN
THANK. GOD I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE THANK YOU. RIGHT
MISTER CONCERNING SHOOTING ONE
SIR. GOOD THING YOU MADAM AND
MY NAME IS LIKE YOU KNOW HE'LL
I'VE BEEN OFFICE. AND FOR THAT
WE THAT MY COLLEAGUES ARE
MENTIONED YOU KNOW ASK YOUR
SHOW. SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN.
HOW PEOPLE IS FROM LIFE INTO.
YOU KNOW I CURRENT TO REDUCE
OUR CRIED OF NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN. AND THREE DAYS PARTICULAR
AT HAVE HAS TO YOU KNOW SIXTY
SEVEN WILL THERE BE PEOPLE AS
PART WILL CHARM. I HAVE HAD
THEM INCLUDING THE CRIME
THRILLER AS AS WE IT. A MORE
FOR CAR. IS A FOLDER REASONS WE
LOVE OUR AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT BECAUSE THERE'S IN BILL
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE GREAT
FOR THE PAIN YOU'RE RIGHT. AND
WHATEVER AND THEN WANT THAT
GRANT COULD BE IN THEIR ARE
QUITE A REPORT. THANK YOU MUCH
PERFECT PERFECT TIMED. ARE
MYSTERY. WOULD YOU. PROMPT IN.
WAITING TO TEST. ON SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN THAT WE MAY BE. AND
A- FOR THOSE WHO TO TEST PLEASE
ON ME. YOUR PHONE. SO THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY. OF NAME. AFFILIATION
AND INDICATING THAT YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE SO WITH
THAT- MISTER MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO
AT THIS TIME THAT'S ONE BAND.
WELL WE DID HAVE ONE THAT HAD
ALREADY CUED UP WE'LL GO TO BAT
LINE IT IS LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX TWO TWO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RHONDA
AND FEDERAL LAW AND POVERTY AND
OR- THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT
IT'S ONE VAN ZERO. I AM NOT
SHOWING ANYBODY ELSE DOING UP
AT THIS TIME WHAT DO WE WANT
ANOTHER TEN SECONDS AND THEN WE
WILL MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION.
CERTAINLY. MISTER MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE. WE
DO NOT ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- IF YOU WOULD OPEN
THE LINES AND ALLOW THOSE WHO
ARE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN. TO PLEASE TAKE THEIR
PHONES OFF OF MUTE AND I DO
BELIEVE TO WE HAVE. A WITNESS
LINED UP YES WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS LINED UP WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. MYSTERON
KINGSTON OF CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIC ADVISERS IS MISTER
KINGSTON ON THE PHONE. YEAH ALL
RIGHT MISTER. MISTER KINGSTON
IF YOU WOULD LIKE AGAIN- I AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO GIVE
TESTIMONY PER SE AND SO WE WILL
A LOT TO THE SAME THREE MINUTES
THAT THE SUPPORT GOD- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO START. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE CRANIUM RUN
KINGSTON. WE REPRESENT A VERY
UNIQUE- GROUP- OF AFFORDABLE
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATIONS THERE.
THEY COLLECTIVELY- MANAGE. DEED
RESTRICTED PROPERTIES FOR LOW
INCOME AT 50% OR BELOW IS THE
AREA WIDE MEDIAN. ALL DISABLED
AND SENIOR HOUSING THERE'S
NOTHING ELE THAT THEY DO THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF UNITS THAT THEY
OWN AND MANAGE IN CALIFORNIA IS
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND UNIT SO IT'S NO SMALL
NUMBER- SO. THESE GROUPS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION OF PACIFIC%
SOUTHWEST AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND HAWAII. HELD
PROPERTIES THAT ARE FINANCED BY
HARD TO OR- STATE TAX CREDIT
PROPERTIES OR THEY ARE-
PROVIDED BY- IN HOUSE BY PEOPLE
HAVING SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS
THE HAVING SAID THAT WE HAVE.
BEEN IN CONSTANT CONVERSATION
WITH- MISTER BRADFORD AND- HIS
ABLE STAFF TRYING TO CRAFT OUT
A AN ACCEPTABLE BILL WERE NOT
THERE UNFORTUNATELY- AND LET ME
GIVE YOU THE- THE REASONS WHY
IT IS VERY VERY PROBLEMATIC FOR
THESE- HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
UNITS THAT ARE OWNED AND
MANAGED IN CALIFORNIA- FIRST OF
ALL. THIS BILL FOCUSES ON LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE IN
JUST THESE UNITS AND NOT ALL
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
ARGUABLY MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING HOUSED IN UNITS THAT
ARE DEEMED RESTRICTED THAT ARE
NOT HEAVILY RESTRICTED FOR UP
TO FIFTY FIVE YEARS. AND FOR
ALL THOSE SO IF WE- DECREASED
AND PROVIDE THIS- THIS AUCTION-
FORD DOES TO BUY INTO THIS TYPE
OF PROGRAM. EVERYBODY ELSE-
WILL NOT BENEFIT ARGUABLY THERE
FOR. THE CREDIT SCORES OF
EVERYBODY ELSE THEY CAN'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS AND IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS THEIR SCORES WILL G DOWN
AND OTHERS WILL GO UP AT THE
EXPENSE WE DON'T SEE THAT TO BE
VERY EQUITABLE SECOND. WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WOULD- OFFER
A PROGRAM. TO TENANTS I TO-
COME HELL A PROPERTY OWNER OR
MANAGEMENT COMPANY TO REPORT TO
THE CREDIT BUREAU- THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION- FOR THE SOLE
BENEFIT NOT THE HOUSE- THE
THESE ARE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. BUT SO THAT THEY
CAN GET BETTER CREDIT FOR
BUYING CARS BUYING STEREOS
BUYING ALL SORTS OF OTHER
THINGS HAVING NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE HOUSING AND WINKING
MISSILE THAT IS THANK YOU ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN THANK YOU
MISTER KINGSTON. THANK YOU SIR.
RIGHT RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY DRY
WE HAD SURGERY. THAT IS THREE
MINUTES AND THIRTY SECONDS
ACTUALLY I GAVE YOU A LITTLE
MORE TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO THE LINES AND- SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS ITEM IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN AGAIN PLEASE TAKE YOUR
PHONE OFF OF MUTE AND MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PROCEED.
SO WE CAN HEAR THE NAME
AFFILIATION AN INDICATION OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
CERTAINLY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPILLWAYS OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO. WE DID HAVE ONE THAT
DID Q. UP ALREADY WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE TWO FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE AFTERNOON SURE
JACKSON MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. IMPOSE
MUCH TO MAKE DECISION ON THIS
MEASURE. CA ARE WILL OPPOSE AS
THE ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN AM TOLD
AS AMENDED TO ATTEMPT SMALL
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS OF
ASSISTED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
BLACK THE RESOLUTION COMPLY
WITH A NEW OWNER IT'S UNTESTED
MECHANISM THANK YOU SIR HILL.
ALRIGHT NEXT WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE
OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR. THERE ARE NONE CUED
UP AT THIS TIME RIGHT WILL GIVE
IT ANOTHER TEN SECONDS AND THEN
WE WILL- BRING THIS BACK TO THE
DYESS. I NOTED SENATOR BORCHERS
HAS RAISED HIS HAND WE WILL
START WITH HIM IF THERE ARE NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE.
JEFFERSON JACKSON THERE ARE
NONE IN Q. AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU SIR BRING THIS BACK TO THE
DIET SENATOR BOARD USE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES INDEED. THANK YOU- MY
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR THROUGH
THE CHAIR. JUL BLUDGEONING IS.
WHY WOULD IT NOT BE MORE
EQUITABLE TO HAVE. OUR LOW
INCOME RENTERS THAT DO NOT
RECEIVE STATUS SYSTEMS. BE
ELIGIBLE FOR OUR CREDIT
REPORTING- REGIMEN THAT YOU'RE
IDENTIFYING HERE. WITH THAT NOT
SEEM MORE EQUITABLE THAT. ALL
OF RENTAL HISTORY HE REPORTED.
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND WELL THE STATE
QUESTIONNAIRE. ESSENTIALLY I
BELIEVE THE QUESTION IS
SHOULDN'T ALL RENTAL HISTORY TO
BE REPORTED INCLUDING THOSE WHO
ARE NOT ON. ASSISTANCE IS THAT
IS THAT THE QUESTION CENTER
BORCHERS. ESSENTIALLY IT US. I
WOULD AGREE WITH THIS BUT THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP OF TRYING TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS ESTABLISH
CREDIT SOUL AS WE OFTEN SAY WE
DEVELOPED A ONE BITE AT A TIME
SO THIS IS OUR FIRST ATTEMPT AT
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING TO HELP ON
THE SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION A
STOLID SO. CREDIT HISTORY. SAID
ANSWER QUESTIONS SENATOR IT
DOES- PARTIALLY- I THINK I CAN
APPRECIATE THE PREDICAMENT THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE THE MEANS BY WHICH
TO ACHIEVE OF FACTORS THAT GO
INTO CREDIT WORTHINESS ARE.
STANDARDS IT JUST SEEMS A
LITTLE UNFAIR TO THE
ESSENTIALLY WORKING FOLKS IN IN
WORKING COR IF YOU WILL IN MANY
INSTANCES WHERE YOU DON'T
RECEIVE STATE ASSISTANCE. AND
DON'T DRIVE A BENEFIT SO WERE
ALLOWING A BENEFIT. TO EXIST
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING
STATE ASSISTANCE. AND NOT
HAVING THE DISCRETION OVER
THOSE DOLLARS THAT WOULD
NORMALLY GO TO THE RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S PRESCRIBED. THE
SECTION EIGHT OR SOME OTHER
PROGRAM- I WOULD JUST FIRST I
WOULD ASK HE AUTHOR IF YOU
WOULD CONSIDER. THROUGH
FRIENDLY AMENDMENT THAT IF YOU
WERE TO MOVE FORWARD THAT IT
NOT BE FOR OUR STATE OR
FEDERAL. FEDERALLY SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING SUPPORT HI JUST RANGERS
AS A WHOLE I THINK. THAT I
THINK WE MORE EQUITABLE AND THE
SECOND WOULD HE CONSIDER THAT
THE MOM AND POP LANDLORDS. OUR
THAT WOULD NOW BE REQUIRED TO
ISSUE THIS TYPE OF OUR OUR-
MONTHLY YEAH RECORDING OR
ORIENTAL REPORTING THAT WOULD
NOT BE BETTER YES THE ENTITY
THAT PROVIDES THE- OUR SUPPORT.
SECTION EIGHT OR HARD TO BEAT
THE ENTITY RESPONSIBLE WITH
SUBMITTING. THAT REPORT
BECAUSE- I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
ASKING A LOT OF FOLKS TO BECOME
VERY SOPHISTICATED NURSES
QUESTIONS ARE. HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT NOW WILL BE
MY FINAL REQUEST- FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER AND MAYBE EVEN IF YOU
CAN RESPOND TO THAT NOW IT I'D
LIKE TO. WELL AS IT RELATES TO
THE MOM AND POPS I KNOW PLENTY
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS WHO OWN.
HUNDREDS OF UNITS IN NO NONE
OTHER BUILDING SOMETIMES EXCEED
MORE THAN TEN UNITS PER UNIT
AND THEY CONSIDER THEMSELVES
MOM AND POP RUNNER SO I DO
UNDERSTAND THE SMALLER FOLKS
WHO. OWN THREE OR FOUR UNITS
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION TO HELP
WORK OUT SOME OF THOSE COULD
KINKS AND CONCERNS THAT ARE.
WILL BE FACED BY SOME THESE
LANDLORDS IT'S ALSO A TEN
DOLLAR FEE THAT I. I'M WILLING
TO ACCEPT TO AID BILL SMALL MOM
AND POP OUR LANDLORD SO THEY
DON'T- BEAR THE FULL COST OF
THIS REPORTING PROCESS BUT
AGAIN. IF THIS MEASURE MEASURES
PASSED WE HAVE UNTIL JANUARY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
WORK OUT SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
AND HELP ADDRESS AND
FACILITATE. THOSE SMALL
OPERATORS IN A MEETING THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVE HERE AND
AGAIN THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM IT'S NOT MANDATORY- IT
HAS TO BE AGREED UPON BY BOTH
THE RENTERS AND THE LANDLORD IN
ORDER. FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I JUST LIKE TO ADD I THINK
PART OF THE REASON IS IT'S MANY
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA'S ARE
OFTEN UNBANKED WERE UNDER BANK
SO THEY HAVE NO CREDIT HISTORY-
WHATSOEVER- AND IT HAD LITTLE
OR- NO ESTABLISHED. OPPORTUNITY
SO- AGAIN MADE BEING VOLUNTARY
AYE I THINK THAT IS A NEW WANTS
THAT THAT IS DESERVING OF A
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AS WELL THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER A SENATOR
TO ROSS SO YEAH I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S GREAT I
THINK TAKEN A- BIG STEP
FORWARD. THESE ARE THE FOLKS
WHO HAVE THE HARDEST TIME
ESTABLISHING CREDIT. I MEAN YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE- IN THE OWN YOUR
HOME IF YOU. OWN IF YOU ON THIS
OR THAT OR YOUR INCOME THAT'S
MUCH EASIER- RESTART YOUR
STARTING WITH THE ONES THAT ARE
HAVING THE MOST DIFFICULT TIME.
AND TRYING TO USE THAT THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE GOOD AND PAYING
THEIR RENT. YOU KNOW AS A WAY
OF SHOWING THAT THEY'RE WORTHY
OF A GOOD CREDIT EXCITED. I
THINK IT'S GREAT THANK YOU. SO
ARE WILL ENTER. A MALL. IS TO
REMOTE. BY THE MOVE BY THE THIS
STERN OF THE CENTER BRED IF
LIKE TO RE CLOSE. THANK YOU
KNOW WHEN TO THANK OF- OF THE
SUPPORTERS OPPOSITION ON ON THE
ADDRESSING THIS MEASURE AGAIN
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO JR DRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS BUT I THINK THIS
AGAIN SHOWS HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
LEAD TO NATION AND MOVING
FORWARD AND SERVING SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION THAT
EXISTED PRIOR TO CALL THAT
NINETEEN BUT NOW IN LIGHT OF
THIS. AND LET ME ADDRESS THE-
BECOMING CREDIT WORTHY AND THE
FIRST THING YOU WANT TO DO IS
GO BUY A STEREO OR CAR.
BECOMING CREDIT WORTHY YOU
MIGHT MOVE OUT OF BEING A
RUNNER FOR TWENTY AND THIRTY
YEARS AND BY YOUR FIRST HOME SO
THAT'S WHAT MANY PEOPLE STRIVE
TO DO WHEN THEY BECOME CREDIT
WORTHY IS NOT GO OUT AND BUY A
STEREO. BUT BE ABLE TO QUIT
BEING AROUND HER AND ONE DAY BE
A LAND OWNER AND A PROPERTY
OWNER AND OWN THEIR OWN HOME SO
I RESPECTFULLY I SURE I WILL.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS A TO THE SENATE FLOOR BY
SENATOR STERN. EVERYBODY EXCUSE
ME AS TO PASS AS AMENDMENT
EXCUSE ME TO THE SENATE FLOOR
MICROPHONES ON PLEASE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. JACKSON HI JACKSON I
DID ALSO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I JONES. MONNING AYE MONNING
AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE BURKE.
I'M BURKE I WAKE CAL SKI. TWO
THREE NINE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX OF SIX ZERO LEAVE IT OPEN
SIXTIES HERE WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD THE COMMENTER MEMBERS
ARE. SAFE TRAVELS. WE ARE NOW
GOING TO CALL ON SENATOR UMBERG
WHO HAS TO MEASURES AND WE WILL
CONCLUDE WITH SENATOR TO RISE
SHOWS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SO WE
ARE GOING BACK NOW AND THANK
YOU SENATOR BURKE- FOR
DEFERRING. A YEAR TIME- VERY
GENTLEMANLY AND I'LL PROBABLY
TAKE A LOT OF HEAT FOR GOING
OUT OF- FILE ORDERS ARE WAS
DIRECTED TO DO BUT THE- OFFER
GOOD CAUSE AND WE WILL START
NOW IS FILE ITEM FIVE SB NINE
EIGHTY. Q. MANTRA THAT WAS ME
SMILING PROBABLY COULDN'T TELL.
OF RESULT LET LET ME THANK YOU
IN THE COMMITTEE FOR-
SUGGESTING AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE- THAT IMPROVE THE BILL I
CERTAINLY ACCEPT THEM- WHAT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES THIS BILL-
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO. GENETIC DATA THAT
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
PROVIDE TO VARIOUS ENTITIES OF
FOR PURPOSES OF FOR EXAMPLE
ASSESSING THEIR ANCESTRY I HAVE
DONE THAT MYSELF- BUT I WAS
ALERTED TO AN ISSUE THAT I
HADN'T QUITE THOUGHT ABOUT
EARLIER- THIS YEAR. WHEN I
THOUGHT THE PART DEFENSE MEMO
THAT ADVICE MILITARY MEMBERS
NOT TO PROVIDE THEIR DNA TO
DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING COMPANY BASED THE
FOLLOWING THESE DTC GENETIC
TESTS ARE LARGELY UNREGULATED
AND COULD EXPOSE PERSONAL AND
GENETIC INFORMATION AND
POTENTIALLY CREATE UNINTENDED
SECURITY CONSEQUENCES INCREASED
RISK TO THE JOINT. FORCE AND
MISSION- WHAT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT SAYS SIMPLY THAT. IF
YOU PROVIDE YOUR DNA. AND THE
ENTITY TO HOME YOU PROVIDE THE
DNA WHICH IS TO USE IT FOR
OTHER PURPOSES WHAT ITS
RESEARCH OR EVEN COMMERCIAL
PURPOSES THEY CAN DO SO. THEY
JUST NEED YOUR INFORMED CONSENT
AND SO THE BILL. AS A
PROHIBITION ON ENTITIES
PROVIDING. INFORMATION WITHOUT
YOUR CONSENT- THE ISSUE IS
PROBABLY MORE ACUTE NOW THAT WE
HAVE. COVE IN NINETEEN TESTING
ALTHOUGH COVERT NINETEEN
TESTING TESTS FOR OUR NAY DOES
NOT TEST FOR DNA BUT WHAT IS
CAPTURED CAN ALSO BE USED FOR
DNA PURPOSES. AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS THAT- AS REFLECTED BY
THE BUSINESS INSIDER IS THAT
100% OF THE GENETIC DATA WHICH
IS DE IDENTIFIED CAN ULTIMATELY
BE IDENTIFIED TO A SPECIFIC
HUMAN BEING- WE ARE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WE DO
NOT WANT LAW ENFORCEMENT TO-
NOT HAVE THIS INVESTIGATIVE
TOOL- BUT- THAT THAT. IT IS
STILL AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED- BOTTOM SIX DRUM BAND
I. WHISPER WITH I'VE- IT THANK
YOUVERY MUCH MY UNDERSTANDING
WE HAVE WE HAVE WITNESSES ALSO
LET ME LET ME INTRODUCE THE
WITNESSES- OR WITNESS OF MISS
MAUREEN MAHONEY A POLICY
ANALYST FOR CONSUMER REPORTS
VERY GOOD MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU ARE PRESENTING HERE IN
OR DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. I DO
NOT ALL RIGHT WITH THAT MS
MAHONEY YOU ARE OR HAVE A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES IF YOU'D LIKE
TO USE THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
BUT IT IS AVAILABLE THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING OR I SHOULD
SAY GOOD AFTERNOON. AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS
MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M A POLICY
ANALYST AT CONSUMER REPORTS.
AND WE'RE PROBABLY SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD GIVE
CONSUMERS. IMPORTANT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS OVER SOME OF THEIR
MOST UNIQUELY SENSITIVE DATA.
DATA COLLECTED BY DIRECT
CONSUMER TESTING COMPANIES.
THIS DATA CAN PROVIDE INSIGHT
INTO WHETHER OR NOT BOB
CONSUMERS OR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE VULNERABLE TO.
CONSTANT ABILITY EATING
DISEASESLIKE BREAST CANCER FOR
CYSTIC FIBROSIS. THAT'S
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE USED TO
MAKE IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT
CONSUMERS THE CONSUMER SHOULD
BE IN CONTROL OF THAT. MILLIONS
OF CONSUMERS HAVE ALREADY UC'S
KIDS TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND DISCOVER
THAT CONSUMERS WILL LIKELY
ASSUME THAT THE STATE IS
PROTECTED BY STRONG. HEALTH
PRIVACY LAWS LIKE HYPOCRISY IN
MIAMI. THEY DO HAVE DEFAULT
PROTECTIONS OVER DISCLOSURE OF
DATA. BUT UNFORTUNATES NOT THE
CASE. IN TERMS OF PRIVACY THIS
DATA IS CHIEFLY. REGULATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT. UNFORTUNATE SO MUCH WEAKER
LAW THAT PROVIDES NEXT NEW
CONTROLS OVER WHAT COMPANIES
CAN USE THIS DATA FOR. IT DOES
HAVE AN OPT OUT A SALE BUT THAT
ONLY TAKES IN AFTER THE
CONSUMER TAKES AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION SO THAT MEANS THAT BY
DEFAULT COMPANIES COULD SELL
THE STATED TO THIRD PARTIES
LEGALLY. THIS BILL CORRECT
BALANCE BY INSURING MEANINGFUL
CONSENT SOFT FOR SECONDARY USES
AND DISCLOSURE OF THIS DATA.
EVEN IF IT'S AN DE IDENTIFIED
FORM PUTTING CONSUMERS SQUARELY
CONTROL OF HOW THIS INFORMATION
IS TYPICALLY USED AND FOR THAT
FROM. IN THIS BILL IS TIMELY
ASSESSING OUTSIDE OF THE
HEALTHCARE. LIKELY TO INCREASE
IN LIGHT OF COVER NINETEEN-
WHATEVER FORM THESE TESTS TAKE
THAT MEANS THE COMPANIES ARE
GOING TO HAVE INCREASED OF
PHYSICAL POSSESSION OF
CONSUMERS GENETIC MATERIAL AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
PROTECTED. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT SORELY NEEDED AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT- ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES I GUESS OR STONE
AND TWENTY FORTY OF THIS
MODERATOR WOULD YOU QUEUE UP-
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHTY FILE
ITEM FIVE BY SENATOR ON BURKE.
CERTAINLY IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE EIGHTY YOU
MAY DO SO ON THE PHONE AT THIS
TIME BY PRESSING ONE AND- I'LL-
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE
MISTER MODERATOR. YEP WHAT IT
IS QUEUED UP TO GET THEIR LINE
NUMBER TO THE MOMENTARILY
ALREADY IN AGAIN FOR THOSE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE ON MUTE YOUR
PHONE. OKAY WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY THREE THAT'S FIVE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR. ONCE AGAIN TO
QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT IT'S ONE
TEN ZERO. DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE LINE AT THIS TIME. NOT NOT
AT THIS TIME. NOT AT THIS TIME
IT WILL GIVE A TEN MORE SECONDS
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION. WHICH MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE CUED UP IN
SUPPORT. WE DO NOT AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT IF THERE ARE NO MORE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LET'S GO
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
CALLING IN WITH CONCERNS.
GUARDING THE BILL- IS THIS-
MISTER ERIC HEATH THE CHIEF
PRIVACY OFFER FOUR ANCESTRY AND
JACQUI HAGGERTY GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR TWENTY THREE AND ME. A
MISTER MODERATOR ARE THEY ON
THE LINE. THEY ARE INDEED ALL
RIGHT SO WE WILL GIVE YOU A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES- WHOEVER
WANTS TO START PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHURCH BACK THEN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JACKIE HAGGERTY I AM
THAT THE PM LEGAL AND PRIVACY
OFFICER WITH TWENTY THREE ME.
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
COALITION FOR GENETIC DATA
PROTECTION WE'RE PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO DISCUSS AT THE NINE
EIGHTY. IT HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH SENATOR
UMBERG OFFICE AND ARE HOPEFUL
WE CAN GET TO A POINT WHERE WE
CAN FULLY ENDORSE THE BILL.
TODAY WE SUPPORT THE SPELL IF A
MAN DEAD. FROM THE START WE
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH THE CENTRAL TENET OF
THE BELL CONSUMERS SHOULD AT
ALL TIMES HAVE CONTROL OVER
THEIR GENETIC INFORMATION THE
PURPOSES FOR WHICH  DIFFUSE
AND WITH HIM THAT INFORMATION
IS SHARED. BY FIRE COMPANY
JOINED WITH OTHERS IN THE
INDUSTRY TO DEVELOP THE PRIVACY
BACK PRACTICES FOR CONSUMER.
GENETIC TESTING SERVICES.
TOGETHER WITH PRIVACY. AND IF
YOU OF PRIVATE PEOPLE. WE
DEVELOPED WHAT WE BELIEVE ARE
THE A PER. GUIDELINES TO ENSURE
CONSUMERS HAVE CONTROL OVER
THEIR DATA. ARE PRESENTED WITH
EASY TO UNDERSTAND PRIVACY
POLICIES AND ARE EMPOWERED TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON HOW THEIR
DATA SHOULD BE IT. AT THE
BEGINNING OF OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH OUR- CUSTOMERS THEY
PROVIDE CONTENT BEFORE WE
PERFORM THE INITIAL AMOUNT THAT
THAT THEIR DNA. THEY THEN CAN
MAKE A NUMBER OF AFFIRMATIVE
OFTEN CHOICES. THEY CHOOSE
WHETHER THEIR EXAMPLE SHOULD BE
STORED WHETHER TO SEE POTENTIAL
GENETIC RELATIVES AND WHETHER
TO PARTICIPATE AND HIGHER BE
APPROVED RESEARCH PROJECT. THEY
CAN ALSO CHOOSE TO DELETE THEIR
ACCOUNT. THEIR INFORMATION AND
DESTROY THEIR SAMPLE ANYTIME.
WE CARE DEEPLY THE CANCER RIGHT
TO MAKE THOSE CHOICES AND OUR
OBLIGATION TO PREVENT THEM WITH
CLEAR INFORMATION OUT THEY MAKE
THAT DECISION. WE WANTED TO
ADDRESS SEVERAL CLAIMS MADE BY
CONSUMER REPORTS TO THE
COMMITTEE WHEN THEY STATE THAT
GENETIC INFORMATION GATHERED BY
DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
COMPANIES CAN BE SHARED OR SOLD
TO THIRD PARTIES WITHOUT THE
BUDGET TO THE CONSUMER. THEY
DIDN'T LEADING OUR COMPANIES
ARE SUBJECT TO AN ALREADY
COMPLY WITH NOTICE AND
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CPA. FURTHER WE ARE
CONTRACTUALLY FOR CLOTHES FROM
ANY SUCH SHARING OR TAIL. FIRED
ON TERMS OF SERVICE WHICH WE
PROVIDE OUR CUSTOMERS. WHEN
THEY SAY THAT 71% OF COMPANIES
CAN YOU CONSUMER INFORMATION
INTERNALLY FOR PURPOSES OTHER
THAN PROVIDING RESULTS TO THE
CUSTOMER HE AGAIN QUESTION WHAT
COMPANY IS THAT WHAT PURPOSES
THEIR BACKGROUND THING. OUR
COALITION MEMBERS EXPLAINED IN
PLAIN ENGLISH THE USES OF
GENETIC DATA IN OUR PRIVATE
RESPECTIVE PRIVACY POLICIES. AT
AT THE NINE EIGHTY MINUTES
FORWARD WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AUTHOR AND ALL LEGISLATORS TO
KEEP CHOI. CHOICE IS IN THE
HANDS OF CONSUMERS AND TO
PROVIDE THE FLEXIBILITY IN HOW
WE COMMUNICATE THOSE CHOICES
AND OBSCENE CONTENT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OF MISTER HE
THANK YOU HAVE A AFFECTED PLEA
THIRTY SECONDS BUT I WILL GIVE
YOU A MINUTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR BACK THEN-IN
ADDITION TO- OUR COMMEMORATIVE
CONSUMER PRIVACY WELL. LET ME
FIRST SAY THANK YOU- IN JAIL.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG'S
OFFICE FOR ENGAGING WITH US ON
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY- BUT
YOU WANT TO ECHO. THE COMMENTS
SO- BETWEEN THIRTY ME- I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT A COUPLE
FLAWS- BUT WE ARE STILL WORKING
ON WITH THE- WITH CENTERS
OFFICE. AND THAT IS- IMPEDING
OUR ABILITY TO ENDORSE THIS
BILL FULLY VERSES THAT THE DEBT
DEFINITION GENETIC GOT IN THE
BILL. HE'S FROM THE NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE HUNDRED CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT- DIST IT IS TIME BARRING
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
GENETIC DATA. I WAS AT THAT
TIME RATHER IT WAS YOU KNOW
THAT BARRING DISCRIMINATION ON
THE BASE TO CHECK THAT IT WAS
GROUNDBREAKING- BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING GENETIC DATA AND
ITS APPLICATION TO VASTLY
EXPANDED- WE'VE- WE'VE SUGGEST
A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE- THE
MORE ACT REALLY CAPTURED WHAT
WE WOULD NEED TO TALK. WHAT WE
WOULD MEAN. ABOUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GINNY HAD A. THE WOULD BE
REPORT. OF THE- IMPROVEMENTS
NEXT AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE
BILL WOULD. ALL BY LAW SAMPLE
ENGINE IMPROVE. TO BE JUST. OR
DELETED ONCE THE SPECIFIC
PURPOSE OF THE AUTHOR A
AUTHORIZED BY THE INDIVIDUALS
FULFILLED. HERE AGAIN WE
BELIEVE THE CONSUMER CONTROL.
OVER HOW THEIR DATA AND SAMPLES
ARE HANDLED SHOULD SHOULD
PREVAIL. WE DO STORE INDIVIDUAL
BIOLOGICAL SAMPLES BUT ONLY TO
CONSUMER AUTHORIZES US TO DO
SO- AND THEY MUST MAKE AN
INFORMED CHOICE. ABOUT CHOICE
WHEN THEY SIGN UP FOR THE
SERVICE CONNECTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- MONEY THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY ALREADY
APPRECIATE THAT. IN A- NUMBER
Gí
OPPOSITION OR OF THE- THOSE
WITH CONCERNS- AND WILL ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES. ODDLY LET'S GO TO
THE PHONES WERE FIRST IS THERE
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
WHO WISHES TO. STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NON LET'S GO TO
THE PHONES. ARE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO. EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION BY GIVING US THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
INDICATION OF OPPOSITION. OF
PLEASE. FEEL FREE TO DO SO NOW
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IS AT THIS TIME.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ALREADY LINED
UP IN THE QUEUE. WE DO NOT. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GIVE IT ANOTHER FEW
SECONDS IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE SB
NINE EIGHTY BY SENATOR ON BURKE
WHICH IS OUR FILE ITEM FIVE
PLEASE. FEEL FREE TO JOIN. AND
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
THROUGH YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. MISTER MODERATOR
WOULD CHIU ANNOUNCES ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. SURE IT CAN IT'S
ONE THAT NUMBER ON YOUR
TOUCHTONE KEYPAD. IT'S ONE DASH
ONE ZERO THEN YOU HIT NOT ONE
AND THEN ZERO. YOU'RE COMING IN
A LITTLE MUDDLED MISTER OF
MODERATOR. ONE TEN ZERO. ART
HAS ANYONE- INDICATED A DESIRE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION CUED UP AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD TO WITH THAT WE WILL
BRING THE OF DISCUSSION BACK TO.
THE DYESS AND TO THOSE TO
ANYONE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MA'AM
CHAIR I JUST HAD TO CONCERNS
AND YOU CAN ADDRESSING DIRECTLY
OR IN THE CLOSING WHICHEVER- I
APOLOGIZE IF ONE OF THE- OUR
WITNESSES AXES ALSO- THAT
SHOULD THE TWO MAIN CONCERN IS
FIRST- LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS USE
THIS INFORMATION OUT. SEVERAL
TIMES RECENTLY EXPECT AND SOME
HIGH PROFILE CASES- THE GOLDEN
STATE KILLER AND SLEEPER WHICH
IS IN MY NOTES THEM- ANSWERED
HOW DOES THAT IMPACT AND THEN
THE SECOND THING THAT WHICH IS
PROBABLY. REALLY INTRIGUING TO
ME IS THAT THE- THE ACTUAL UP
PERSON DOESN'T HAVE THE RIGHT
OF ACTION IS ONLY THE-
GOVERNMENT AGENCIESOR- THEY
CAN RECOVER THE CIVIL PENALTIES
AND NOT THE INDIVIDUALS SO. NOT
SURE ABOUT THAT. ALTHOUGH
SHOULD LIKE TO RESPOND SENATOR.
A B. HAPPENED RESPONSE FIRST OF
ALL LET ME MAKE IT CLEAR THAT A
NUMBER OF COMPANIES ARE DEALING
WITH THIS ISSUE QUITE ETHICALLY
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WERE
CODIFYING SOME OF THE PRACTICES
THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
INDUSTRY OUT LIARS NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO IN TERMS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT I AGREE WITH YOU-
CENTER JONES THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION- THERE
IS A WIDE DISPARITY AS TO HOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCESS IS THESE
DATABASES RIGHT NOW EVERYTHING
FROM A COMPANY REQUIRING A
SEARCH WARRANT TO SUBPOENA TO
JUST- SHARING IT ON A SORT OF
AN AD HOC BASIS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT- WE ARE. WE'RE
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS ACCESS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN THEY ONE OF OUR
QUERY- THE DATABASE AND THEY
HAVE A SUBPOENA- THAT HAS SOME
DEFINED PARAMETERS. OF THE CAN
DO SO AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
GET THERE SO BUT IT BUT YOUR
CONCERN IS AN IMPORTANT ONE.
SECONDLY AS TO YOUR INTEREST IN
IN AMENDING THE BILL TO ADD A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION- DIED.
OF WELL I'M SORRY I MISSED. THE
WAY THE BILL'S WRITTEN- IT WELL
MAYBE SO I GUESS LIKE THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS THIS IS LOCAL
PROSECUTORS AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S. ARE THE ONLY ONES
THAT HAVE ACCESS TO BRING A
LAWSUIT SO MAYBE THAT IS WHAT
I'M ASKING NOW THAT WE- THINK
ABOUT- CAN WE MAKE A NOTE OF
THAT IS IN THE STORE FIRST TO
THAT ONE OF OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES CECILIA MORE MORE
ASKING WHY YOU DIDN'T DO THAT.
WELL THAT THAT IS BEEN A POINT
OF CONVERSATION. WEEK WE
ALTERNATELY DECIDED THAT THAT
IT WOULD IT WOULD BE BETTER TO
BE THIS IS A COMPLICATED AREA.
BETTER BE LIT LEAVING THAT TOOL
IN THE HANDS OF A DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS- WITH
THAT THERE IS NOT A- LOT OF
CRIMINAL PENALTY ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
WE'VE TAKEN TODAY IS TO
ELIMINATE THE CRIME- BUT- BOB
THAT THAT'S A POINT OF
CONVERSATION. CENTER JOHNSON.
IF YOU WANT TO CONTINUE THAT WE
WILL BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE THAT
AS WELL. I AGREE. VOTE NO TODAY
BUT HOPE THAT WE GET THOSE
ISSUES WORKED OUT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
AT THE FOR CLARIFICATION CENTER
ON BURGER YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE- COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
AUTHORS MOMENTS TODAY. FORGET
YES MANAGER THANK YOU KNOW IT'S
INTERESTING TALKING TO YOUR THE
BACK OF YOUR HEAD- BUT I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU THERE WE GO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME CONCERNS- THE CCPA. SOME
WOULD ARGUE DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH- WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE'S DNA HERE THIS IS FOR.
PERSONAL INFORMATION I'M SURE A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T EVEN
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS INFORMATION
CAN ACTUALLY. BE SOLD. OR USED
FOR MARKETING PURPOSES WHEN
PEOPLE SEEK THE INFORMATION
THEY GENERALLY AREN'T WANTING
TO SHARE WITH THE WORLD I JUST
WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT THEIR
FAMILY BACKGROUND IS- SO THE
KNOWLEDGE IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND I APPRECIATE THE-
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
WITNESSES ON THE- ON THE CALL
IN ANTICIPATE THAT THE- THERE
WILL BE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
BUT- THE PROTECTIONS THAT. THE
ARE PROVIDED BY THIS BILL I
THINK ARE ESSENTIAL TO
CONSUMERS DESERVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENIN TO THEIR INFORMATION
THEY DESERVE MORE CONTROL.
AGAIN ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD TO
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
AND UP. A WHILE I DO SHARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS AROUND THE
PRECISE LANGUAGE USED HERE. I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR AND HAVE A
LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN THIS
AUTHOR HAVING THE- APPRECIATION
FOR THIS AND THAT THAT. YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THE UP. THE
GOALS THE NOBLE GOALS OF THIS
BILL ARE A CHEAT AND SO WITH
THAT IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
BRIEFLY CLOSE. AND WILL TAKE A-
MOTION AT THAT TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR UTTERED VIRGIN IVEL
ALREADY A IS OUR MOTION A
MOTION BY SENATOR TO ROSS SO
AND THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATOR. CREATIONS
OF IF YOU WOULD ALL PUT YOUR
PHONES ON EXCUSE ME YOUR
MICROPHONES ON- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTY BY SENATOR-
BURKE JACKSON. HI X. AND I'D TO
WRESTLE BY JUST SO I GONZALEZ
HI. SALAS I JONES NO. JONES NO
MORNING NINE MONNING AYE STERN
AYE. STERN I AM BURKE I. I'M
BURKE HIGHWAY CASKEY. ONE AT
SIX TWO ONE LEGAL SIX TWO ONE
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG WILL MOVE ON TO
YOUR TO YOUR FINAL BILL WHICH
IS FILE ITEM SIX SB NINE NINE.
NINE THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS. OF SB NINE NINE NINE
ADDRESS IS AN ANOMALY IN THE
LAW- I THINK ALL OF US HERE
RECOGNIZE THAT MOBILE HOMES ARE
DIFFERENT THAN APARTMENTS IN
TERMS OF. ACTUAL MOBILITY AND
THAT ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO
RENT STABILIZATION ARE
DIFFERENT FOR MOBILE HOMES AND
THEY ARE FOR YOU KNOW THE
TRADITIONAL TENANT- THE ANOMALY
IN THE LAW IS THAT. WHEN A
LOCAL JURISDICTION PASSES A
RENT STABILIZATION ORDINANCE OR
RENT CONTROL ORDINANCE. THAT IF
A MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS- TENANT
HAS A LONG TERM LEASE THEY CAN
NOT AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
PROTECTIONS OF THAT LOCAL
ORDINANCE. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT SIMPLY RETURNS- TO LOCAL
CONTROL THE ABILITY TO ENACT
RENT STABILIZATION ORDINANCES
THAT WOULD IMPACT. OF MOBILE
HOMES AS WELL AS OTHER-
DWELLINGS. SO THE- THE
CHALLENGE WITH RESPECT TO
MOBILE HOMES. IS THAT THIS IS-
UNKNOWN TO A NUMBER OF MOBILE
HOME. RESIDENTS TENANTS THE
DATE MAY NOT KNOW. IN FACT I
WOULD ARGUE THAT MOST DO NOT
KNOW THAT IF THEY SIGN A LONG
TERM LEASE THAT THAT THEY'RE
BASICALLY PRECLUDING- THE
PROTECTIONS OF A RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE. AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS THIS THIS- REMOVES
THAT THAT EXEMPTION. ORIGINAL
VOTE THANK YOU AND SO THAT
WE'RE CLEAR IN THE DISCUSSION
ARE A YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE BE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SINCE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS IS THAT
CORRECT. YES MA'AM SURE I AM
ALSO I HAVE A MISTER JULIA ALL
OF THE CHIEF OF STAFF COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
AS A WITNESS AND- MISTER BRUCE
STAND CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED HOME
OWNERS ASSOCIATION. AS
WITNESSES. VERY GOOD AND I
BELIEVE THEY'RE BOTH ON THE
PHONE SO. THREE MINUTES TOTAL.
IF YOU LIKE TO PER TO CHECK
CORRECT MISTER MODERATOR THEY
ARE ON THE CALL. THAT IS
CORRECT ALL RIGHT OF WHICHEVER
WHATEVER HE WISHES TO START
PLEASE PROCEED TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL IDEOLOGIES OF
STAFFORD LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AND BUSINESS
AFFAIRS I'LL BE OUT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROUD BECAUSE BONTA
DIMINISH THE NINE NINE NINE.
FIRST ELECTED THANK SENATOR
UMBERG TOWARD LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW JURISDICTIONS SUCH
AS THE COUNTY OF LA TO EXPAND
LOCALLY ENACTED MOBILE HOME
RENT STABILIZATION PROJECTIONS
THE LONG TERM MOBILE HOMES
BASERUNNERS MUCH IN LINE WITH
CURRENT STATEWIDE INITIATIVES
THAT ARE AND TO KEEP THE PEOPLE
IN THEIR HOMES. ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC
MANUFACTURED A MOBILE HOMES ARE
ONE OF THE LAST BASTIONS OF NON
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE STATE. THE COLD NINETEEN
BAND THAT MAKE HAS ONLY FURTHER
EXACERBATED THE NEED FOR
LOCALITIES TO HAVE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS THAT ADDRESS. THE
NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS DURING THE ECONOMIC
REALITIES WE'RE NOT FACING
CURRENTLY STATE LAW PROHIBITS
INCORPORATED CITIES AND
COUNTIES. LONGER THAN TWELVE
MONTHS AS SUCH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE PREVENTED
EXTENDING PROTECTIONS TO MOBILE
HOMES BASERUNNERS WERE OFTEN
SUBJECT TO A VARIETY OF RENTAL
BE USES. INCLUDING REASONABLE
RENT INCREASES COERCION INTO
SIGNING EDITORIAL ON TERM
LEASES AND TENANT HARASSMENT
FOR RETAIL. AND BECAUSE MOST
MOBILE HOME CAN I USUALLY.
THEIR SEMI AFFECTS HOW. THERE
ARE THERE ARE LEFT TO FEW
OPTIONS ONE CAN WITH EXORBITANT
INCREASE. ALL RIGHT OKAY. OR
UNDER LEASE TERM. FIRST OF THIS
YEAR THE COUNTY WILL ALSO AN
ACCIDENT SO RENT. OR TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS. EXCESSIVE RUNNING.
EVICTIONS WITHOUT JUST CAUSE
AND EFFECT DOES. THE MOBILE
SPACE. HOWEVER THIS IT'S ALL
COVER THE SO 60% OF ALL MOBILE
SPACES IN THE COUNTY SERVICE
AREA. RIGHT LONG TERM LEASE
EXEMPTION. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW OKAY TO EXTEND THESE
COULD TO ALL NEW TERM SPACE
RUNNERS AND SUBSEQUENTLY ALL
ALONG EXISTING LONG TERM SPACE
RUNNERS AT JANUARY. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. YEAH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THIS EXEMPTION
ENACTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. WAS PURPOSE TO ALLOW OR
ENABLE MANAGEMENT HOMEOWNERS TO
CONTRACT FOR THE- HOW TO
OTHERWISE AVOID THE MINISTRY TO
PROCESS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT
WHILE THOUGH IS DEFINED AND
CONCEPT JUST HAS WORKED. AN
INSTRUMENT WILL COLD IT'S BEEN
A- LONG TERM LEASES ARE. BOB IN
NC TO FIVE. THEY HAVE A LOT OF
ONE SIDELAND. UP CENTRIC IN
THEM. AND WE JUST A NUMBER
SCHOOL TO DO SIGNATURE OF LONG
BEACH INCLUDE. FICTION THAT
LAST ONE IS SIDE WITH A PART
IT'S CHANNELS. WITH A LARGER
POP. WERE ONE DOOR TO DOOR TO
THANKS SIGNATURE. IN CREEK IN
DECIDING THEY THOUGHT WERE SO
CAL. BEING DENIED THERE SO TWO
HOUR REACHED. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T GET A COPY OF THE LEASE
ALLOWED SEPT TWO HOURS. OR CAN
GET LEADING INCREASE AFTER
LEASE AND DID NOT HOME. AS
HAPPENING WILL CARP. ANEROID
GRANT. ANY OTHER WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEEING NO ONE HERE AND
IN SUPPORT I TO ME THE
OPPOSITION WE SEEN YOU BEFORE
SO I MADE THAT CONNECTION. ALL
RIGHT AND THE AT THIS POINT-
LET'S GO TO THE PHONES IF THERE
ARE ANY PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF FILE ITEM
SIX. SB NINE NINETY NINE.
PLEASE QUEUE UP AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE MODERATOR AND
LET ME REITERATE TO PLEASE TAKE
YOUR PHONES OFF OF MUTE. IT
WILL TAKE CARE OF THE REST OF
IT THROUGH THE- SYSTEM THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO US OFF OF MUTE
NOW. AND MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD TAKE OVER AND DIRECT
PEOPLE HOW TO LINE UP IN THE
QUEUE. YES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK OUT IN SUPPORT YOU MAY DO
SO BY PRESSING ONE THEN THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME THAT'S ONE
THEN ZERO. MISTER MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE LINED UP AT THIS
POINT. WE DO NOT LET'S WAIT IF
HE SECONDS AGAIN PEOPLE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
FILE ITEM SIX SB NINE NINE NINE
BY SENATOR UMBERG. MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. LEAD LET US MOVE THEN TO
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I
WILL GIVE YOU EQUAL TIME AND
THAT IS THREE MINUTES AND FORTY
SECONDS TOTAL SO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO START GIVE US YOUR-
NAME AFFILIATION AND PROCEED
WITH THAT. AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MADAM TEACH ME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHASE AND I
CAN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
ALLIANCE- IT IS IT IS TRUE THAT
CIVIL CODE SECTION SEVEN NINE
EIGHT POINT ONE SEVEN ALLOWS A
PARK OWNER IN A RESIDENT TO
ENTER INTO A LEASE AGREEMENT
THAT IS A LONG TERM ISN'T
SUBJECT TO RENT CONTROL- WHAT
HASN'T BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL THERE
AND NUMBER PROTECTIONS IN THAT
LAW- THAT RESIDENTS ARE
ENTITLED TO BEFORE THE PARK
OWNER. CAN ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT THAT IS AND SUBJECT
TO RENT CONTROL IT WAS STATED
EARLIER THAT RESIDENTS MAY NOT
KNOW THAT THEY ARE ENTERING
INTO AN AGREEMENT THAT IS AND
SUBJECT TO RENT CONTROL BUT ONE
OF THE PROTECTIONS IS THAT THE
FIRST SENTENCE OF THE FIRST
PARAGRAPH OF THE LEAST AND
TWELVE POINT BOLDFACE FONTS
HOUSE TO STATE THE POLICE IS
NOT SUBJECT TO A LOCAL RENT
CONTROL MARTIN. IT'S IT HAS TO
BE GIVEN THIRTY DAYS TO REVIEW.
AND RIPPED. REJECT THE
AGREEMENT- THEY HAVE TO BE
GIVEN THREE DAYS TO AVOID THAT
AGREEMENT ONCE SIGNED. AND IF
THEY CHOOSE TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHT TO REVIEW OR- A BOY THAT
AGREEMENT- THEY THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO A SHORT TERM LEASE
UNDER. ESSENTIALLY THE SAME
TERMS AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
RATES AND CHARGES- AS AS LISA
THEY IN GOSHEN THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN LONG TERM. AND FINALLY-
THE ANALYSIS. IT NOTES I EVEN
THOUGH IT DOESN'T DISCUSS THE
FIRST SENTENCE REQUIREMENTS-
THE ANALYSIS DOES KNOW THAT
THERE'S A DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
LANDLORD POTENTIALLY IN A
RESIDENT BECAUSE A LANDLORD
ENTERS INTO MULTIPLE- LEAST AGO
SHE SINCE A YEAR. AND HAS MORE
FAMILIARITY WITH THE LAW. BUT
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER PROTECTION
THAT ADDRESSES ARE MITIGATES
THAT CONCERNED BY REQUIRING
THAT A PARK OWNER PROVIDE
SEPARATELY IN WRITING
NOTIFICATION. THAT THE RESIDENT
HAS A RIGHT TO REJECT THE
AGREEMENT. AND HAS A RIGHT TO
AVOID IT AFTER THREE DAYS AFTER
SIGNED YET. SO FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF OUR CLIENT WE
BELIEVE THAT. THE PART. THE LAW
A LOT. A LANDLORD IN A-
PRESIDENT NEGOTIATE IN GOOD
FAITH WITH ONE ANOTHER. AND
SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT FOR THAT
MAKE YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
YOU'VE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE AND
FORTY SECONDS. THANK YOU. UNDER
GOVERNOR ON. OF WMA AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
CENTER ON BURKE- A COUPLE OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE BROUGHT UP
IN THE ANALYSIS FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ARGUMENT OF CONTRACT
IMPAIRMENT. AND HOW DOES THIS
BILL. LEASES PLACE. PART WE
HAVE FIVE AND TEN YEAR LEASES.
SO SOMEBODY ENTERED INTO A
LEASE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
LAST- TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. HOW
DOES THIS BILL AFFECTED- ARE WE
GOING TO BE IN COURT LITIGATING
THIS SO OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WE WOULD SEE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOMETHING GOING FOR YOU CAN
IMPAIR EXISTING CONTRACTS IN
FOR DISCLOSURE BY THE WAY. WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING TO CENTER ON
BURKE. AND HE DID TASK US WITH
GOING BACK TO OUR BOARD OUR
MEMBERS WITH FOR DOING WE
DIDN'T HAVE. TIME TO DO IT FOR
THIS COMMITTEE BUT HE HAS
TASKED US AND. HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH US TO SEE IF WE
CAN FOR FIND A RESOLUTION. THAT
I OF US MAY BUT WE MIGHT. THE
PROBLEM LONG TERM CONTRACTS AS-
RIGHT NOW. IN MY RECKONED
JURORS. ARE LONG TERM LEASES
ARE BELOW RENT CONTROL WHICH
MEANS IN LOS ANGELES IF IT'S A
4% WE MIGHT HAVE A LEASE THAT
SAYS YOU GET A 2% A YEAR
INCREASE. WHY WOULD WE DO THAT
BELOW RENT CONTROL. BECAUSE WE
MAY SAY ON CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO TO THE RENT
CONTROL BOARD TO MAKE A CASE TO
GET A CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT. SO
WE MADE A GOOD SHAPE AT LEAST
THE CURRENT RESIDENT GETS LAST
RENT. FOR THE ENTIRE TERM OF
THE LEASE. BUT IN EXCHANGE
MAYBE WE GET TO CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS. IN PLACES THAT
DON'T HAVE VACANCY DE CONTROL
WHICH MEANS YOU CAN FLIP THE
RENT ON TURN OVER. WE MIGHT
OFFER. NO RATE INCREASES FOR
SEVERAL YEARS BUT WE MAY SAY
WHEN YOU LEAVE. WE WILL DO AN
ADJUSTMENT ON TURNOVER FRIEND
SINCE THE CITY OF VISTA CAME UP
WITH A MODEL LEASE. THE
TURNOVER RATE WAS SIXTY SEVEN
DOLLARS PHASED IN OVER TWO
YEARS. BUT THE CURRENT
RESIDENTS HAD LAST BEEN RENT
CONTROL RATES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. APPRECIATE IT. ALL
RIGHT ARM. WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE- BY FEARS THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME WHO WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SO MISTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU REITERATE-
THERE WE WILL TAKE WITNESSES
WHO. MAY HAVE WANTED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PREVIOUSLY IF THEY
WOULD- LINE UP. AND I GUESS
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE SYSTEM.
WE DON'T WANT ANYONE WHO'S-
LINED UP IN OPPOSITION TO GET
OFF THE PHONE. WATER WHICH IS
GO AHEAD TAKE PEOPLE AS YOU SEE
THEM. LINED UP AND AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD ANNOUNCED THE METHOD BY
WHICH PEOPLE SHOULD. A CALL IN
IN ORDER TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE FOR THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND INDICATE
WHETHER THEY ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I WILL CERTAINLY DO
SO BUT APART AS APPARENTLY MY
SCREEN FROZE I DID NOT SEE THEM
BUT THEY ARE DEEP THERE AND WE
WILL HEAR FROM THEM. WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THAT IS TWO SIX ZERO.
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
JACKSON MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THAT IS ONE THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS DIEGO
TO BULK UP I'LL BUT AS I AM IN
SUPPORT I WAS IN SUPPORT ON
BEFORE YOU. TECHNICAL ISSUES I
DON'T LIVE IN A MOBILE HOME BUT
I DO LIVE WITH MY MOM SO I
INTRODUCED AND AFFORDABILITY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR X. WITNESS PLEASE. YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO THAT TWO SEVEN TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON OUR DEMO QUESTIONS ON
ON LAW AND POVERTY COMING UP
WITH YOUR LA FOUNDATION AGAIN
APART. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE YOUR VOICE
HEARD IN A PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES ONLINE EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. NO
OTHERS ARE KILLING UP AT THIS
TIME LET'S GIVE IT TEN SECONDS
AND IF YOU COULD INDICATE IF
YOU'RE A DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA IF YOU'RE- A SCREEN
FREEZES OR IT'S JUST THE GAS
MINISTER SOME INDICATION YOU
GET THAT. THERE IS NO RECEPTION
OCCURRING NO. THREE RESPONSE
REACTION. I DO HAVE A HELPER
THAT IT COULD BE A PRICE THAT
THE EXTREME THE SAME THING THAT
I AM AN ENTERTAINING NOT IN Q.
AT THIS TIME. ALREADY TEN
SECONDS AND THEN WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DYESS ANY
QUESTIONS. MISTER MODERATOR. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT. GOOD LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS FOR
ANY DISCUSSION DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE HI JUST WANNA THANK YOU
SENATOR- ON BURKE FOR BRINGING
THE BILL AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THIS IS A GOOD
CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURE WAS
MENTIONED THAT- IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY. THEY HAVE HAD REAL
PROBLEMS WITH THIS- AT THIS
POINT IN TIME RENT CONTROL
MAKES- PARTICULAR SENSE IN THE
MOBILE HOME CONTEXT WHATEVER
ITS MERITS ARE AND OTHERS- YOU
KNOW RESIDENTS AGAIN JUST CAN'T
PICK UP AND LEAVE. AND I THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO KEEP IN MIND- AS WE GO
FORWARD- IN AGAIN THIS BILL
THOUGH DOESN'T TO IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL. ON THE PARK OWNERS
SHOULD JUST SHIPS THE VENUE WAS
I UNDERSTAND A FOR THE
CONVERSATION. FROM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO YOUR LOCAL
JURISDICTION. WERE ARGUABLY
PEOPLE KNOW BASTIN SENATOR. A
NUMBER GIVE YOU MY CHEST
COMMENT ON THAT AS YOU MAKE
YOUR CLOTHES- THE CLERK THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THANK YOU
MANAGER LET ME JUST THE ADOPT
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU OF.
COUPLE THINGS ONE YOU'RE RIGHT
IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE OF LONG
TERM LEASES NUMBER TWO IT
DOESN'T IMPOSE RENT CONTROL.
NUMBER THREE IN TERMS OF. THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS BEING
APPRISED OF THE SITUATION THEY
SIGNED A TEN YEAR LEASE AND
FIVE YEARS INTO THAT LEASE-
THERE'S A RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE THEY MAY NOT HAVE
ANTICIPATED FIVE YEARS BEFORE
THAT THERE WOULD BE RENT
CONTROL. ORDINANCE IN PLACE AND
WHAT THAT DOES ISA CRAZY
ANOMALOUS SITUATION WHERE
YOU'VE GOT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
SURROUNDED BY OTHER HOUSING
WHICH IS ALL RENT STABILIZED
EXCEPT FOR THE AREA WHERE YOU
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE THE SENIOR
PARK FIFTY FIVE IT OVER. SENIOR
PARK WHICH IS NOT SUBJECT IS
NOT PROTECTED BY RENT
STABILIZATION- I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH WITH THOSE WHO
OPPOSED. IN THE HIGHER DRIVABLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
A MOTION IS THERE A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WITH THAT PLEASE PUT YOUR
MICROPHONES ON MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL. ONE
SB NINE NINETY NINE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. YES JACKSON BY EX
IN AYE A DRESS SO I. THOUGHT I
A GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I JONES
NO. JON SNOW MONNING AYE.
MONNING AYE A STERN BY. STERN I
AM BURKE HI. I'M BURKE I Y.
CASKEY. SIX TO ONE I BELIEVE
SIX AND ALL RIGHT WE WILL-
LEAVE THE ROLL OVER OPEN FOR
OUR ACTION MEMBER WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG LAST BILL IS- SENATOR
DHIRAJ SHOWS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
SB. ELEVEN NINETY. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MA'AM THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON- AND
EVERYBODY. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE- BUT SENSE
NETIQUETTE. IT'S GOOD TO TALK
TO EACH OTHER. NEVER GET TO SEE
ANYBODY OKAY FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR- AND
JUST EXCELLENT- WORK ON THE NOW
THIS IS OF THIS BILL AND- I
WANT TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AS DETAILED ON PAGES ELEVEN TO
FOURTEEN OF THE COMMITTEE
AALYSIS. GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS CAUSED BY KOBE
NINETEEN CRISIS THE STATE
REALLY SHOULD FOCUS ON KEEPING
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR HOMES ONE
OF THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
NEEDS WE HAVE IS TO LIVE IN A
SAFE AND SECURE HOME. I AM
PROPOSING PROTECTIONS FOR
TENANTS EXPERIENCING THE MOST
VULNERABLE CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH
AS VICTIMIZATION. AFTER A
VIOLENT CRIME VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILY HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS MAY
NEED TO RELOCATE QUICKLY.
STAYING IN THE VICTIM'S HOME
MAY INCREASE THE RISK OF
DEVELOPING POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER AND EXPOSE VICTIMS TO
EVEN FURTHER VIOLENCE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW
ENSURES THAT VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT STALKING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND ABUSE OF AN
ELDER FOR DEPENDENT ADULT. AND
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO LIVE IN
THEIR HOUSEHOLD CAN TERMINATE
THE LEASE WITHOUT PENALTY
FOLLOWING THE VICTIMIZATION
HOWEVER. VICTIMS OF OTHER
VIOLENT CRIMES FOR EXAMPLE COOL
VICTIMS OF HOMICIDE SURVIVORS
OF GUN VIOLENCE AND SURVIVORS
OF ROBBERY. AND THEIR FAMILY
AND HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS DO NOT
HAVE THE SAME RELOCATION
OPPORTUNITIES THESE VICTIMS OF
OTHER VIOLENT CRIMES SHOULD NOT
BE FORCED TO BREAK THEIR LEASE
FOR THE SAKE OF THEIR SAFETY
THEY SHOULD JUST HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RE LOCATE.
BREAKING THE LEASE COULD LEAVE
TENANTS RESPONSIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL PENALTIES MARK THE
TENANTS CREDIT SCORE AND LEAD
TO FUTURE LANDLORDS
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST THE
TENANTS SB ELEVEN NINETY WOULD
ALLOW VICTIMS AND FAMILY
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS TO RELOCATE
WITHIN A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS FOLLOWING THE CRIME. IN
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL I
AM PROPOSING LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
OF EXISTING TENANT PROTECTIONS
LAST YEAR FOURTEEN EIGHT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WAS PASSED
AND SIGNED INTO LAW. IT
CODIFIED JUST BECAUSE
PROVISIONS AND RENT CAPS RATE
CAPS RENT CAPS HOWEVER AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HAS VERY
LIMITED ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
TENANTS MUST TAKE THEIR CASES
TO THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THERE HAS BEEN
LITTLE GUIDANCE ON THIS
PROCESS. SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
WOULD ALLOW ENFORCEMENT BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THIS MEANS
THAT A CITY ATTORNEY INCLUDING
THE CITY ATTORNEY OF A CITY AND
COUNTY A DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR
ANY COUNTY COUNCIL CAN ENFORCE
THOSE PROVISIONS. AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IS THE LAW AT THIS
TIME WE NEED TO MAKE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ACCESSIBLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS FOR THESE
REASONS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING SB ELEVEN
NINETY BEFORE YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY WITNESS TODAY WILL
BE TO CHANTE MCCOY FROM GROUP
CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE TO CHANTE WILL SPEAK
FOR THE ENTIRE THREE MINUTES. I
WILL ALSO HAVE AVAILABLE ANDREA
GENTIL FROM CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND BRIAN
AUGUSTA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ROUTE RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION WHO WILL HELP ANSWER
ALL YOUR QUESTIONS ASSUMING YOU
HAVE SOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND DO WE HAVE TO SHANTOU
MACQUARIE ON THE LINE. ALL
RIGHT MISSOURI MACQUARIE. OF
YOU HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES
YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE IT ALL
BUT IT'S YOURS IF YOU DO AND
YOU ARE READY TO GO. HI THERE
THANK YOU FOR MY MONEY MARKET
FUNDS AND LOCAL AND I AM A
MOTHER LET'S GET BACK. I'M NOT
THE BY THE OF A GUNSHOT WOUND
TO THE LAKE AND I LOST MY
BUTTON CLICK THE BOMB. EITHER
ONE OF MY NEEDS ARE COVERED
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW. I AM
PROUD AND BLESSED TO BE A
REGIONAL MANAGER FOR CRIME BY
THE- DEFICIT. WE ARE A NATIONAL
NETWORK OF CRIME WITH MORE THAN
FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
NATIONWIDE WE HAVE A VERY
MEMBERSHIP OF MORE THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND EVEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOW. ORGANIZED BUT
I'VE LEARNED FROM THE MOST
IMPACTED BY CRIME AND VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THE VOICE IS AN
EXPERIENCE ARE OFTEN LOOKING
AND PUBLIC SAFETY. AND THE-
QUESTION. MY WELL I THINK WHAT
I OF CALIFORNIA THE BIBLE STATE
THE THEY NEED AND OF COURSE
AFTER A CAR. HOW YOU THE BILL
OF THE EIGHT HARD. BUT MANY
PROVIDE ARE ONE DAY AND-
BECAUSE OF THE VEHICLE. BUT
IT'S NOT A TECH BY CURRENT LAW.
I THE UNIQUE UP. TO BE A PART
OF THE IN OF THE PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. AND MY WELL AS MANAGER
HEARD WITH AND- CRIED AT NIGHT
IS WHEN MY AND BY WHO DESIRED
TO MOVE THEIR- AFTER IN EIGHTY.
BUT WERE ABLE TO BE BECAUSE OF
WHEN THE- THAT RESTRICT. BUT
THAT IN FACT BECAUSE OF HAPPENS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE AND ABLE TO
BE. I AM VIVIDLY MUSKRAT IN
WILL HAVE A LITTLE BAG A LAND.
AT A DECLINE TO KNOW ABOUT WHY
NOT TAKE A ONE HOUR OF THE. AB
BEING SHOT AT THE BYE BYE AND
THEN TRYING BECAUSE THEY THEM
TO LET BREAK THE HELLO. ANOTHER
ACROSS TOWN BECAUSE THEY TREAT
YEAH HE ACTUALLY. THINKING
ALONG HER BECAUSE- THE YOUNG
LADY AND HER CLOTHES ON WHAT
FOR A DAY IN AND ENVIRONMENT
CAN IDENTIFY THIS AS THE BIBLE
MONTH ABOUT I REMEMBER ALL THE
WAY AND BY YOUR FELT BEING.
AREA DAILY A MONTH BUT PACK
AWAY A CLASSICALLY I REMEMBER
LITERALLY THAT NUMBER IS MYSELF
EVERY TIME THE CAR BY. DOES
ROAD COLLECTED UNITS ARE WHAT
LEAD HE- ATTY BY THE NOT BE
BACK IF YOU ARE HE BUT WHAT THE
BIBLE BUT THEY ME BACK. I YOU
KNOW COLD AT NIGHT ALREADY HAS
THE- ACT I'M CURRENTLY THEN I'M
GONNA BOOK COME. I'LL BE AN
EMPLOYMENT THE BILL HE ARE
TAUGHT CONCERN ALL CAUGHT.
SHOULD NOT HAPPEN TO BETWEEN
AND HAVE A CURRENT LAW CRITICS
RIGHT. RIGHT THE VICTIM
EXPERIENCES BUT CRIME ABOUT.
AND THEIR FAMILIES NEED AND THE
OUT CRITICS YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MUCH.
AT THIS TIME A- WILL TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO. OF NAME AND A- AND
THE I CAN IN THERE SOME FOR
THEM. SING KNOWN IN ROOM FORTY
OH THREE MISTER MODERATOR WOULD
YOU GO TO THE PHONES AND INVITE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO GIVE THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT
OF FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB ELEVEN
NINETY TO PLEASE QUEUE UP. YES
IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINES
AND HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO IN
WHICH TO MAKE YOUR SUPPORT
KNOWN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DID HAVE SEVERAL
LET ALREADY PRE QUEUED WILL GO
TO THEM NOW. WE'LL START WITH
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO TWO SEVEN TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR HARMON ON BEHALF OF THE
WEAPONS ON A LAN PARTY AND
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND-
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. X. WITNESSES LINE
TWENTY THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND SENATORS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MARCH YOU KNOW WITH
CALIFORNIANS ARE SEEKING
JUSTICE PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR. TEXAS LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN EIGHT TWO
SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BACK IN DOLLARS NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX TO SEVEN SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SHERRY
TO MINGLE WITH SO CON BALLY
DEBUG AND WENT TO PART OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND SIX NINETY NINE
TWO SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE TRACKING NINE WE ARE
PLEASED. GO AHEAD. SH TO MEET
HOLLAND AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR CURRENT OF OURS
FOR SEEKING JUSTICE I AM
STRONG. ELEVEN NINETY. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. FIND TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
LOOKING AT IT OR NOT I'M
EXECUTOR NUMBER TENANTS
TOGETHER CALIFORNIANS IT WHAT
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
CREATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SPELL- TO BE ABLE
TO FEEL STREET THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
LIMITATION EDWARD PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR UNITED COMMUNITIES
FOR PEACE AND A CRIME PROVIDE
FOR ALSO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM. TO A LINE
TO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR TWO
SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS EMAIL CALL MAJOR AND I
AM A CRIME SURVIVOR AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL STRONGLY.
THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LIKE TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE. SIX FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH WALKER OF ANYA AND I
AM A CRIME SURVIVOR WILL MAKE
THEIR CRIME DRIVERS MY SON WAS
MURDERED AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SPELL. THANK YOU MA'AM.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
TWO SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS DAVID YOU THOUGHT
ALL CRIME SURVIVOR. ALL OF.
SURVIVOR MY BROTHER ACOSTA
BROTHER GILBERT STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN NINETY THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR NEXT NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
GINA RODRIGUEZ AND I'M
REPRESENTING SURVIVORS AND I
THAT IN BOTH SUPPORT AS A
SURVIVOR MYSELF AND FOR OTHER
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN IN THIS
POSITION AND SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
BE FORCED THANK YOU MA'AM
FIGURATIONS WHERE THE THREAT TO
THEIR LIKE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. BEST LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TO TWO A TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS SELLING A DELIVERY NO I HATE
IT. BUT I AM A CRIME SURVIVOR
OF WORRY MY BROTHER WAS BY THE
ONLY GUN DOWN AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL SB ELEVEN NINETY. CALL ARE
ONLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
TWO EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS LISA MARIANO I
AM A SURVIVOR AND A SOCIAL
WORKER AND I. STRONGLY AND
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN NINETY THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AND AS
A REMINDER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT YOU CAN QUEUE UP
BY PRESSING ONE AND THEN ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE TWO SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS. MARSHALL I AM WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. Q. MISTER
MODERATOR HOW MANY MORE DO WE
HAVE LINED UP IN SUPPORT. BUT
AFTER I JUST READ WE HAVE THREE
MORE THANK YOU. NEXT ONE PLEASE
LINE TWO HUNDRED IN CHURCH LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE TWO
EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TO EIGHTY ONE CHECK IN
LINE FOR MEAT. I I'VE ALREADY
SPOKEN. NINE TO EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU OVERLY SET LINE WILL
GO TO THE NEXT ONE WHICH IS TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE ONE TWO
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY MY NAME IS JAMIE GUERRERO
THE REGULAR DIRECTOR KELLY
VANDALS FOUNDATION A LOS MY
SISTER'S INCLUDING THE MASTIC
VIOLENT. THEN I AM STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS CLEAR LIGHT. BY
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
TWO SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MERCEDES
PART I'M A SURVIVOR AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT. HE ELEVEN
NINETY THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. COMETO THE END OF THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
LET'S GIVE PEOPLE A ONE MORE
CHANCE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WITH
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BE ELEVEN
NINETY PLEASE SIR QUEUE UP.
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE ONE LAST CALL. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE YOUR
VOICE HEARD YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT TO HAVE ANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINES. WE DO
NOT VERY GOOD WE WILL THEN GO
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
FLORA I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS CONFIRMED- DEBORAH
CARLTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
PATRICK MORAN FROM THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ASSOCIATION
ON THE LINE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT
MISTER MODERATOR. WE DO HAVE
MISTER MORAN I'M SO SORRY I DID
NOT HEAR THE OTHER NAME THAT
YOU SET DEBORAH CARLTON. I DO
NOT SHOW HER ON THE LINE AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WILL WE DO HAVE
MISTER MORAN WHO WAS INDICATED
PREVIOUSLY OF HIS INTENT TO
SPEAK FROM THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
MISTER MORAN WE WILL GIVE YOU
UP TO THREE MINUTES IF YOU SO
CHOOSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
IT BUT- THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CATAMARAN
WITH AARON READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION- WERE OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN NINETY. SB ELEVEN NINETY
WILL PROVIDE A NEW EXPENSIVE
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF THAT AND IT'S
PROTECTION ACT THAT WOULD YOU
LAST YEAR'S AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN
THE CREATION OF AN EXPENSIVE
STATE REGULATORY PROCESS THE
GOVERNOR RENT INCREASES AND
JUST BECAUSE THE PICTURE
NOTICES. LIKE LOCAL JUST
BECAUSE MEASURES JUST
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE KIND OF
PROTECTION THAT ARE NOW IN
FORCE THANK YOU YOU SHOULD BE
THROUGH THE UNLAWFUL DETAINER
PROCESS A PROCESS THAT IS FULLY
OCCUPIED BY STATE LAW. THE BILL
WOULD IN BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TRADICIONAL EXPENSIVE
PROCEDURAL HURDLES THEREBY
NULLIFYING THE INTENDED SUMMARY
NATURE OF THE LONGSTANDING
UNLAWFUL DETAINER REMEDY. AS WE
STRUGGLE TO ENCOURAGE MORE
INVESTMENT IN HOUSING SB ELEVEN
NINETY WOULD CREATE ANOTHER
HUGE DISINCENTIVE FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING. IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION BY
GIVING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR. I'M MORE LIKE TO
BELIEVE THAT THE OTHER
INDIVIDUAL IS HERE THEY WERE IN
ON ON LINE BUT THERE LINE IT
SHOULD. THE CARD FOR GOOD WILL
GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- I BELIEVE FOR. TO
DEBORAH CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATIONS ARE CORRECT AND IF
SO PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
YES MADAM CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR
ME INDEED I CAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DEMóCRATAS THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION PERSONALLY STATE WE
ARE FINE WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL THAT DEAL WITH VICTIMS
OF CRIME THAT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO OUR OBJECTION
SURROUNDED THE CHANGES TO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THAT WAS
THE SUBJECT OF INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS LAST YEAR THE
PARTIES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WHO WORKED ON THIS
MEASURE IN GOOD FAITH AGREED
THAT THE ACT WOULD BE ENFORCED
THROUGH EXISTING PROCEDURES.
THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED THAT
THIS LOG IS THE STRONGEST
RENTER PROTECTIONS IN THE
NATION SOME OF YOU WERE EVEN CO
AUTHORS INCLUDING SENATOR
DORADO TO NOW GO BACK ON THE
PROMISES MADE. AND TO MOVE THIS
BILL WOULD BE WRONG. THIS BILL
WE BELIEVE AS A VEILED ATTEMPT
TO CREATE A REVENUE STREAM FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCORDING TO
THE LANGUAGE OF THE PROPOSAL A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. COULD FIND
SMALL AND LARGE OWNERS TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH AND
EVERY BY ELATION OF THE ACT
INCLUDING TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS.
THIS IS QUITE FRANKLY
OUTRAGEOUS THE BILL IS
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S TIME DURING A
CRISIS CREATED BY THE CODED
PANDEMIC. THE LEGISLATURE MUST
SPEND ITS TIME FOCUSING ON
EQUIPPING FRONT LINE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. RESTORING THE
ECONOMY AND HELPING
CALIFORNIANS BOTH OWNERS AND
TENANTS WITH THE DEBT DEBT THAT
THEY HAVE ACCUMULATED DURING
THIS CRISIS. NOT ON ARMING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH A CARTE
BLANCHE TO ENFORCE STATE LAW
AND UNDERMINING THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER PROCESS THAT WE WORKED
SO HARD ON LAST YEAR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT NOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONES FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO STATE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE SB ELEVEN NINETY.
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE TAKE IT FROM HERE. TO
SPEAK OUT IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IT IS ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT OF A FEW THAT
ALREADY CUED UP WE WILL GO TO
THOSE LINES LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN TWO
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACKSON NUMBERS
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. HELLO LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
THAT'S TWO EIGHT FOR YOUR LOCK
NINE IS OPEN. I'M SURE MEMBERS
STEVE CARLSON FOR THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES FOR THE REASONS STATED
BY MY COLLEAGUES. WE ARE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SIR. ONCE AGAIN ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
VOICE OPPOSITION YOU MAY DO SO
BY PRESSING ONE AND THEN IS
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE.
YES DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHERS ON
THE LINE. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. SOUNDS GOOD BY THIS IS RUN
KINGS AND I REPRESENT THREE
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS
ONE IN THE BAY AREA- EAST BAY
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S SOUTHERN CITIES
AND THE APARTMENT FACIAL. OF
ORANGE COUNTY WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE WE ARE
OPPOSED THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS. ONCE AGAIN PROPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION RIGHT LET'S WAIT
ANOTHER TEN SECONDS AND THEN WE
WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE DYESS. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PEOPLE QUEUED UP TO
EXPRESS THEIR- POSITION ON THIS
MEASURE MISTER MODERATOR. THERE
ARE NO MORE AT THIS TIME RIGHT
LET'S BRING THIS BACK TO THE-
DíAS- WANNA THANK BOTH
SOLUTIONS SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
THE WITNESSES FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY. SENATOR DORADO ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU
FROM ANY MEMBERS CENTER ON
BURKE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A
SENATOR RUSSELL. IF YOU COULD
CLARIFY SOMETHING A TEN IN THE
CAN- AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
PROTECTIONS OF THIS ACT OF WITH
A SOME SORT OF ATTESTATION I
SEE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN'T
ATTENDANCE OF. WILL SO THE
PROTECTIONS WITH JUST SIMPLY A
STATEMENT OF THE TENANTS OR
DOES IT REQUIRES SOME OTHER
VERIFICATION. A YES IT IT CAN
BE THEIR OWN STATEMENT BUT LET
ME DOUBLE CHECK OUT WITH- COULD
HAVE ANDREA. VERIFY THAT FOR ME.
THIS IS ANDREA ON THE PHONE IS
ANDREW STILL ON THE PHONE.
SHE'S NOT SHE'S. HELLO OKAY
WELL THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT YES THEY CAN. THANK YOU
I'M ATTEMPTING TO RECALL I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME- OF
THE SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
WITHIN THAT PROVISION THAT WE
DID TRY TO TIGHTEN UP. DURING
THE DISCUSSION AND THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THE AMENDMENTS WHICH
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE. TAKEN YES
I'M SORRY I CAN'T RECALL IT
RIGHT AT THE MOMENT. BUT I KNOW
THAT THAT WAS PART OF OUR
DISCUSSION. PERHAPS A. I DID
YEAH OKAY SO I BELIEVE THE DAD
THAT PROFICIENT WE STRENGTHEN
THE OTHER ASPECTS OF THAT THE
ATTESTATION IF YOU WILL HAVE TO
BE FROM ANOTHER PARTY- AND THAT
IT WAS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
SERVING AS THE TESTATOR IS
THERE SUCH A TESTATOR AT ANY
RATE THAT THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
SEEKING THE ABILITY TO WITHDRAW
FROM THE TENDENCY IT CANNOT DO
SO INDEPENDENTLY WITHOUT OTHER
CORROBORATION. I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHERE WE LEFT IT AND WE ALSO
DID TIGHTEN UP SOME OF THOSE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
STATEMENTS WOULD BE ACCEPTED AS
THE SIGNET A SUFFICIENT. SO I
DON'T HAVE A THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. YES THANK YOU ARE A
VICTIM OF VIOLENT CRIME YES A
VICTIM OF VIOLENT CRIME
ADVOCATE AND AN ADVOCATE TO
HAS- IS PART OF THE- OF. COURSE
WHICH IS THE OR A- AN ENTITY
THAT IT THAT IS KNOWN TO BE A
VALID AND TODAY IT'S YOU JUST
CAN'T PUT YOUR NAME NEXT
SOMETHING HAS TO BE AN EXISTING
LEGITIMATE ACCEPTED.
ORGANIZATION RECOGNIZED YES.
YES SENATOR OR DID YOU ASK HIM
ANYTHING ELSE CENTER ON BURKE
NO OKAY CENTER START OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I JUST HOPE
I'M TRYING TO GET CLARITY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT.
UNDERSTANDING THIS MORE
THOROUGHLY IN ADVANCE BUT- THE
FIRST SECTION OF THE BILL IS
ABOUT. THIS OTHER CLASS OF
THIRD OF AFFILIATED THAT FAMILY
MEMBER TO TENNIS BUT THE BUT
THE AUTHORIZATION FOR
ENFORCEMENT IS APPLIES ACROSS
THE BOARD REPLY OKAY SUIT CAN
YOU JUST COMMENT ON THE HISTORY
THE PROVISION FROM LAST YEAR
AND THAT. THE NOTION THAT WE
SORT OF WE WORKED ON ALL THESE
DETAILS OF ENFORCEMENT ALREADY
AND WHAT WHAT YOU FEEL IS
REALLY LACKING IN THE CURRENT
ENFORCEMENT FRAMEWORK THAT
JUSTIFIES THIS EXPANSION WELL I
WASN'T YOU KNOW IN THE
BACKGROUND OF PUTTING THAT BILL
TOGETHER BUT I CERTAINLY
SUPPORTED IT BECAUSE- BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
PROTECTION WITH JUST BECAUSE WE
HAD DISCUSSED IT AND I HAD A- A
BILL MYSELF- WHAT WE FOUND AND
WHAT WE'VE- HEARD BACK IS. THAT
THE IDEA OF HAVING TO GO TO THE
TURN ATTORNEY GENERAL MADE IT
MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR A
TENANT- TO BE ABLE TO ASSERT
THIS NEW THESE NEW RIGHTS OF
THESE NEW PROTECTIONS AND SO
DOING THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
FACILITATED THAT- AND WAS JUST.
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT THING GOING TO THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
THE JUST TO CLARIFY IS IT
PURELY. IT'S PURELY
ADMINISTRATIVE OR HAVE THE
ACTUAL FINES AND PENALTIES
CHANGE THEMSELVES AND MORE THE
VAN YOU THINK THAT. THAT THE
CITY ATTORNEY. OR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR COUNTY COUNCIL CAN
DO THIS ENFORCEMENT OR DO WE
ACTUALLY CHANGE THE. THE LEVEL
OF FINES OR PENALTIES. EIGHTY
TWO FRAMEWORK BY THE WAY SIR I
SHOULD I SHOULD BE ABLE TO. IS
BRIAN AUGUSTA STILL ON THE LINE.
I AM OKAY BRIAN BARGER. YES
PLEASE YOU COULD YOU ANSWER THE
LAST QUESTION THE ANSWER. YES
THE ANSWER THE CENTERS QUESTION
IS THAT IT DOES ADD A NEW
PROVISION THAT WHAT AUTHORIZED.
ADDITIONAL PROSECUTION OR LEVY
FINES UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. CHOSE TO IMPLEMENT
WHAT THE STATE AUTHORIZED THEM.
KAREN SO EXISTING LAWS HAS A
LESSER FINE OR RESTITUTION IN.
WELL RIGHT NOW THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM AND
CURRENT LAW IS GENERALLY OF THE
SENATE AS THE AUTHOR OF THAT
THAT WILL BE WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR MAYBE UNDER SOME
OTHER THEORY- ANOTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL LIKE THAT
SHOULD BE ATTORNEY OR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CAN IN FOR SOME
PORTIONS OF THE LAW BUT IS
GENERALLY SOMETHING FORCING
RESPECT TO A TENANT WHO WOULD
RAISE THESE ISSUES AND THE FANS
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- AND IN DIFFERENT AND I'M
OFF A PAIR OF ONE OF. THE
THINGS THAT HAVE COME OUT. HE
IS HOW DO YOU GET OUT SOME OF
THE CRACK THAT OCCUR THE LOCAL
WHERE. THAT BEING THE ONLY
DEFENSE. IS OUT OF TO CRACK. BY
LANDLORDS. A TENANT REALLY DID
NOT AND POSITION TO STOP AND SO
I THINK THE CON HERE IS. TO
ALLOW GOVERNMENTS TO DO THAT
AND HAVE SOME OF THE REMEDIES
THAT THE- SEPARATELY WOULD
ALLOW. I'M TO BETTER IN COME
WITH THE LOCAL WHERE THEY KNOW
THE PRACTICES THAT ARE GOING ON
THAT YOU THAT LEVEL ENFORCEMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY TO YOU FOR
THE CLERK I JUST THE THAT THAT
THOSE FINAL CAUGHT ME OFF GUARD
I SHOULD THE MY DILIGENCE
BITTERNESS BUT- AYE AYE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FIRST
SECTION ON IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT CENTER
BUT- I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DEAL STRUCK LAST YEAR
IN THOSE FINAL PROVISION SO
MANY I WANT TO JUST KEEP AN EYE
ON HOW THAT LOOKS BEFORE THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU GET.
ALL RIGHT OF ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS- I THINK
THE TO DO LIST THIS BILL DOES
REFLECT THE NEED. MY EXPERIENCE
WITH UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTIONS
IS THEY AREN'T AS A MEDIA. AS
THE NEED IS THAT THEY CAN TAKE
MONTHS I KNOW LA COUNTY IT'S
NOTORIOUS. WITH THE SITUATION-
THAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCED UNDER
COVERT NINETEEN WHEN THE COURTS
TO GET BACK ALL THEY'RE GOING
TO BE DOING IS CRIMINAL CASES
OF FOR MONTHS IF NOT YEARS
BECAUSE OF THIS BACKLOG.
UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTIONS WILL
BE LACKING IN THE THEORY IS
THAT THEY ARE IMMEDIATELY
ENFORCEABLE AND IF THAT WERE
THE CASE I THINK THAT MY
CREATED DIFFERENT SITUATION BUT
THAT IS NOT THE REALITY SHOW.
WITH THAT. OUR MARRIAGE IS LESS.
MERIT BETTER FOR SOME SUSPECT
AT ANY RATE I'M SORRY SENATOR
BOARD JUST HAS HIS HAND RAISED
SENATOR BORCHERS MY APOLOGIES
FOR PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME YES INDEED
THANK YOU- JUST COURT JESTER.
JOINT CLARIFICATION SO I'M
LOOKING AT THE BILL AND IN THE
EXISTING LAW IT INDICATES THAT.
ALL I CAN IT IS ELIGIBLE YOU
THERE'S A RESTRAINING ORDER
INSPECTION A AND THEN IT GOES
ON SECTION BEING. REPORT BY
EIGHT PEACE OFFICER. THAT THE
TENANTS HAS FILED A REPORT.
SURE EXISTING LAW IT INDICATES
THAT A RECORD IS ALL THAT'S
NEEDED. AND THEN MOVING INTO
THE NEW SECTION. OF. SUBSECTION
SIX. THAT A CRIME THAT CAUSED
PHYSICAL INJURY OR EMOTIONAL
INJURY. I GUESS I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT. COULD THIS BE
ABUSE BY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
RELOCATE OR TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO CANCEL OUT
ON A LEASE WHETHER THEY'RE
COHABITANTS OR IN PARTNERSHIP
IN SOME FASHION. COULD THIS BE
ABUSE INSTEAD IS MY QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR UNDER A SCENARIO
WHERE. ONE PARTY. FILES A
REPORT. THAT SOUNDS WISE ONE
SECTION IN ALLEGES EMOTIONAL
INJURY. AND BY VIRTUE OF THOSE
TWO OCCURRENCES ARE LEAST IS
CAN BE BROKEN- THEREAFTER THE
AUTHORED THROUGH THE CHAIR OUR-
COMMENTS ON WHETHER THIS COULD
BE USED GIVEN THAT THERE SEEMS
TO BE. SOME ALL ENCOMPASSING
LANGUAGE. IF I MAY ARM IF YOU
LOOK AT A AMENDMENT ONE. IT TO
IT TIGHTENS UP OF THE LANGUAGE
WITH RESPECT TO CRIMES AND IT
ALSO REMOVES EMOTIONAL INJURY.
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT CREATE A
CLARITY. JOE MOTIONAL INJURY-
OR THREAT OF PHYSICAL INJURY
WERE TAKEN OUT. OF IT INCLUDES
NOW A CRIME THAT CAUSED BODILY
INJURY OR DEATH A CRIME THAT
INCLUDED THE EXHIBITION DRAWING
BRANDISHING OR USE OF A FIREARM
OR OTHER DEADLY WEAPON-
INSTRUMENT. A CRIME THAT
INCLUDED THE USE OF FORCE
AGAINST THE VICTIM OR THE
THREAT OF FORCE AGAINST THE
VICTIM SO WE HAVE SPECIFIED
MADE IT MUCH CLEARER. IN
REMOVED THE EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
ASPECT. OKAY THAT'S HELPFUL TO
KNOW AND THEN BUT THE EXISTING
PROVISION IS THAT ONLY A REPORT
NEEDS FILED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. NOT THAT IT THE
THREAT WAS TEAMS UBER OCCURRED.
I AM NOT SURE THAT THAT WE THAT
I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION BUT
BASICALLY WHEN YOU FILE A
POLICE REPORT IF YOU FILE A
FRAUDULENT POLICE REPORT THAT
IS A FELONY. SO AT LEAST FOR
THE LAST TIME I LOOKED SO OR AT
THE VERY LEAST SHOULD TO CRIME
TO DO THAT SO- AGAIN WE'RE
TRYING TO LIFT UP BAR SO IT
ISN'T JUST HE SAID SHE SAID
THERE HAS TO BE SOME
DEMONSTRATED SIGNIFICANT ACTION
TAKEN IN RESPONSE TO THAT CLAIM.
OF WHETHER IT'S SIR CRIME
HAVING BEENCOMMITTED WHETHER
IT'S- ALLEGATIONS. IF YOU GO TO
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT WITH THEM
AND YOU FILE A COMPLAINT. THAT
THE BIT IF THAT ISN'T ARE IN
AND OF ITSELF IS A SERIOUS ACT
WITH SIGNIFICANT LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES IF IT IS
FRAUDULENT WHICH I THINK
PROTECT YOUR CONCERN.THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION. VERY
GOOD WELL THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS IF THERE AREN'T
ANY- CENTER TO RUSSIA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BRIEFLY CLOSING WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION THANK YOU
AND NINETY CENTS FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MOVED TO THE
RIGHT MOTION BY SENATOR MORNING
THING MOTION IS TO PASS S.
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE PUT YOUR
MICROPHONES ON. MADAM SECRETARY
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SB ELEVEN NINETY.
JACKSON HI X. IN I DID ALSO I
IT ALSO I GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS
I JONES. AT NO. JONES NO
MONNING NINE MONNING AYE STERN.
UMBERG. WHY CAL SKI HI LIKE
HOUSE KEY I PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE EARNED. I'M BURKE. THE
VOTE IS. FIVE TWO ONE FIVE TWO
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES WE WILL
NOW GO BACK AND TO GO THROUGH
ALL OF THE- ITEMS WE'RE WE
STILL HAVE THE RULES OF OPEN.
VENTURE SENATOR JONES THEY WANT
THE I'M I THINK I'M DONE I'M ON
EVERYTHING THAT I WANT TO GO
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY GOOD JOB
TODAY. ON RUNNING THIS MEETING
WE WERE EXPECTING TO BE HERE
LATE- TODAY AND I KNOW WITH
THE- WITH THE CHALLENGES OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AYE I THOUGHT THE
YOU MANAGE THOSE VERY WELL. I
HOPE THAT EVERYBODY THAT WANTED
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAY SOMETHING
WAS ABLE TO ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ACCOMMODATING SENATOR
BARGES AT I THINK THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARY AND- GIVING HIM
THE ABILITY TO- PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING- HE'S OUR EXPERT ON
OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE ON ALL
THESE THINGS AND I JUST TRY TO
HANG ON TO HIS COATTAILS AS
BEST I CAN BUT- JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AND I. I THOUGHT
THAT THE MEETING WENT VERY WELL
TODAY THANK YOU CENTER JONES WE
ARE LIVING IN THE UNUSUAL TIMES
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
AND THE WORK OF ALL THE PEOPLE
HERE IN THIS FROM AND ALSO TO
THE GOOD SENATORS ON THIS DíAS
AND OUR STAFF- I HOPE EVERYBODY
DID GET TO BE HEARD WE DID OUR
BEST TECHNOLOGY ISN'T ALWAYS
PERFECT BUT- I THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS AND I THANK
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN HERE. SO
THAT LET'S GO TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE EVERYTHING WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO OPEN THE ROLES FOR A
NUMBER OF ITEMS FIRST WITH
START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND ADAM CHECKERED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M BURKE
BERG HI TO. EIGHT EIGHT TWO
ZERO THE CONCERN CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED FILE ITEM TO S. BEING
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT SENATOR Y.
CASKEY THAT YOU'RE VOTING I-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AT THE MISSION
ON THAT WAS DUE PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. JONES.
I'M BURKE. AMBERG I. FIVE SIX
SEVEN TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT- FILE ITEM
THREE SB NINE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA CHAIR VOTING I AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AT MOTION WAS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS I'M BURKE. ON
BERG I BY CASKEY HI I CASKEY I.
BUT SEVEN TWO ONE SEVEN TWO ONE
THE ITEM IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. BE AT NINE
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR WIENER
ARCHER VOTING I MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THAT MOTION WAS DEEP PASSES
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. STERN UMBERG.
FIVE TWO ONE FIVE TWO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB NINE EIGHTY BY SENATOR
NUMBER THE CHAIR VOTING HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THAT MOTION WAS DEEP PASSES
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS Y. CASCADE HIGH
AYE CASKEY I. THAT WOULD BE
SEVEN TO ONE SEVEN TWO ONE THAT
THE ITEM IS OUT FILE ITEM SIX.
BY SENATOR UMBERG SB NINE
NINETY NINE THE CHAIR VOTING I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MOTION WAS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. WHY CASKEY
HI THE CAST HE I. THAT SEVEN
TWO ONE SEVEN TWO ONE THAT ITEM
IS OUT AND THE FINAL ITEM- THAT
IS STILL OPEN IS FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR BRADFORD THE CHAIR
VOTING HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT MOTION WAS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. JONES WHY CAL SKI
HI. Y. CASKEY I. AT SEVEN TWO
ZERO SEVEN TWO ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT WE HAVE CONCLUDED OUR
PROCEEDINGS THANK YOU TO MYERS
AWESOME STAFF AND TO THE
AWESOME PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING
COLLEAGUES WE ARE JOURNAL.